SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY IS BEGINNING. WE ARE IN
ROOM 2200. I'M HOPING THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT, I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR
A ROLL CALL, JUST TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM FIRST. WAHAB HERE. WAHAB
HERE. SATO. SATO. HERE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE.
SKINNER. WIENER. THANK YOU.
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. I'D
LIKE TO GIVE A COUPLE OF ITEMS
FOR JUST ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE
25 BILLS ON THE CALENDAR TODAY.
SIX BILLS ARE ON CONSENT. THOSE
BILLS ARE AB 2531 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN AB, 1954 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS AB, 1972
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS AB,
2176 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
AB. 2730 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AND AB 2985 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART. I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT BEFORE WE DO HAVE BILL
PRESENTATIONS JUST FOR EVERYONE
TO UNDERSTAND. WE WILL HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SPEAK AT THIS
LECTERN AND MEET ISSUES AND LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION OR IN
SUPPORT. SPEAK AT THAT LECTERN,
WITNESSES. LEAD WITNESSES WILL
ONLY HAVE TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK,
EACH SPEAKER. AND THEN WE WILL
HAVE A SERIES OF ME TO ME, TWO
SPEAKERS SHOULD ANNOUNCE THEIR
NAME, THEIR ORGANIZATION, AND
ONLY WHETHER THEY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE, ONE OF THE BILLS. AND,
ANOTHER THING THAT WE JUST WANT
TO ANNOUNCE AGAIN IS THAT THE
RETAIL THEFT BILLS WILL BE HEARD
IN COMMITTEE TODAY IN ORDER.
OVERALL, AB 1779 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN AB 1794 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AB. 1802 BY JOAN
SAWYER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAN
SAWYER, AB 1960, BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SORIA AB 2943 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ZUBER AB 3209
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. WE
WILL BE HEARING THESE MEASURES
FIRST BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
REST OF THE AGENDA. ASSUMING
THAT THE AUTHORS ARE PRESENT,
THESE BILLS ARE BEING EXPEDITED
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND WILL BE
HEARD IN SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE NEXT WEEK. IN ORDER TO
AVOID ANY DELAYS, COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ADD IN AN
URGENCY CLAUSE SO THAT THEY MAY
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY UPON
APPROVAL OF THE GOVERNOR AND
INOPERABILITY CLAUSE, SO THAT IF
THE PROPOSED INITIATIVE, TITLED
THE HOMELESSNESS, DRUG ADDICTION
AND THEFT REDUCTION ACT, IS
APPROVED BY VOTERS IN THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION, WITH THAT
SAID, I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO
TAKE UP, ITEMS ON CONSENT FIRST.
DO I HAVE A MOTION? SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES CONSENT. CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? WAHAB? AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. SATO AYE. SATO. AYE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER.
WIENER. THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR VERY
FIRST BILL, AB 1779 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 1779, WHICH RETURNS AUTHORITY
TO DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO JOIN
CHARGES FOR MULTIPLE COUNTIES IN
ONE TRIAL WHEN PROSECUTING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT RINGS
OPERATING ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS. MOST
JURISDICTIONS, THE BILL IS PART
OF THE ASSEMBLY'S CALIFORNIA
TOGETHER AGAINST RETAIL CRIME
PACKAGE OF BILLS. ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT CONTINUES TO PLAGUE
OUR COMMUNITIES AND ITS
RESULTING FINANCIAL IMPACT
BURDENS NOT ONLY RETAILERS BUT
ALSO THE AVERAGE FAMILY TRYING
TO PURCHASE GOODS. WHILE I AM
PROUD TO HAVE REVIVED THIS
ABILITY TO JOIN CHARGES FROM
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN 2022, WE
HAVE HEARD FROM THE CHP AT THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION AND
FROM THE RETAILERS THAT THERE
ARE MORE MULTI-JURISDICTIONAL
CASES THAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS WILLING TO TAKE ON.
MEANING NOW IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME TO REVIVE THIS TOOL FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY PRIMARY WITNESS,
MICHELLE MICHELIN, FROM RACHEL
MICHELIN FOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU, SENATOR WAHAB, MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RACHEL
MICHELIN. I'M THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL 1779.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE VIDEOS
INDIVIDUALS WALKING INTO A STORE
AND CLEARING OUT A SHELF FULL OF
PRODUCTS INTO A GARBAGE BAG AND
RIDING OUT ON A BIKE. OR WHAT?
OR WHAT ABOUT THE THIEVES TAKING
ESSENTIAL ITEMS LIKE BABY
FORMULA, CROSSING COUNTY LINES
TO STEAL FROM MULTIPLE STORES
WHILE THREATENING RETAIL
EMPLOYEES, KNOWING IT WOULD BE
MORE DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE TO
THE FULL EXTENT OF THE LAW
BECAUSE PROSECUTORS CURRENTLY
LACK THE AUTHORITY FOR
MULTI-JURISDICTIONAL
PROSECUTIONS. RETAILERS, RETAIL
EMPLOYEES, AND CALIFORNIA
CUSTOMERS ARE FRUSTRATED WITH
SEEING RETAIL THEFT AND
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME HAPPENING
ALL AROUND THEM. WE MUST GIVE
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
PROSECUTORS THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO ADDRESS THESE SOPHISTICATED
CRIME RINGS AND HOLD THESE
ENTERPRISES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
CALIFORNIA PROSECUTORS
EFFECTIVELY UTILIZED CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL CHARGING BETWEEN
2019 AND 2021, AND WHILE IN 2022
THE STATE ALLOWED FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE PROSECUTING WITH THIS
TOOL, THE UNFORTUNATE FACT IS
RETAIL THEFT IS SO RAMPANT THAT
IN ORDER TO DETER IT FROM
INCREASING AND ENSURE OUR
BUSINESSES, EMPLOYEES AND
CUSTOMERS ARE SAFE FROM CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY, WE NEED TO RESTORE THE
ABILITY OF CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
CHARGING TO OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS THROUGH COLLABORATION
AMONG THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND RETAILERS
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M CONFIDENT
WE CAN BEGIN TO TACKLE THE
GROWTH OF RETAIL THEFT AWSY AND
BEGIN TO SEE SAFER RETAIL
ENVIRONMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THIS BILL BUILDS ON A
NUMBER OF LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
AS PART OF THE BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATIVE RETAIL THEFT PACKAGE
THAT TAKING COMPREHEND, WE COULD
HAVE MEANINGFUL IMPACTS ON
STOPPING THE GROWING THREAT OF
RETAIL THEFT AND ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME IN CALIFORNIA, AND
SENDS A SIGNAL THAT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE ISSUE OF
HOLDING REPEAT OFFENDERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR IS CHANGING. AB 1779
ENSURES CALIFORNIANS THAT WE
WILL NOT ALLOW CRIMINALS TO
CIRCUMVENT THE LAW BY CROSSING
COUNTY LINES TO AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
CRIMINAL ACTIONS. FOR THOSE
REASONS, I REQUEST YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES? OKAY, DO WE HAVE
LEAD OPPOSITION? SEEING NO LEAD
OPPOSITION? WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO. OKAY. WAIT. LEAD UP. DO
YOU? OKAY, SO ARE YOU LEAD
OPPOSITION? YES, YOUR HONOR.
OKAY TWO MINUTES, PLEASE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR WAHAB
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
SOOJUNG-KIM. I'M A DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDERS OFFICE,
PROVIDING RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AB 1779, WHICH WOULD ALLOW
CONSOLIDATION OF THEFT CHARGES
OCCURRING IN DIFFERENT COUNTIES
INTO A SINGLE TRIAL IF THE
DISTRICT, DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
ALL INVOLVED JURISDICTION AGREE
RETAIL THEFT PANIC WAS SPREAD BY
HIGHLY PUBLICIZED FALSE
STATEMENTS BY RETAILERS THAT
HAVE SINCE BEEN RETRACTED.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS EVIDENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS GROUNDED IN CREDIBLE
INFORMATION. AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER, I KNOW THAT THEFT IS
AN ACT OF DESPERATION. THÀNH AND
EFFORTS TO CURB THEFT MUST
ADDRESS ROOT CAUSES, INCLUDING
INVESTING IN MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S BASIC NEEDS AND
HOUSING. AB 1779 DOES NONE OF
THIS AND WILL LEAD TO
PROSECUTORIAL OVERREACH, UNJUST
CONVICTIONS AND A HUGE EXPENSE
TO CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYERS. 1779
WOULD ALLOW FOR CONSOLIDATION OF
THEFT CHARGES FROM DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS, EVEN IF THE
PROSECUTOR IN THE COUNTY IN
WHICH THE OFFENSE ALLEGEDLY
OCCURRED HAS ALREADY DETERMINED
THAT THE CHARGES ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE OR NOT IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE, OR WHERE
THE CHANGE OF VENUE WOULD HARM
THE INTERESTS OF VICTIMS.
WITNESSES AND DEFENDANTS. GIVING
LOCAL PROSECUTORS THE FINAL SAY
OVER CHARGING DECISIONS MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE ONE, A LOCAL
PROSECUTOR, CAN CONSISTENTLY
DETERMINE WHAT CHARGES, IF ANY,
ARE APPROPRIATE IN THEIR
JURISDICTION TWO FORCING
VICTIMS, WITNESSES AND
DEFENDANTS TO TRAVEL OUT OF
COUNTY CAN THREATEN THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AND ABILITY TO CARE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES, AND THREE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
UNDERSTANDABLY RELY ON THEIR
LOCAL ELECTED DA'S TO HANDLE
ALLEGED CRIMES THAT HAPPEN IN
THEIR JURISDICTION. DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE ELECTED COUNTY
WIDE TO REFLECT THE PRIORITIES
OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR DISREGARDING
THE WILL OF ONE ONE COUNTY'S
VOTERS BASED ON THE BIASES AND
POLICIES OF ANOTHER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ME TWOS. ME TWOS AGAIN.
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE. WE LIKE TO DO THIS PART
PRETTY QUICKLY, BRANDED UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING,
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA, ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY OF VENTURA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ETHAN NAGLER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF CARLSBAD
, CORONA, MERCED, RANCHO PALOS
VERDES, IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IN PRINT. THANK YOU. JULIANA
VOIGTS, ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
CHARREN MEMBERS CASSANDRA MÀ ON
BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. MADISON
D¯ÚI PAGOSA, WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF TARGET
CORPORATION. IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, BRENDA BASS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
PRISCILLA, KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT, AUSTIN, D¯ÚI, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. WE
SUPPORT THE BILL LANGUAGE IN
PRINT, BUT WILL RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL IF IT'S AMENDED
TO INCLUDE THE POISON PILL,
RENDERING IT INOPERABLE IF THE
VOTERS APPROVE. THANK YOU. JUST
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA RESERVE PEACE
OFFICERS AND THE PEACE OFFICER
ASSOCIATIONS OF ARCADIA, BURBANK
, CLAREMONT, CORONA, CULVER
CITY, FULLERTON, MARIETTA,
NEWPORT, NOVATO, PALOS VERDES,
POMONA, RIVERSIDE, AND UPLAND,
AND THE DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OF PLACER COUNTY.
WHILE WE SUPPORT THE BILL, WE
ARE ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. AGAIN. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR ME TO
STATE YOUR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE
REPRESENTING, AND AGAIN, SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE THE BILL. NO DETAILS.
THANK YOU, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING.
SENATOR SATO YEAH, I'LL PROVIDE
THE DETAILS, SO, AND THIS GOES
FOR ALL OF THE RETAIL THEFT,
BILLS THAT WE HAVE IS THAT THIS
IS BIPARTISAN. WHAT WAS
INTRODUCED IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL SUPPORT, ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
MENTIONED THEY HAD SEEN WE'VE
ALL SEEN THE VIDEOS FOR MULTIPLE
YEARS, AND YET THE EFFORTS OVER
THOSE MULTIPLE YEARS TO ADDRESS
IT WITH MANY BILLS THAT LOOK
JUST LIKE THESE HAVE BEEN
REBUFFED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
MOST OF THEM WOULD DIE IN PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEES, EITHER IN THE
SENATE OR THE ASSEMBLY. NOW WE
HAVE THESE BILLS. WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT THEY WOULD BE A
GIANT STEP AND HELPING UP,
HELPING OUT OUR, OUR RETAIL
THEFT ISSUE. AND, AND SOME OF
THE CRIME ISSUES BROUGHT ABOUT,
BY THE LACK OF RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE ARE SOME SHORTCOMINGS WITH
ONE OF THE PROPOSITIONS THAT
MOST OF THESE ARE BASED ON, ON
TRYING TO ADDRESS TYING THIS TO.
AND FINALLY, PEOPLE GOT SICK AND
TIRED OF IT. AND NOW THEY HAVE A
BALLOT PROPOSITION THAT AT THE
LAST MINUTE WE DECIDED TO TIE
ALL OF THESE TO, HEY, IF YOU
GUYS VOTE FOR THAT, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LET YOU DO THIS STUFF.
THAT'S CALLED POLITICAL GAMES.
WHEN WE BRING UP ALL OF THESE
FOUR MONTHS BEFORE AN ELECTION,
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THIS OVER
THE YEARS, LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO DO DESPERATELY, SOME
OF US ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE, I'VE HEARD BILLS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS GET KILLED OVER AND
OVER THAT ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS STUFF. SO IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS, WE WE'VE BEEN INTRODUCED
TO THIS CONCEPT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE, THE, IMMEDIATE, I MEAN,
MAKING THIS A 27 VOTE. ISSUE SO
THAT WE CAN IMMEDIATELY INVOKE
THESE THINGS. AND THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. BUT TELLING US THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE IT ALL AWAY, IF
YOU DARE VOTE FOR THIS
PROPOSITION COMING UP, WHICH IS
GOING TO REPEAL PROP 47, WHICH
STARTED THIS MESS, WE'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS IT, AND
WE HAVE NOT DONE IT. AND SO NOW
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
IS IT'S GOING TO GO TO THE IT'S
GOING TO GO TO THE VOTERS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO SPEAK. AND IF
THEY SAY YES, WE'LL WIPE THE
SLATE CLEAN AND WE CAN START
OVER. BUT A LOT OF THE START
OVER, IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
THESE BILLS. THIS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO BE PUT IN PLACE AND
IF THERE'S A CONFLICT JUST LIKE
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE BEFORE, IF
THERE IS A CONFLICT DOWN THE
ROAD, WE'LL GO AHEAD AND ADDRESS
IT AT THAT TIME. WE DO THAT WITH
BILLS ALL THE TIME. WE'RE WE'RE
DOING CLEAN UP LANGUAGE ON
BILLS. TWO YEARS AGO THAT WAS
INTRODUCED, KNOWING THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME ISSUES. WELL,
IF THERE ARE SOME CONFLICTING
ISSUES ABOUT ANY OF THESE BILLS
THAT ARE ARE SHOULD BE PASSING,
THEN WE'LL TAKE CARE OF IT AT
THE TIME TO TIE THIS TO PROP 47,
THE REPEAL OF PROP 47 IN THE
FALL IS A POLITICAL GIMMICK.
IT'S A GAME AND I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE PLAYING IT. I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE TAKING THESE
REALLY GOOD BILLS AND TYING THIS
ANCHOR TO IT TO TRY TO TELL
PEOPLE THAT, HEY, IF YOU VOTE
FOR THIS, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE ALL THIS AWAY FROM YOU
AND THE OTHER PART OF THIS I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IS WHAT'S TO SAY
IN JANUARY WHEN WE RECONVENE A
NEW SESSION, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
REPEAL EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE. IF 47, IT FAILS. IF THE
REPEAL OF PROP 47 FAILS. SO THIS
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT. I WANT
TO VOTE FOR THESE, BUT IF IT HAS
THOSE, AMENDMENTS IN IT, I'M
GOING TO BE LAYING OFF UNTIL THE
DUST SETTLES ON THIS AND WE GET
IT TO THE FLOOR OR
APPROPRIATIONS. SO MY QUESTION,
I DON'T KNOW IF THE AUTHOR KNOWS
THIS, BUT IT WAS KIND OF
MENTIONED. ARE THOSE AMENDMENTS
APPLYING TO ALL OF THESE NOW,
HAVE THESE BEEN AMENDED TO
INCLUDE THAT LANGUAGE? THE
AMENDMENTS, IF THE AMENDMENTS
ARE TAKEN, THEY WILL BE TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS. THIS IS SO YOU
SAID THIS IS A GOOD BILL WITHOUT
I KNOW IT IS. SO NOW YOU CAN
VOTE FOR IT BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENTS AREN'T IN THERE.
YEAH, BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
TAKEN UP IN APPROPRIATIONS. WE
SHOULD KNOW THIS AHEAD OF TIME.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE TAKEN UP IN
APPROPRIATIONS. APPROPRIATIONS
FOR ALL OF YOU THAT DON'T ATTEND
THAT. AND I SIT ON, WORKS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. THERE'S
NOT A WHOLE LOT OF IT SPEAKS TO
THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF IT. SO
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE POLICY THEN? SO THAT'S A
GREAT PLACE TO TAKE THIS UP. SO
MY OPINION IS THIS PROCESS, WHAT
HAS HAPPENED NOW IS CRAP. AND SO
I'M GOING TO BE LAYING OFF UNTIL
IT IS FIGURED OUT. IF IT COMES
UP IN APPROPRIATIONS, I WILL
VOTE NO ON THIS BECAUSE WE DON'T
NEED GAMES. WE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR RETAILERS. WE NEED TO DO
THAT NOW. THAT'S A GREAT IDEA.
BUT TYING THIS TO THAT IN THE
VOTE IN NOVEMBER AND HOLDING
PEOPLE HOSTAGE ON THAT, THAT'S
RIDICULOUS. SO SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PEOPLE WHO WORKED
HARD AND AGREED TO TAKE THESE UP
. BUT NOW THAT WE'RE PLAYING
LAST MINUTE GAMES, I'M GOING TO
BE, I'M GOING TO BE LAYING OFF.
SO THANK YOU. WOULD ANY OTHER
MEMBER LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM? SENATOR SKINNER
. THANK YOU. CHAIR, ARTHUR, I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS TO
US. AND JUST IN RESPONSE,
OBVIOUSLY OUR COLLEAGUE, SOME
MEMBER, SATO FEELS PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS. HOWEVER, I THINK
THERE'S, UNFORTUNATELY, GAMES
THAT ARE PLAYED IN, BY MANY
PARTIES TO TRY TO GET SUPPORT
FOR THEIR PARTICULAR,
ACTIVITIES. AND IF WE LOOK AT
THE INITIATIVE HE'S REFERENCING,
IT HAS LITTLE TO NOTHING TO DO
WITH RETAIL THEFT. AND YET IT'S
GOING TO BE, OR GOING TO BE IT
IS NOW BEING, PRESENTED AS IF
IT'S A SOLUTION, WHEN IN FACT,
THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE, NOT ONLY
THE BILL THAT'S BEING PRESENTED
NOW BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN,
BUT MANY MORE IN THE PACKAGE ARE
WILL REALLY GET AT THE HEART OF
DEALING WITH THE PROBLEM OF
RETAIL THEFT. AND THE RETAILERS
APPRECIATE THAT THE RETAILERS
ARE CLEAR THAT THESE BILLS ARE
MORE IMPORTANT. AND SO, THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT MESSAGE TO SEND
TO THE PROPONENTS THAT YOU
CANNOT USE PHONY MESSAGING WHEN
YOU IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
PRESENT SOMETHING, DO NOT USE
PHONY MESSAGING. AND, WITH THAT,
I WILL MOVE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU, I SPECIFICALLY ALSO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT, AS PART OF
THE LEGISLATION, DÍAS EFFORT TO
TACKLE THE ISSUE AROUND RETAIL
THEFT AND FENTANYL, BOTH HOUSES
OR, COORDINATING TO MOVE OUR
RESPECTIVE PACKAGES QUICKLY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WITH THE HOPES OF GETTING THESE
14 BILLS ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK,
BEFORE RECESS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY, WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE PUBLIC WANTS. I DO ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT, YOU
KNOW, REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
RETAILERS HAVE SPOKEN IN
SUPPORT. SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT
AND THEIR EFFORT WORKING WITH US
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE AND BALANCED POLICY
PACKAGE, THAT CAN BE, YOU KNOW,
VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. AND I WILL SAY
THAT I HAVE SAT ON, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE FENTANYL WORKING GROUP ON
THE SENATE FOR OVER NINE MONTHS,
SPEAKING TO STAKEHOLDERS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, DA'S AND HEALTH
EXPERTS TO REALLY TACKLE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE ARE SEEING
IN OUR SOCIETY. SO SO,
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE THAT WE
APPROPRIATELY ADVANCE THESE
PRIORITIES, BOTH HOUSES WILL BE
ADDING AMENDMENTS. IT WAS STATED
EARLIER IN THE, BEGINNING OF
THIS MEETING IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO THESE BILLS TO
INCLUDE THE URGENCY CLAUSE, AND
AN INOPERABLE CLAUSE SHOULD THE
INITIATIVE THAT IS CIRCULATING,
YOU KNOW, MOVE FORWARD. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THESE BILLS
ACTUALLY DO FOCUS ON THE ISSUES
THAT ARE CONFRONTING THE
RETAILERS, THE SMALL MOM AND POP
SHOPS, AND MUCH MORE. SO, I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT, OF
COURSE, YOU KNOW, THE SENATE AS
WELL AS I'M SURE THE ASSEMBLY IS
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. SO I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO CLOSE AND WE CAN MOVE ON.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JUST REALLY QUICKLY TO ANSWER
FROM THE OTHER OPPOSITION, A
COUPLE OF POINTS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP, FIRST OF ALL, AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE, THE AG HAS HAD
THIS ABILITY FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS WITH A BILL THAT WE DID,
AND THEY ARE OVERWHELMED RIGHT
NOW. SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO BRING
DAS INTO THE EQUATION. AND WE
DID TAKE AN AMENDMENT TO REQUIRE
THE PERMISSION OF LOCAL DAS.
WHEN YOU DO THIS CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL PROSECUTION. SO
WE'VE BEEN LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION ON BOTH SIDES. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
VOTE AB 1779. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB
A WAHAB I SEYARTO VOTING. SATO
NOT VOTING BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
SKINNER I SKINNER I WIENER THAT
BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO AB 1794 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU. SO I CAN GO OVER TO
OUR ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IN A SECOND AND HEAR
SOME OF YOUR BILLS. THIS AGAIN
IS PART OF OUR PACKAGE. AND TO
ADDRESS THE SENATOR FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE. THIS IS AN AS IS
BILL DOESN'T HAVE THE INOPERABLE
LANGUAGE. AND THAT'S FOR ANOTHER
DAY. BUT TODAY IS THIS BILL. AND
SO WE'RE ALL ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF RETAIL
THEFT. I SEE IT LOUD AND CLEAR
IN MY DISTRICT, AND I'M STRUCK
BY THE ISSUE THAT WE HEAR A LOT
FROM THE BIG BOX RETAILERS. YOU
KNOW, THE TARGETS, THE WALMARTS,
THE AND THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT, THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
OWNED BY, YOU KNOW, WALL STREET
ENTITIES. BUT THE MAIN STREET
STORES, THE GROCERS THAT ARE
OWNED BY, YOU KNOW, FAMILIES AND
FAMILIES THAT WORK 100 HOURS A
WEEK AND THEY'RE IMPACTED AND
SOMETIMES THEY'RE IT'S A DEATH
BY A THOUSAND CUTS. AND I REALLY
THINK THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
HELPING OUR SMALLER RETAILERS AS
WELL AS OUR, OUR LARGER
RETAILERS. AND SO THIS AGAIN IS
PART OF THE PACKAGE OF BILLS
HERE TODAY ESSENTIALLY DOES TWO
THINGS. IT CLARIFIES ALONG WITH
THE COMPANION BILL FROM THE
SPEAKER AND MR. BYRNE, A FEW
SECONDS ABOUT AGGREGATION. ALLOW
US AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO FOCUS
ON CRIMES OF MULTIPLE VICTIMS
AND MULTIPLE VENUES. AND THEN
SECONDLY, STREAMLINES THE
PROCESS FOR REPORTING
SHOPLIFTING INCIDENTS DIRECTLY
TO PROSECUTORS FROM RETAILERS
BASED UPON A YOLO COUNTY MODEL.
WE HEAR FROM A SECOND CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA FAST PASS. THIS
INNOVATIVE APPROACH HERE ACROSS
THE RIVER IN YOLO COUNTY HAS
SERVED AS A GREAT APPROACH,
ALLOWING MORE COLLABORATION
DIRECTLY FROM RETAILERS, SHOP
OWNERS AND THE DA'S TO BRING
ABOUT MORE SWIFT ACTION AND
FOCUS ON ACCOUNTABILITY. AGAIN,
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES? IF THE
LEAD WITNESS WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT AT THIS LECTERN, YOU
WILL BE TIMED AT TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS PRESTON SCHAUB. I'M A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN YOLO
COUNTY, AND I'M THE LEAD
ATTORNEY OVERSEEING OUR FAST
PASS PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS FAST
PASS, WHICH ALLOWS RETAILERS TO
DIRECTLY FILE AND REPORT THEFT
TO OUR OFFICE WITHOUT RELYING ON
A LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE. WE
DEVELOPED THIS MODEL BACK IN
2023 TO ADDRESS TRENDS THAT WE
NOTICED THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
INCLUDING UNDERREPORTING,
LIMITED LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE
, AND PROSECUTORS NOT HAVING THE
COMPLETE INFORMATION NECESSARY
AT THE TIME OF FILING, BY
ALLOWING THE RETAILERS TO REFER
CASES DIRECTLY TO OUR OFFICE,
WE'RE PROVIDING THEM WITH A PATH
TO PRIORITIZE THEIR MOST
PROLIFIC OFFENDERS. WE HAVE
GRANTED OUR RETAIL PARTNERS THE
ABILITY TO UPLOAD THEIR REPORTS
AND EVIDENCE DIRECTLY TO OUR
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM, JUST AS
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS DOING IT.
THESE REFERRALS ARE THEN
FORWARDED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
THEY CAN PROPERLY TRACK THE DATA
OF THE THEFT OCCURRING IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. WE HAVE CRITERIA
FOR WHICH OFFENSES QUALIFY FOR A
FAST PASS REFERRAL, AND ONCE THE
REFERRAL IS RECEIVED BY OFFICE,
OUR ATTORNEYS REVIEW THE CASE
FOR CHARGING. IF WE FILE IT, IT
PROCEEDS THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE SAME WAY ANY
TRADITIONAL CASE WOULD. FROM
AUGUST 2023. TO DATE, WE HAVE
RECEIVED 65 FAST PASS REFERRALS
RELATING TO 75 SUBJECTS. THESE
REFERRALS TOTALED JUST UNDER
$165,000 WORTH OF STOLEN GOODS.
AND SO FAR, WE HAVE RESOLVED 18
CASES WITH A TOTAL VALUE OF
ABOUT $70,000 WORTH OF STOLEN
GOODS. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
MODEL, WHEN PAIRED WITH
TRADITIONAL REPORTING, IS AN
EFFICIENT USE OF RESOURCES THAT
REDUCES, DELAYS AND HOLDS PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE FULL EXTENT
OF THEIR CONDUCT. AND AGAIN,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS, I CAN
ANSWER THEM. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD WITNESSES
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO LEAD WITNESS OPPOSITION OR
OPPOSITION. YES. TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON, A VOLUNTEER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION, ALONG WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE, IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AB 1794. WE ALWAYS MUST BE
VIGILANT WHEN DISCUSSING
STREAMLINING THE CRIMINAL SYSTEM
. WE CANNOT ROLL OVER
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS IN THE
NAME OF MAKING THINGS EASIER FOR
THE SYSTEM. THIS BILL, IF A
COUNTY ADOPTED SUCH A PROGRAM,
WOULD PERMIT RETAILERS AND NO
ONE ELSE TO HAVE DIRECT ACCESS
TO DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND SUBMIT
CASES TO BE FILED THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN INVESTIGATED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THIS ASPECT OF THE
BILL IS NOT ONLY UNFAIR, BUT
WOULD RAISE POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS. IT WOULD PERMIT
RETAILERS WITH SIGNIFICANT MEANS
TO PRESSURE DAS TO FILE CASES
AND CREATE A TWO TIERED SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE, WHERE POWERFUL
RETAILERS MAY SUBMIT CASES FOR
PROSECUTION THAT ARE NOT FULLY
INVESTIGATED. IT WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE SPECIAL TREATMENT TO
RETAILERS THAT NO ONE ELSE IN
THE CRIMINAL SYSTEM HAS. HAS.
THIS BILL INACCURATELY DESCRIBES
THAT IT IS DECLARATIVE OF
EXISTING LAW. IT IS NOT EXISTING
LAW REQUIRES PROOF THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL SPECIFICALLY INTENDED
TO PERMANENTLY DEPRIVE THE OWNER
OF PROPERTY. THE LAW IS CLEAR Ã
THEFT IS NOT COMMITTED WITHOUT
PROOF OF SPECIFIC INTENT. THIS
BILL APPEARS TO SUGGEST THAT
THEFT COULD BE COMMITTED IF A
PERSON IMPULSIVELY, WITHOUT
SPECIFIC INTENT, COMMITS A
THEFT. THIS IS SIMPLY NOT THE
LAW. SEN SATIONAL CLAIMS ABOUT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT, RUNNING
RAMPANT HAVE BEEN DEBUNKED, AND
DATA SHOWS THAT RETAIL THEFT IS
NOT RISING STATEWIDE. WE MUST
RESPOND TO OUR PROBLEMS,
COMMUNITY CONCERNS AND LOCAL
BUSINESSES. TWO MINUTES WITH
REAL. THANK YOU. LEAD
OPPOSITION. ANYBODY ELSE? YES.
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS KELLY WALTERS. I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. AND I'VE COME HERE
TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
1794, LIKE SO MANY OTHER
SOCIETAL PANICS, RETAIL THEFT
PANIC HAS BEEN FUELED BY HIGHLY
PUBLICIZED AND LATER RETRACTED
STATEMENTS BY MAJOR RETAILERS
FOR INSTANCE, THE NATIONAL
RETAIL FEDERATION ONCE CLAIMED
THAT ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY HALF OF
ALL INVENTORY LOSSES IN 2021, A
STATEMENT THEY LATER ADMITTED
WAS BASED ON INCORRECT DATA.
SIMILARLY, THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED THE LACK OF
COMPREHENSIVE, RELIABLE DATA ON
THEFT CLAIMS BY CORPORATIONS
LIKE WALGREENS AND TARGET ABOUT
CLOSING STORES DUE TO RETAIL
THEFT HAVE BEEN CONTRADICTED BY
EVIDENCE SHOWING THEY KEPT OTHER
NEARBY STORES WITH HIGHER
INCIDENCE OF CRIME OPEN,
SUGGESTING FINANCIAL STRUGGLES
RATHER THAN THEFT AS THE PRIMARY
REASON FOR CLOSURES. THE BILL
PERMITS COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH
PROGRAMS ALLOWING RETAILERS TO
REPORT SHOPLIFTING INCIDENTS
DIRECTLY TO THE COUNTY. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THROUGH AN ONLINE
PORTAL UNTIL JANUARY 1ST, 2030,
A PIPELINE THAT IS NOT PROVIDED
TO VICTIMS OF PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. THIS PROVISION RAISES
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR BIASED REPORTING,
LACK OF OVERSIGHT WHICH COULD
LEAD TO WRONGFUL PROSECUTIONS,
AND FURTHER STRAIN ON THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
INCREASED PENALTIES FOR LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES LIKE SHOPLIFTING
WILL DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
COMMUNITIES ALREADY TARGETED BY
SYSTEMATIC RACISM, MAINLY BLACK
AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS. IN SAN
FRANCISCO, BLACK PEOPLE ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE THE USE OF FORCE BY
POLICE, BE ARRESTED AND BOOKED
INTO JAIL, AND CONVICTED OF
CRIMES. COMPARED TO WHITE
INDIVIDUALS, SUCH POLICIES
EXACERBATE RACIAL DISPARITIES
AND CONTRIBUTE TO MASS
INCARCERATION, MOVING US FURTHER
FROM ACHIEVING EQUITABLE JUSTICE
. AB 1794 CODIFIES THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CAN COMBINE
THE VALUE OF MULTIPLE THEFTS,
EVEN UNRELATED ONES, TO MEET THE
$950 THRESHOLD FOR A FELONY
CHARGE. ONE OF THE PRIMARY
FACTORS CONSIDERED IS WHETHER
THE DEFENDANT USED A SINGLE
METHOD TO COMMIT THESE THEFTS.
GIVEN THE LIMITED WAYS PROPERTY
CAN BE TAKEN FROM A STORE. THIS
CRITERION. THANK YOU. TWO
MINUTES IS DONE. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ME TO BOTH IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE DANICA.
RADAMEL ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND VERA INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. SARAH PALERMO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. CRYSTAL
CROSS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BEVERLY HILLS IN SUPPORT.
JULIE NAVAS, ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT. ETHAN NAGLER I'M HALF
THE CITY OF RANCHO PALOS VERDES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN PRINT.
GOOD MORNING, BRENDA BASS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. CASSANDRA
MÀ WITH THE CITY OF DOWNEY AND
THE TOWN OF APPLE VALLEY IN
SUPPORT. DAN FELIZARDO WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN SHERM WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. NARCOTIC
OFFICERS AND THE OTHER POWS AND
DSA'S PREVIOUSLY STATED IN
SUPPORT BUT OPPOSED TO THE
INOPERABILITY APPRECIATE IT.
THAT'S OUR POSITION ON THOSE
THINGS. THANK YOU. JIM LINDBERG,
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA, OPPOSED. HEROIN.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS OF
CHILDREN, AS WELL AS ALL OF US
ARE NONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ANYBODY? I'LL SPEAK
ON ONE THING. OKAY SENATOR
SARAH, THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU
FOR CARRYING THIS PARTICULAR
BILL, IT IS A VERY GOOD BILL AS
IT IS PRINTED RIGHT NOW. AND MY
COMMENTS FROM BEFORE STILL
STAND. WE SAW A VERY SIMILAR
BILL TO THIS TWO YEARS AGO. I
THINK I WAS ONE OF THE ONLY ONES
TO VOTE FOR IT, AND THEN IT GOT
KILLED, SO I'M GLAD TO SEE IT
BACK, IN A FORM THAT WILL BE
HELPFUL TO RETAILERS. BUT AGAIN,
I'M GOING TO BE HOLDING OFF
UNTIL WE GET THIS. THE ENTIRE
BILL WITH ALL THE AMENDMENTS IN
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHER MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH.
THANK YOU, ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS, JUST ONE
QUICK ISSUE. IT'S BEEN STATED
THAT IT'S UNCERTAIN HOW MUCH
RETAIL THEFT WE HAVE, ESPECIALLY
RELATED TO OUR BIG BOX
RETAILERS. AND I HAVE NO PROBLEM
DEFENDING OUR BIG BOX RETAILERS.
AND IT'S AN ISSUE FOR EVERYBODY.
I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU A QUICK
LITTLE STORY, A FEW WEEKS AGO I
WENT TO MY DISTRICT. IT WAS HOT
NIGHT. I WANTED TO PULL OVER AND
GET LITERALLY A GATORADE, GOING
TO A COMMUNITY MEETING. IT WAS
THE REAL END OF MARKET ON RIO
LINDA BOULEVARD, ABOUT THREE
MILES FROM HERE. AND I ASKED THE
GUY, YOU KNOW, IS THIS YOUR
STORE? HE SAYS, YEAH. HE SAID, I
WORK HERE 100 HOURS A WEEK, SO
IT'S HIS STORE. AND I SAID, YOU
KNOW, THIS THING, RETAIL THEFT.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU SEE IT? AND HE
SAID, EVERY DAY, EVERY DAY. SO
THE NOTION ABOUT HYPING HE
DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I JUST STARTED CHATTING
WITH THIS GUY AND I SAID, WHAT
DO YOU DO? AND HE LOOKED OVER
HERE BEHIND HIS COUNTER AND HE
HAD A BASEBALL BAT OVER THERE.
AND HE SAID, IT DEPENDS. IT
DEPENDS. THAT'S NOT A SOLUTION.
SO THIS IS AN THIS IS A THING
THAT IMPACTS ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND I CARE ABOUT
OUR BIG BOX RETAILERS. BUT THESE
LITTLE STORES THAT HAVE HUGE
IMPACT ON THEM, I CARE A LOT
ABOUT THEM TOO. AND SO WE NEED
TO HAVE FAIR AND BALANCED
SOLUTIONS THAT THAT ANSWER THE
CALL. AND I THINK THIS IS WHAT
WE DID JUST HERE IN THIS BILL.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO I
HAVE A MOTION? SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES THE BILL. LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. AB 1794. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WILL HAVE A I
CIERTO CIERTO NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
WIENER THAT BILLS ON CALL, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB 18 ZERO
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES.
SAWYER. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 1802, WHICH WILL
ELIMINATE THE SUNSETS ON THE
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
PROPERTY CRIMES TASK FORCE. IN
2017, I AUTHORED Ã AB 1065,
WHICH ACTUALLY CREATED THE CRIME
OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT, WHICH
MAKES IT THE OG OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT BILLS. AB YES,
YOU'RE THE SECOND OG AB 1065.
ALSO ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL PROPERTY CRIMES
TASK FORCE, WHICH TO DATE HAS
RECOVERED OVER $30 MILLION IN
STOLEN GOODS THIS YEAR. I'VE
AUTHORED 1802 TO ELIMINATE THE
SUNSET FROM MY ORIGINAL BILL AND
MAKE THE CRIME OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT AND THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY TASK FORCE PERMANENT
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO THE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
TOOLS WE HAVE IN DEALING WITH
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. AND MORE
IMPORTANT, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
HAVING EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES,
THIS IS WHAT A SHINING EXAMPLE
OF WHAT CAN BE DONE. BECAUSE NOT
ONLY DOES IT GO TO THE ROOT OF
TACKLING THE CRIMINALS ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT, IT ALSO PROVIDES
OFF RAMPS AND DIVERSION PROGRAMS
FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED IT. UNLIKE
THE CURRENT BILL INITIATIVE, AB
1802 IS PART OF A PACKAGE OF
BILLS THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
WITHOUT REGRESSING TO THE KIND
OF POLICY THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES. THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS PACKAGE AIM
TO STRIKE A BALANCE TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T END UP WITH CONFLICTING
OUTCOMES, AND ALLOW LAWMAKERS TO
REASSESS SHOULD THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE PASS. AB 1802 WILL
ENSURE THE LAW THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS THE NECESSARY
MEANS TO ARREST AND PROSECUTE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT RINGS AND
CONTINUE TO DISRUPT THE LIFE AND
THEIR LIFE IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
I'M PROUD TO CONTINUE MY LEGACY
OF WORK WITH THIS BILL AND
CEMENT AND PERMANENTLY CEMENT
THE CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT IN CALIFORNIA. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS DAN FELICIANO. ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL'S SPONSOR, LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY GEORGE
GASCON. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE, A RECENT STUDY BY THE
NATIONAL RETAIL FEDERATION FOUND
THAT ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT HAS
INCREASED BY OVER 26% SINCE
2021. CONTRARY TO THE OPINION OF
SOME, ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT IS
NOT A VICTIMLESS CRIME. IT HARMS
OUR COMMUNITIES SENSE OF SAFETY
AND SECURITY WHILE SHOPPING, AND
IT HARMS LOCAL BUSINESSES
ABILITY TO STAY IN BUSINESS. ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT TOOLS WE
HAVE TO COMBAT ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT IS OUR ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT STATUTE, WHICH MAKES IT A
WOBBLER FOR AN ORGANIZED GROUP
OF TWO OR MORE PERSONS TO STEAL
GOODS FROM A MERCHANT WITH THE
INTENT TO SELL, EXCHANGE OR
RETURN THE GOODS FOR VALUE. LAST
YEAR, OUR OFFICE FILED OVER 500
CASES USING CALIFORNIA'S
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT STATUTE.
THE MAJORITY OF THESE CASES
INVOLVED MULTIPLE DEFENDANTS.
OUR OFFICE ALSO WORKED WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGIONAL
ORGANIZED TASK FORCE TO RECOVER
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN STOLEN
GOODS, WHICH WERE RETURNED TO
THE RETAILERS IN 2020. OUR
OFFICE FILED 95 CRIMINAL CASES
CHARGING ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT,
78 FELONIES AND 17 MISDEMEANORS
LAST YEAR, THAT NUMBER HAD
INCREASED TO 541 CASES, 434
FELONY CASES AND 107 MISDEMEANOR
FILINGS. RETAIL THEFT IS A
PROBLEM THAT NOT ONLY AFFECTS
MERCHANTS, BUT IT AFFECTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEIR LOCAL,
RETAIL STORES ARE FORCED TO
CLOSE, OVER 80% OF THE THEFTS,
ARE COMMON GOODS. THIS IS WHY IT
IMPACTS EVERYBODY. WE ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. LET'S
MOVE ON TO ANOTHER, LEAD
WITNESS. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ME TO'S. ME
TWOS AGAIN. STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION. WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. AND KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO JUST THOSE THREE
SARAH PALERMO, CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT BRENDA BASS, CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
JULIAN ALVAREZ, CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND SUPPORT, MADISON,
DWELLEY POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON
BEHALF OF TARGET IN SUPPORT
CASSANDRA MÀ ON BEHALF OF THE
TOWN OF APPLE VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
ETHAN NAGLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF CARLSBAD, MERCED,
REDWOOD CITY, AND RANCHO PALOS
VERDES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IN PRINT. AUSTIN DEUEL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL, IN PRINT
AND IN OPPOSITION TO THE POISON
PILL AMENDMENTS. GOOD MORNING,
CHIARA ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF STOCKTON IN SUPPORT.
PRISCILLA, KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT. BRIAN SHERMAN OF THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION,
NARCOTICS AND THE PREVIOUS
OPPOSE DSA'S IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND OPPOSE OPERABILITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOLLOWING
DIRECTIONS, SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
TURN THE CONVERSATION ON OVER TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SEEING NONE.
PLEASE CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION? Þ SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES THE BILL. CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? AB 1802, MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WILL HAVE A I CIERTO CIERTO NOT
VOTING. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE WIENER
THAT BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBER
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBER IS GOING
TO PRESENT AB 2943. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO SERVE AS A
JOINT AUTHOR WITH, ALONG WITH
SPEAKER RIVAS ON THIS BILL. AB
2943 THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL THEFT
REDUCTION ACT. THIS BILL IS A
PRIMARY COMPONENT OF A BROADER,
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY AND
PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT ADVANCES
BALANCED, EFFECTIVE, AND
MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS TO RETAIL
CRIME AND ENDEAVORS TO PRESERVE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS THAT
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE AT KEEPING
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE. WE
ENDEAVOR TO ACHIEVE CONSENSUS
WHEREVER POSSIBLE, AND THE
PROPOSALS IN THIS BILL ARE AN
OUTGROWTH OF THE WORK OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
RETAIL THEFT, WHICH HAS HELD TWO
COMPREHENSIVE HEARINGS FEATURING
A RANGE OF EXPERT PERSPECTIVES
AND THE PRODUCT OF EXTENSIVE
ENGAGEMENT AMONG THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE, THE SENATE LEADERSHIP
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, AND
WITH POLICY EXPERTS AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
RETAILERS, WORKERS, CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ADVOCATES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AT THOSE HEARINGS,
WE REVIEWED THE FACTS AND
FIGURES, AND WE HEARD THAT THE
DATA IS MIXED IN SOME PLACES
SHOPLIFTING AND OVERALL CRIME
ARE GOING DOWN. IN OTHER PLACES,
IT'S GOING UP. WE'RE ALSO SEEING
MORE AND MORE STORES LOCKING UP
THEIR INVENTORY AND REPORTING
INCREASING LOSS RELATED TO
RETAIL CRIME. WE'VE HEARD FROM
RETAILERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT RETAIL CRIME IS A VERY
REAL, ONGOING CHALLENGE IN THEIR
STORES. WE HEARD FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT THE RESOURCES
AND REFORMS THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING THE
COMMUNITY. WE LEARNED ABOUT
DIVERSION PROGRAMS, HOW
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND THAT ONE OF THE
AREAS WE SHOULD FOCUS ON IS
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES AND
ENFORCEMENT. WE HEARD THAT THE
BEST DETERRENCE IS NOT GOING
BACK TO LONG PRISON TERMS, BUT
INSTEAD ENSURING A REASONABLE
LIKELIHOOD OF APPREHENSION AND
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES WHEN
SOMEONE IS ARRESTED. WE HEARD
THAT RETAIL CRIME IS AN
EMOTIONAL ISSUE FOR MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. BUSINESS OWNERS
FEAR FOR THEIR LIVELIHOODS,
WORKERS FEAR FOR THEIR
WELL-BEING, AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WORRY THAT IT MAY BE NO
LONGER SAFE OR CONVENIENT TO
FREQUENT THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
STORES. THE CONCERN AND FEAR IN
OUR COMMUNITIES IS REAL, AND WE
MUST ACT WITH URGENCY. WE MUST
ALSO LOOK TO AT THE FACTS AND
FIND SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY WORK. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PURSUING REFORMS
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE AT TARGETING
RETAIL CRIME, WHILE AVOIDING A
WHOLESALE ROLLBACK OF REFORMS
THAT WORK TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER, AND AVOIDING
IMPRISONING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE FOR MINOR INFRACTIONS OR
ACTS OF SURVIVAL. ALL THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS INFORM THIS BILL
AND THE ASSEMBLY RETAIL'S CRIME
PACKAGE THAT WAS ANNOUNCED BY
THE SPEAKER IN APRIL. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LAY OUT THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL, EACH OF
WHICH CAN BE ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED INTO LAW
WITH OR WITHOUT VOTER APPROVAL.
ORGANIZED CRIME RINGS HAVE
CAUSED VERY REAL AND VISIBLE
HARM IN OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. SO FIRST, AB 2943
PLACES GREAT EMPHASIS ON
STOPPING ORGANIZED CRIME RINGS
BY CREATING A NEW CRIME
TARGETING SERIAL RETAIL THIEVES.
THOSE THAT ENGAGE IN REPEATED,
SPECIFIED CONDUCT, OR WHO
POSSESS A QUANTITY OF GOODS
INCONSISTENT WITH PERSONAL USE
AND THE INTENT TO RESELL. AND
THIS AND OTHER COMPONENTS
ADVANCE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
RELEASED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. THIS BILL ALSO MORE
SPECIFICALLY DEFINES HOW THE
VALUE OF THEFT, HOW THE VALUE OF
THEFTS FROM DIFFERENT VICTIMS
CAN BE AGGREGATED TO CHARGE
GRAND THEFT. NOTABLY, THE BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE LAW THAT THE
INTENT STANDARD CAN BE MET BY
EVIDENCE THAT THE ACTS INVOLVED
THE SAME DEFENDANTS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR AND OCCUR
WITHIN A 90 DAY PERIOD. AB 2943
ALSO EXPANDS THE TOOLS FOR
POLICE TO ARREST, FOR
SHOPLIFTING, AND TO KEEP REPEAT
OFFENDERS AND THOSE COMMITTING
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME IN
CUSTODY, WHILE ALSO
INCORPORATING GUARDRAILS AGAINST
FRIVOLOUS OR DELAYED ARRESTS. IT
PROTECTS BUSINESSES FROM HAVING
NUISANCE ACTIONS BROUGHT AGAINST
THEM SIMPLY FOR REPORTING
LEGITIMATE RETAIL CRIME
INCIDENTS. AND SIGNIFICANTLY,
THIS BILL HELPS ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THEFT BY EXPANDING THE
USE OF DIVERSION AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS,
OFFERING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
EARLY DISCHARGE IF PROGRAMS ARE
COMPLETED AND AGAIN, I WANT TO
THANK THE PRO TEM, THE SPEAKER,
THE GOVERNOR, MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE, MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
COMPANION BILLS, AND ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR STRONG
ENGAGEMENT OVER THE PAST MANY
MONTHS AND FOR INVESTING IN
DEVELOPING THIS COMPREHENSIVE
SET OF PROPOSALS THAT WILL HAVE
A MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON RETAIL
CRIME. I ASK FOR YOUR. I VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE A WITNESSES? YES WE
DO. TWO OH, JUST ONE. OKAY. YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU, CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE,
RACHEL MICHELIN, PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION, HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL 2943.
THIS BILL DEMONSTRATES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
LISTENED TO RETAILERS LARGE AND
SMALL, IN ADDITION TO
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
AND SHOWS A SERIOUS APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING RETAIL THEFT THAT IS
PLAGUING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
PUTTING OUR EMPLOYEES AND STORES
AT RISK. THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN CONVERSATIONS AROUND
RETAIL THEFT THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN FOR SEVERAL YEARS IN THIS
BODY. THIS COMPREHENSIVE SET OF
PROPOSALS BUILDS ON A NUMBER OF
OTHER LEGISLATIVE BILLS AS PART
OF A PACKAGE THAT, TAKING
COMPREHENSIVELY COULD HAVE
MEANINGFUL IMPACTS ON STOPPING
THE GROWING THREAT OF RETAIL
CRIME AND ENSURES OUR STORES ARE
SAFE FROM REPEAT CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. OUR EMPLOYEES HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO WORK, AND OUR
CUSTOMERS CAN SHOP FREE FROM
WITNESSING CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
AROUND THEM. THIS BILL ADDRESSES
MANY OF THE ISSUES THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
HAS ADVOCATED FOR IN THE PAST,
INCLUDING PROVIDING CONSEQUENCE
FOR REPEAT OFFENDERS AND THE
CREATION OF A NEW FELONY FOR NOT
ONLY SERIAL SHOPLIFTING, BUT
ALSO OF SOMEONE POSSESSES
PROPERTY THAT WAS STOLEN FROM A
RETAIL BUSINESS, WHETHER OR NOT
THEY COMMITTED THE ACT OF
STEALING THE PROPERTY. THIS BILL
ALSO PROTECTS RETAILERS FROM
BEING CITED AS A PUBLIC NUISANCE
BY PROSECUTORS FOR CALLING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO RESPOND TO RETAIL
THEFT IN ADDITION, IT CLARIFIES
AND SIMPLIFIES THE ABILITY FOR
PROSECUTORS TO AGGREGATE UP TO
THE $950 THRESHOLD. AB 2943 ALSO
PROVIDES TOOLS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MAKE ARRESTS FOR
MISDEMEANOR SHOPLIFTING. IF THE
OFFICER OBTAINS A SWORN WITNESS
STATEMENT FROM A PERSON WHO
WITNESSED THE ALLEGED VIOLATION,
OR THE OFFICER OBSERVED VIDEO
FOOTAGE SHOWING THE PERSON TO BE
ARRESTED COMMITTING THE ALLEGED
CRIME, THE ARREST CAN BE MADE
EVEN IF THE OFFENSE WAS NOT
COMMITTED IN THE OFFICER'S
PRESENCE. IN ADDITION, SUSPECTS
CAN BE HELD IF THEY ARE CAUGHT
WITH LARGE QUANTITIES OF PRODUCT
, WITH THE SECURITY TAGS STILL
ON THEM. IN ADDITION TO
INCREASING ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
SERIAL RETAIL THEFT, THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE PARTICIPATION, THE
PARTICIPATION AND COLLABORATIVE
COURTS AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS. SOMETHING SOMETHING
THE RETAILERS ASSOCIATION HAS
ALWAYS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF. THANK
YOU. IS THAT IT? OKAY THANK YOU.
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AGAIN TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. MR. YOUNG KIM DEPUTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE PROVIDING RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 2943, WHICH
WOULD INCREASE PENALTIES FOR
POSSESSION OF STOLEN GOODS AND
SHOPLIFTING, AS WELL AS INCREASE
ARREST AUTHORITY AND PRETRIAL
DETENTION FOR RETAIL THEFT. AB
2943 WILL NOT MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER BY ALLOWING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MORE EASILY
ARREST AND DETAIN PEOPLE. YEARS
OF RESEARCH SHOW THAT PRETRIAL
DETENTION DECREASES COMMUNITY
SAFETY IN THE LONG RUN. A
LANDMARK STUDY OF MORE THAN 1.5
MILLION CASES FOUND THAT ANY
AMOUNT OF TIME IN JAIL BEYOND 23
HOURS MAKES A PERSON MORE LIKELY
TO BE ARRESTED AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE. THIS IS BECAUSE EVEN THE
SHORT PERIOD IN JAIL CAN RESULT
IN SOMEONE LOSING THEIR JOB,
THEIR HOUSING, OR CUSTODY OF
THEIR CHILDREN. WHEN SOMEONE IS
NOT A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY OR
A FLIGHT RISK, EVIDENCE TELLS US
THAT THE SAFEST OPTION IS TO
ALLOW THEM TO AWAIT TRIAL WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY, WHICH IS LESS
COSTLY AND DOES NOT CONTRIBUTE
TO INCREASED RECIDIVISM. WHILE
THE STATED GOAL OF AB 2943 IS TO
GO AFTER HIGHER LEVEL OPERATORS
IN THE RETAIL THEFT INDUSTRY,
THE CRIME OF UNLAWFUL
DEPRIVATION OF A RETAIL BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITY ALLOWS THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF THEFTS TO BE AGGREGATED
FOR THE PURPOSE OF REACHING THE
$950 THRESHOLD. IF THE DA NEEDS
TO GO BACK TWO YEARS TO ACHIEVE
THE $950 THRESHOLD, THEN THEY'RE
CLEARLY GOING AFTER LOW LEVEL
OFFENDERS. LASTLY, THIS BILL
INCREASES THE MAXIMUM TERM OF
PROBATION ON MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES FOR SHOPLIFTING AND
PETTY THEFT FROM THE PRESUMPTIVE
ONE YEAR TO A MAXIMUM OF TWO
YEARS. ONLY FOUR YEARS AGO. THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB 1950,
WHICH REDUCED THE PROBATION
LENGTH. IN MOST CASES, THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE AND LENGTHENING
PROBATION AGAIN WILL SERVE
PUBLIC SAFETY, RATHER, INCREASE
LEVELS OF SUPERVISION CAN LEAD
TO INCREASED INVOLVEMENT IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
INCARCERATION BASED ON VERY
MINOR INFRACTIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON AB 2943.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO METOOS. AGAIN. PLEASE
STATE YOUR LEAD OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES. WE'RE TWEENERS. I WILL
BE FAST. GOOD MORNING, LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION, REGARDING OUR
CONCERNS, WE'RE SEEKING
AMENDMENTS TO PROTECT OUR
NON-CITIZEN CLIENTS FROM THE
HARSHER CONSEQUENCES OF 2943,
INCLUDING DEPORTATION, REMOVAL,
AND BANISHMENT FROM THE UNITED
STATES. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO METOOS AGAIN IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR OREGON, WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE DANICA ROEM ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
VERA INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. BRIAN
SHERMAN WITH RIVERSIDE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, THE OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT OPPOSED
TO THE INOPERABILITY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS CARLOS GUTIERREZ
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JULIAN NAVAS, ON BEHALF OF
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. WE
HAVE ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORTER
FERMENTED POSITION ON THIS ONE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. BRENDA
BASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ETHAN AGUILAR, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF CORONA, MERCED,
REDWOOD CITY, RANCHO PALOS
VERDES, IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IN FRONT. BIXEL KUDOS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SEEING NO
CONVERSATION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES JUST THE ONE THING IN
RESPONSE TO ONE OF THE OPPONENTS
WHERE THEY BASICALLY SAID THAT
THE AGGREGATION GOES BACK TWO
YEARS, THAT THAT PERIOD OF TIME
IS 90 DAYS. SO THAT IS INCORRECT
. AND IN CLOSING, I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO ADVANCE BALANCED, EFFECTIVE
AND MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO I HAVE A
MOTION? SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES
THE BILL. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL
VOTE, PLEASE? MAYBE 2943. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WILL HAVE A JOB.
I SAY TO CIERTO NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER
WIENER. THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU. I'M PREPARED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SORIA'S
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
PERFECT. LET'S DO IT RIGHT NOW,
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZABIR IS
GOING TO PRESENT AB 1960 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA, OKAY.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB 1970 HERE
TO PRESENT THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA AB 1960
RESTORES AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO COMBAT RETAIL
THEFT AND KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. THE BILL EXPANDS CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR THEFT. IT
BOLSTERS, BOLSTERS POLICE AND
PROSECUTOR TOOLS TO COMBAT
THEFT, AND IT HELPS TAKE DOWN
THOSE WHO PROFIT FROM SMASH AND
GRABS AND RETAIL THEFT.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL
REINSTATES A TIERED SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENT SYSTEM IF THE VALUE
OF STOLEN OR DAMAGED PROPERTY IS
EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MANY OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND OUR RETAILERS,
WHO HAVE BASICALLY EXPERIENCED
HIGH DEGREES OF PROPERTY CRIME
IN THEIR IN THEIR STORES. IN
ADDITION TO THE THEFTS, THE
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT TIERS ARE
AS FOLLOWS. AN ADDITIONAL ONE
YEAR OF THE VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY EXCEEDS 50,000, AND
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS OF THE
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY EXCEEDS
200,000, AND ADDITIONAL THREE
YEARS. IF THE PROPERTY VALUE
EXCEEDS 1 MILLION, AND
ADDITIONAL FOUR YEARS IF THE
PROPERTY VALUE EXCEEDS 3
MILLION, AND AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
BEYOND THE TERMS ABOVE FOR EVERY
ADDITIONAL $3 MILLION IN
PROPERTY VALUE, THIS BILL
ENSURES THE PUNISHMENT MATCHES
THE CRIME AND HOLDS INDIVIDUALS
WHO STEAL LARGE AMOUNTS
ACCOUNTABLE, ENHANCE PENALTIES
TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THOSE WHO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AND VICTIMIZE
OUR NEIGHBORS WILL DETER OTHERS
FROM FOLLOWING THE SAME PATH AND
HARMING OUR COMMUNITIES. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB 1960 IS RACHEL MICHELIN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. HELLO. I'M JUST
GOING TO START ACROSS THE STATE,
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS HAVE SEEN
PRODUCTS LOCKED UP OR IN SOME
CASES, PRODUCTS NOT EVEN SOLD IN
STORES. THEY'VE SEEN RETAIL
THEFT HAPPEN BEFORE THEIR OWN
EYES. EVERYONE SEEMS TO HAVE A
RETAIL THEFT STORY. WHAT'S
WORSE, THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE WE
ARE SEEING IN THE DESTRUCTION OF
PROPERTY CRIMINALS ARE USING.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF VIDEOS OF
RETAIL STORES, LARGE AND SMALL,
BEING DESTROYED BY THIEVES, RUN
OUT OF THE STORES WITH STOLEN
PRODUCTS. AB 1960 GOES AFTER
THESE EGREGIOUS ACTS.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
COMMISSION OR ATTEMPTED
COMMISSION OF A FELONY OR A
PERSON IS RECEIVING STOLEN
PROPERTY CHARGED AS A FELONY.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE ENGAGING IN
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AND AS SUCH
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE WITH
ENHANCED CONSEQUENCES. THIS BILL
SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT THIS
TYPE OF VIOLENT BEHAVIOR WILL NO
LONGER BE TOLERATED IN
CALIFORNIA, AND SIGNALS THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE WILL PUT THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THAT OF LAW ABIDING CALIFORNIANS
ABOVE THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO COMMIT
CRIMES THAT NOT ONLY PUT OUR
EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS AT RISK,
BUT ALSO DESTROY PROPERTY AND
LIVELIHOODS OF THE BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS BILL
BUILDS ON SEVERAL OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS AS PART OF
THE BIPARTISAN RETAIL THEFT
PACKAGE THAT TAKING
COMPREHENSIVELY COULD HAVE
MEANINGFUL IMPACTS ON DETERRING
THE GROWING THREAT OF RETAIL
THEFT AND ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
IN CALIFORNIA, AND SENDS A
SIGNAL THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
DAMAGE OR DESTROY PROPERTY IN
THE COMMISSION OR ATTEMPTED
COMMISSION OF A FELONY WILL FACE
NEW SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THOSE REASONS, I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, ANYBODY THAT'S LEAD SUPPORT
SEEING NONE LEAD OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES DNA ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE IN THE VERA
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1960 AND ANY
OTHER BILL THAT SEEKS TO CREATE
A NEW SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THERE
ARE ALREADY OVER 100
ENHANCEMENTS IN THE PENAL CODE,
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS,
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF THE PRISON
POPULATION HAS AT LEAST ONE
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT APPLIED TO
THEIR SENTENCE. THE PROPONENTS
OF AB 1960 STATE THAT THIS IS
NECESSARY TO HOLD PEOPLE
COMMITTING SMASH AND GRABS
ACCOUNTABLE. AB 1960 WON'T LEAD
TO GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY. IT
WILL SIMPLY ADD ADDITIONAL TIME
TO SOMEBODY'S SENTENCE WHO'S
ALREADY BEEN CONVICTED AND
SENTENCED TO A TERM OF
INCARCERATION, ALSO, THE BILL
DOESN'T APPLY ONLY TO RETAIL
THEFTS, BUT PROPERTY DAMAGE
COMMITTED DURING THE ANY
COMMISSION OF A FELONY OR
ATTEMPTED COMMISSION OF A
FELONY, MEANING THE IMPACT OF
THE BILL GOES FAR BEYOND THE
STATED PURPOSE. I ALSO JUST WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION, AS WHAT AB 1960 IS
PROPOSING, TRYING TO REMOVE OR
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT, SINCE THEY'VE BEEN
PROVEN TO BE A DRIVER OF MASS
INCARCERATION. AND IN A MOMENT
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IS
NEGOTIATING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AROUND REDUCING
THE COSTS OF OUR PRISON SYSTEM,
AB 1960 MOVES US IN EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION. I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. LEAD
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, LESLIE
CALDWELL. HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE, IN OPPOSITION,
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE ASSOCIATION RECOGNIZED
EASES THE PUBLIC CONCERN OVER
RETAIL THEFT. HOWEVER AB 1960 IS
AN UNNECESSARY AND MISGUIDED
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, FELONY
STATUTES FOR GRAND THEFT AND
VANDALISM ALREADY PROVIDE FOR
LENGTHY PRISON SENTENCES FOR THE
TAKING AND OR DESTRUCTION OF
HIGH DOLLAR PROPERTY AMOUNTS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN RECENT
YEARS REPEALED MANY SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS AND EXPANDED THE
ABILITY OF JUDGES TO STRIKE
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION.
NONETHELESS, BASED ON RECENT
STUDIES, THE USE OF SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS REMAINS ROBUST. AB
1960 WOULD BE A STEP BACKWARD
FROM THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE IN
REDUCING MASS INCARCERATION,
BECAUSE AB 1960 SEEKS TO PUNISH
CONDUCT THAT'S ALREADY
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED UNDER
CURRENT LAW AND THUS NEEDLESSLY
CONTRIBUTES TO MASS
INCARCERATION FOR NONVIOLENT
OFFENSES. ON BEHALF OF CPA AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDERS OFFICE, WE URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ME, TWOS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. AGAIN, STATE
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORG, AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE,
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE QUICKLY
THROUGH THIS. PLEASE BECCA
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION CÁC ANDREW MÀ ON
BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
TATIANA LEWIS, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING, CHIARA ROSS. ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON
AND SUPPORT ALYSSA MOORE. ALL OF
US ARE NONE IN OPPOSITION. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF MERCED AND RANCHO PALOS
VERDES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IN PRINT. LAWRENCE COX, ON
BEHALF OF LSPC OPPOSITION.
JULIANA VOIGTS, LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA BASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
MADISON, DWELLEY WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF TARGET IN
SUPPORT BRANDON EPP ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF
IN SUPPORT PRISCILLA KUDOS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT YOLANDA
NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT IN
OPPOSITION. KERRY ARZATE WITH
FTIO, AS WELL AS FAMILIES
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. AGUILAR HERE
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US OR NONE
IN OPPOSITION, THANK YOU. JIM
LINDBERG, FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA,
OPPOSE AUSTIN Dð ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IN PRINT AND IN OPPOSITION
TO THE POISON PILL AMENDMENTS.
RYAN SHERMAN OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. NARCOTIC
OFFICERS, THE OTHER POSE AND
DSA'S IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
OPPOSED TO THE INOPERABILITY.
THANK YOU. KELLY WALTERS, LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
SPEAKERS, COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING NONE, I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE, JUST THAT THIS IS PART OF
THE, THE RETAIL CRIME PACKAGE
AND, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. DO I HAVE A MOTION,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
A ROLL CALL UNTIL WE HAVE
SOMEBODY MAKING A MOTION. SO
THIS IS ON HOLD FOR A SECOND.
I'LL GIVE A COURTESY MOTION.
THANK YOU. SO THAT WE CAN.
SENATOR SARDO MAKES A COURTESY
MOTION, CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
AB 1960. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB A
WAHAB. AYE. SATO SATO NOT
VOTING. BRADFORD. SKINNER.
WIENER THANK YOU. THAT BILL IS
ON CALL. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING. 3209 ASSEMBLY BILL.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. AB 3209 WOULD PROVIDE
A NEW ENFORCEMENT TOOL THAT WILL
KEEP STORES AND WORKERS SAFE
FROM THE RISE OF RETAIL CRIME IN
RECENT YEARS, RATES OF RETAIL
THEFT AND ROBBERY HAVE RISEN IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THIS AFFECTS
BOTH OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
BUSINESSES. SB 3209 WOULD NOT
ONLY ADDRESS RETAIL THEFT, BUT
ALSO THE ISSUES OF VANDALISM
WITHIN THE STORES, AS WELL AS
BATTERY AND ASSAULTS ON THE
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN RETAIL.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE A
COURT TO IMPOSE A RETAIL CRIME
RESTRAINING ORDER FOR UP TO TWO
YEARS FOR THEFT, VANDALISM OR
BATTERY ON AN EMPLOYEE WITHIN
THE STORE. AND IMPORTANTLY, AB
3209 WOULD REQUIRE THE COURT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE INDIVIDUAL
RESIDES IN A FOOD DESERT WHERE
THE AFFECTED STORE IS THE ONLY
LOCATION FOR NECESSITIES SUCH AS
FOOD. OR MEDICINE, AND
ENCOURAGES DIVERSION PROGRAMS
FOR ANY VIOLATION OF THE
RESTRAINING ORDER, RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND HERE
WITH ME IS RACHEL MICHELIN, WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND BRENDA BASS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, WHO WILL BE, I'M SURE,
AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE. I WILL BE
VERY BRIEF, VERY MUCH, THE
SAFETY OF RETAIL EMPLOYEES AND
CUSTOMERS IS OUR TOP PRIORITY.
AND TOO OFTEN RETAIL EMPLOYEES
OR CUSTOMERS HAVE BEEN PUT IN
HARM'S WAY DUE TO REPEAT RETAIL
THEFT. OFFENDERS AB 3209 WOULD
PROVIDE A NEW ENFORCEMENT TOOL
THAT WILL KEEP STORES AND
WORKERS SAFE FROM REPEAT RETAIL
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE RETAIL THEFT
RESTRAINING ORDERS PRESENTS A
PROACTIVE AND EFFECTIVE APPROACH
TO COMBATING THIS GROWING ISSUE
BY ENABLING RETAILERS TO OBTAIN
CIVIL RESTRAINING ORDERS AGAINST
HABITUAL OFFENDERS. THIS
LEGISLATION EMPOWERS BUSINESSES
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND DETER
POTENTIAL THIEVES FROM ENGAGING
IN CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES. THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
URGES THE SUPPORT OF AB 3209 AND
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE RETAIL
THEFT RESTRAINING ORDERS. BY
DOING SO, WE CAN TAKE MEANINGFUL
STEPS TOWARDS SAFEGUARDING OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES, PROTECTING THE
LIVELIHOODS OF HARD WORKING
EMPLOYEES, AND PROMOTE A SAFER
AND MORE PROSPEROUS RETAIL
SHOPPING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
BRENDA BASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, THE LARGEST
BROAD BASED BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO
STATE GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
FROM OUR BIG RETAILERS TO OUR
LOCAL MOM AND POP STOREFRONTS,
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES ARE
HURTING BECAUSE OF AN INCREASE
IN RETAIL CRIMES, PARTICULARLY
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. RECENT
TRENDS IN RETAIL THEFT AND
COMMERCIAL ROBBERY ARE
CONCERNING, AND SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA MUST DO MORE TO
PROTECT OUR BUSINESSES. IN 2022,
THE BAY AREA EXPERIENCED THE
LARGEST INCREASES IN SHOPLIFTING
RATES, AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE
SAW A RISE IN COMMERCIAL
BURGLARIES WITH SOME COUNTIES
EXPERIENCING OVER A 50% INCREASE
COMPARED TO RATES IN 2019. AB
3209 WOULD AUTHORIZE A COURT TO
IMPOSE A RETAIL CRIME
RESTRAINING ORDER FOR UP TO TWO
YEARS FOR THEFT, VANDALISM OR
BATTERY ON AN EMPLOYEE WITHIN
THE STORE UPON CONVICTION OR
FOLLOWING TWO OR MORE CITATIONS.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE A NECESSARY
TOOL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PROTECT OUR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO CURB THE TREND
OF INCREASING RETAIL CRIME IN
OUR STATE. FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB 3209
AND RESPECTFULLY URGENT, I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION. YOU GET TWO MINUTES.
SOOJUNG-KIM DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
PROVIDING RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AB 32 3029, WHICH WOULD
CREATE A HARMFUL NEW PROCESS
WHEREBY VÌ ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING LARGE RETAILERS
COULD SEEK A TWO YEAR RETAIL
THEFT RESTRAINING ORDER FOR
PETTY THEFT OR VANDALISM. SUCH
AN ORDER COULD ALSO BE SOUGHT
MERELY IF SOMEONE HAS BEEN
ARRESTED BUT NOT CONVICTED OF
SUCH AN OFFENSE TWICE, WHICH
WOULD REPRESENT AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PUNISHMENT FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS NOT EVEN BEEN
FOUND GUILTY. PROSECUTORS AND
RETAIL STORES HAVE HISTORICALLY
COMBATED THEFT, USING THEFT OR
TRESPASS CHARGES. THESE TOOLS
ARE STILL AVAILABLE AND THEY'RE
MORE THAN SUFFICIENT FOR THEFT
AND VANDALISM OFFENSES. COURTS
CAN IMPOSE PROBATION CONDITIONS
AFTER SOMEONE HAS BEEN CONVICTED
OF A THEFT OFFENSE TAILORED TO
THE UNIQUE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CONVICTION
AND OR DEFENDANT FOR OFFENSES
INVOLVING VIOLENCE AGAINST
RETAIL WORKERS, THE HARMED
EMPLOYEE STILL HAS ALL THE
RIGHTS AVAILABLE TO THEM AS A
CRIME VICTIM, AND THE PERSON
COMMITTING THE HARM COULD BE
CHARGED WITH ASSAULT, BATTERY OR
OTHER FITTING CHARGE. AB 3209
ALSO CREATES AN ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH MORE BLACK, BROWN AND POOR
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE HARMED IN
RETAIL STORES. BANCO BROWN, A 24
YEAR OLD BLACK TRANS MAN, WAS
SHOT AND KILLED IN SAN FRANCISCO
LAST APRIL BY A WALGREENS
SECURITY GUARD WHO ACCUSED BROWN
OF SHOPLIFTING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE VOTE NO ON AB 3209.
THANK YOU. LEAD OPPOSITION TWO
MINUTES. DANICA ADAMO, ON BEHALF
OF THE VERA INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE, I ECHO THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND JUST WANT TO
STRESS THE CONCERNS AROUND
RACIAL PROFILING RAISED BY THE
BILL. EYEWITNESS TESTIMONY HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE INCREDIBLY
UNRELIABLE, AND ESPECIALLY
WORSENED OVER CROSS RACIAL
IDENTIFICATIONS, INCREASING THE
UNRELIABILITY BY 50. SO UNDER
THIS BILL, WE WOULD HAVE
EMPLOYEES IN RETAIL STORES,
PERHAPS THAT NEVER SAW THE
PERSON FOR WHOM THE, RESTRAINING
ORDER IS APPLYING TO TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THEM. AND IN THE CASES
OF WHITE EMPLOYEES AND MAYBE
BLACK PEOPLE BEING PRESENT IN
ONE OF THESE STORES, WE THINK
THAT REALLY RISKS THE WRONG
PEOPLE BEING IDENTIFIED AND
ARRESTED OR JOURNAL. NO. THANK
YOU. METOOS GOOD MORNING, CHIARA
ROSS. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
STOCKTON, IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
. RYAN SHERM WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. THE OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, OPPOSED THE
INOPERABILITY CLAUSE. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND SUPPORT BRENDAN UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF IN SUPPORT CASSANDRA MÀ
ON BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY IN SUPPORT. ETHAN NAGEL
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
PALOS VERDES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IN PRINT. HEAD ON. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US OR
NONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
KELLY WALTERS, LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. PRISCILLA,
KUDOS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN SUPPORT. HENRY
HENRY ORTIZ WITH ALL OF US AND
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR SATO, THANK YOU. YOU
KNEW I WAS GOING TO SPEAK
BECAUSE THIS IS THE LAST OF THE
RETAIL BILLS. SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THANK YOU. GO ON, MR.
BERMAN. NO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS, THIS THIS BILL,
TO US AS PART OF THIS RETAIL
PACKAGE. AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR TO YOU AND ALL OF THE
OTHERS THAT WE ABSOLUTELY I, I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT, MANY OF
THESE, APPROACHES TO DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT RETAIL THEFT,
FOR THOSE WHO ARE PROMOTING THE,
THE IDEA, THE NOTION THAT IT
DOESN'T EXIST, IF I DIDN'T SEE
IT WITH MY OWN EYES, I MAY JOIN
YOU IN SAYING, HEY, IT MAY IT
MIGHT BE OVERBLOWN, BUT FOR ME
TO GO TO FOUR DIFFERENT STORES
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND BE ABLE
TO WITNESS IT HAPPENING WOULD BE
, I MEAN, THAT'S THOSE ARE
ASTRONOMICAL ODDS FOR ME TO
ACTUALLY BE IN A STORE AT THE
TIME SOMETHING IS HAPPENING AND,
AND NOT NOT ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THIS IS AN INCREASE IN WHAT'S
GOING ON. AND I CAN NAME THE
STORES IF YOU WANT, BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO. BUT ONE WAS A GROCERY
STORE, ONE WAS A CONVENIENCE
STORE, ONE WAS AN APPAREL AND
SPORTING GOODS STORE. AND SO
YES, IT IS HAPPENING OUT THERE.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS PEOPLE
ARE SICK AND TIRED OF IT,
REGULAR PEOPLE OUT THERE.
BECAUSE WHEN THESE THEFTS ARE
HAPPENING, OUR PRICES ARE GOING
UP OR WE WIND UP HAVING THE
INCONVENIENCE OF HAVING LESS
STORES TO SHOP AT AND THAT IS
HAPPENING. THAT'S HAPPENING IN
MY COMMUNITY. SO DON'T SIT HERE
AND TELL ME IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
IT IS. SO WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. AND THESE
SOLUTIONS ARE GREAT SOLUTIONS.
AND IF WE PUT THEM INTO PLACE
TODAY, THAT'S A GREAT THING. THE
URGENCY CLAUSE WILL HELP DO THAT
, BUT I SUSPECT THERE'S AN
UNDERLYING REASON FOR THE
URGENCY CLAUSE. AND I'M A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED. AND WE ARE GOING
TO INVESTIGATE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF PROP 47 IN THIS INITIATIVE IN
THE FALL, FAILS, WHETHER ALL OF
THESE WIND UP GETTING NEGATED BY
THE PROPOSITION ITSELF, BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT SPEAKS LOUDER THAN
US PASSING BILLS. WE CAN'T WE
CAN'T UNDO A PROPOSITION. THÀNH
SO AND HAVING HAVING THIS
BROUGHT UP AT THE LAST MINUTE,
WHICH IS THIS WEEK, MAKES US
HAVE TO WAIT FOR, YOU KNOW,
CHECK, CHECK IT OUT, LOOK AT THE
LEGAL, THE LOGISTICS OF WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS AND WHETHER THESE ARE
AT JEOPARDY Kò FROM THAT
ACTUALLY FAILING, AND BECAUSE
THEN PROPOSITION 47 WOULD STAND
AND I FEAR THAT ALL OF THESE I
FEAR THAT ALL OF THESE WOULD,
WOULD GO AWAY. SO, GIVEN THE
LAST MINUTE, FINAGLING, I THAT'S
WHY I'M, I'M DOING NOT VOTING
TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO
INVESTIGATE IT FURTHER AND HAVE
THE TIME TO DO IT. BUT I WANT
EVERYBODY WHO IS IN FAVOR OF
THIS PACKAGE, ALL OF OUR
RETAILERS, ALL OF OUR CITIZENS,
TO KNOW THAT I AM ABSOLUTELY ON
BOARD WITH DOING SOMETHING AND
DOING SOMETHING IN THIS MANNER,
TO COMBAT RETAIL THEFT,
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. WE'VE ERODED
THOSE OVER THE YEARS. ANYTHING
PROP 14 DIDN'T COVER, WE'VE
COVERED IN THIS IN THIS
LEGISLATION, LEGISLATIVE BODY
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. AND NOW
WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE PEOPLE
CAN BARELY DO I MEAN, THEY CAN
DO ANYTHING, AND THEY ARE DOING
ANYTHING. AND SO GIVEN THAT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK IT'S HIGH TIME AND
I AM I AM DELIGHTED TO SEE THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED BY NOT SEEING IT AND
NOT BEING SUPPORTED WHEN WE DO
TRY TO DO SOMETHING BY A
MAJORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE, AND
TODAY WE ARE ACTUALLY DOING
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND REIN IN
THAT BEHAVIOR. AND IF THEY DON'T
REIN IN THAT BEHAVIOR, THEY'LL
BE CONSEQUENCES FOR IT. AND ONCE
PEOPLE START SUFFERING
CONSEQUENCES, IT DOESN'T MEAN WE
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THROWING
EVERYBODY IN JAIL. IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU THINK WAS HAPPENING.
BUT WHEN THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY GET US BACK
TO AT LEAST A NORMAL STATE WHERE
THIS RETAIL THEFT ISN'T
BANKRUPTING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SENDING AND FORCING THE LARGER
RETAILERS TO DOWNSIZE THEIR
OPERATIONS SO THAT WE HAVE LESS
CONVENIENT SHOPPING IN DIFFERENT
AREAS. SO I'M SPEAKING WHILE WE
WAIT. SO ANYWAY, SO I'M JUST
ABOUT DONE, WHICH, SO THANK YOU
AGAIN, ALL OF YOU, FOR BRINGING
THESE BILLS FORWARD. I WILL
AGAIN BE ABSTAINING, BUT I WILL
GIVE YOU A COURTESY MOTION ON
THIS SO THAT WE CAN AT LEAST GET
THE VOTING STARTED. AND, AND
THAT'S IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
APOLOGIES TO EVERYONE WAITING IN
BNP FOR ME TO COME CHAIR THAT
COMMITTEE HEARING. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
, I MEAN SENATOR SERRADO AB
3209. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I HAVE I
SATO. SATO. NOT VOTING BRADFORD.
SKINNER. WIENER. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILLS ON CALL, I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT AB 2309 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI IS
BEING PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING BY THE AUTHOR, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR OTHER
HEARING. THAT MEANS OUR OTHER,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, BRIAN, WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 1810.
OKAY. ANYTIME GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR, AND SENATOR SATO.
IT'S GOOD. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 1810, A
BILL THAT WILL BRING MENSTRUAL
EQUITY TO CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISONS, LOCAL JAILS AND
JUVENILE FACILITIES FOR PEOPLE
WHO MENSTRUATE. PERIOD PRODUCTS
SUCH AS MENSTRUAL PADS AND
TAMPONS ARE BASIC NECESSITIES.
STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES SUPPLY
THESE PRODUCTS TO INCARCERATED
WOMEN AT NO COST UPON REQUEST.
HOWEVER, A 2023 REPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
REVEALED THAT NEARLY HALF OF THE
STATE'S LOCAL FACILITIES ARE
NON-COMPLIANT WITH STATE
MANDATES REGARDING MENSTRUAL
PRODUCT DISTRIBUTION. EVEN WORSE
ARE THE DOCUMENTED CASES OF
CDCR'S OFFICERS WITHHOLDING
PERIOD PRODUCTS AS A FORM OF
RETALIATION AGAINST INCARCERATED
WOMEN WHO HAVE FILED FORMAL
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THEM
NATIONWIDE. THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS REPORTS OF CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS USING ACCESS TO
MENSTRUAL CARE AND MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS TO COERCE INCARCERATED
WOMEN INTO SEXUAL FAVORS. THESE
GROSS ABUSES OF POWER HAVE
CREATED CONDITIONS WHERE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE ASKING FOR MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS, EVEN WHEN THEY ARE
FREE OF COST. DUE TO THAT FEAR
THAT IT MIGHT LEAD TO COERCION,
HUMILIATION, OR HARASSMENT.
THESE WOMEN WOULD RATHER
MAKESHIFT PADS OR TAMPONS OUT OF
TOILET PAPER BEDSHEETS, OR PUT
THEMSELVES IN UNSAFE AND
UNDIGNIFIED POSITIONS OF ASKING.
CORRECTION OFFICERS WHO HAVE
ABUSED THEM. OFTEN A MAN FOR A
MENSTRUAL PRODUCT. IN SOME
CASES, THEY ARE WALKING AROUND
IN BLOOD STAINED CLOTHES BECAUSE
THEY RUN OUT OF THEIR SUPPLY OF
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS AND ARE ONLY
ALLOWED TO DO LAUNDRY ON CERTAIN
DAYS. THIS LACK OF TIMELY AND
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO PADS AND
TAMPONS HAS LED TO SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS URINARY
TRACT INFECTIONS, TOXIC SHOCK
SYNDROME, AND IN SOME CASES, SO WHILE OUR STATE
CURRENTLY GUARANTEES MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS, THEY OFTEN COME AT THE
PRICE OF HUMILIATION AND THE
THREAT OF ABUSE. AB 1810 WILL
BRING OUR STATE CLOSER TO THE
MENSTRUAL HEALTH EQUITY THAT
OTHER STATES ARE SEEING THAT
REQUIRE THAT MENSTRUAL CARE
PRODUCTS ARE FREE AND READILY
AVAILABLE FOR ALL INCARCERATED
WOMEN. IT WILL ALSO BRING OUR
STATE INTO PARITY WITH SEVERAL
OTHER STATES, SUCH AS THE
PROGRESSIVE LOUISIANA, TENNESSEE
AND FLORIDA, ALL OF WHICH DO NOT
REQUIRE THEIR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE TO REQUEST THESE BASIC
NECESSITIES FROM THEIR JAILERS.
TODAY, I HAVE WITH ME, TATIANA
LEWIS FROM THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OOPS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS TATIANA
LEWIS, AND I'M AN ORGANIZER WITH
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. I AM HERE TODAY TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB 1810, A BILL
THAT ENSURES INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS HAVE READY ACCESS TO
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS WITHOUT
HAVING TO REQUEST THEM. I SPEAK
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE, HAVING
BEEN BOTH IN JUVENILE DETENTION
AND COUNTY JAIL. DURING MY TIME
IN THESE FACILITIES, I'VE HAD TO
ASK FOR MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS AND
THEN ENDURE THE INDIGNITY OF
WAITING FOR A GUARD TO BRING
THEM WHENEVER THEY FELT LIKE IT.
THIS PROCESS WAS NOT ONLY
HUMILIATING, BUT ALSO PHYSICALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE. MENSTRUAL HEALTH
IS A BASIC HUMAN NEED, AND BEING
DENIED TIMELY AND BEING DENIED
TIMELY ACCESS TO NECESSARY
PRODUCTS EXACERBATES THE ALREADY
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES OF
INCARCERATION FOR MENSTRUATING
INDIVIDUALS, DESERVE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR PERSONAL HYGIENE WITH
DIGNITY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCARCERATION STATUS. AB 1810
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY ENSURING
THAT MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS ARE
READILY ACCESSIBLE, REDUCING THE
UNNECESSARY BURDEN AND STRESS ON
THOSE WHO MENSTRUATE. PASSING
THIS BILL IS A CRUCIAL STEP
TOWARD TREATING INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE RESPECT AND
HUMANITY THAT THEY DESERVE. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB 1810 AND
HELP MAKE A MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF THOSE
WHO ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED AND
MARGINALIZED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. LEAD
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE'LL
GO TO METOOS. LESLIE CALDWELL,
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDERS OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
DANICA ADAMO, ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND THE GRIP
TRAINING INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
MELISSA MOORE. ALL OF US ARE
NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT. YOLANDA
NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT AND
SUPPORT WHITNEY FRANCIS WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT CARRIE ARZATE
PRISON FROM THE INSIDE OUT AND
CALIFORNIA IMPACTED FAMILIES BY
INCARCERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
REBECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. VANESSA KAHENA,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
SUPPORT IGNACIO HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT. ANTHONY DEMARTINO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ANNIE THOMAS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. JIM LINDBERG, ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ANTONIO AGUILAR
HERE ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN, ARE
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
KELLY WALTERS, ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN, A CO-SPONSOR OF
PROUDLY SUPPORTING MINISTER KING
OF CALIFORNIA PRISON FOCUS
STRONG SUPPORT. SHE WAS A TERM
JOHNMYERS DRAWING SUPPORT.
LAWRENCE COX STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ALL OF US. NONE. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I DON'T HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. I'LL GO AHEAD. AND
THIS IS NOT A COURTESY MOTION.
IT'S JUST A REGULAR MOTION. NO
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BRIAN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO, WHEN WE DECIDED TO
MAKE MENSTRUAL CARE PRODUCTS
FREE FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE,
THE FACT THAT WE MADE IT UPON
REQUEST HAS CREATED THE
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE ALLOWED FOR
A POWER DYNAMIC TO PLAY OUT TO
THE DETRIMENT OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AND INCARCERATED WOMEN.
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THAT AND MAKE MENSTRUAL
ACCESS, MENSTRUAL CARE ACCESS
READILY AVAILABLE FOR OUR PEOPLE
ON THE INSIDE. IT'S A BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT. IT'S A BASIC
NECESSITY. THIS HAS HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ON CONSENT. SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. I
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FOR
MAKING THE MOTION, CAN WE GET A
ROLL CALL? VOTE AB 1810 MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I HAVE A
SEYARTO. I SATO I BRADFORD,
SKINNER. WIENER THAT BILLS ON
CALL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT AB 2215?
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AB 2215 COMES OUT OF THE
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE HAPPENING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES OFTEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMES INTO CONTACT
WITH PROBLEMS ON THE STREETS
THAT THEY KNOW ARE DIRECTLY
POVERTY RELATED. THEY ARE
DIRECTLY CARE RELATED. AND EVEN
THE FRONT LINE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS DON'T BELIEVE THAT
TAKING THIS PERSON TO A JAIL
WILL BE IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE, TO THE BETTERMENT OF
THE COMMUNITY, OR TO THE
BETTERMENT OF THAT INDIVIDUAL.
IN FACT, IN MANY INSTANCES,
FRONTLINE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WOULD LIKE TO NOT BE
THE PERSON WHO RESPONDS TO THESE
KINDS OF SITUATIONS. AND I
BELIEVE IN A PERFECT WORLD,
THAT'S THE SOLUTION WHERE
COMMUNITY BASED INTERVENTION
WORKERS AND POVERTY WORKERS ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE INTERVENING IN
THESE MOMENTS OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND OTHER CRISIS ON OUR STREETS.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT'S PLAYING
OUT. WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THE FIRST
RESPONSE. AND IN INSTANCES WHERE
THEY WOULDN'T LIKE TO TAKE YOU
TO JAIL, WE SET UP PROGRAMS IN
2017, THE LEAD PROGRAMS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSISTED DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOWED FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO TAKE YOU
DIRECTLY TO A COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDER TO DEAL WITH THE DIRECT
NEEDS THAT FOLKS HAVE. WHAT WE
FOUND, THOUGH, IS THAT THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND OFFICERS WHO ARE
AFRAID TO USE THIS TOOL BECAUSE
THE PENAL CODE DOESN'T
EXPLICITLY ALLOW IT. WHAT AB
2215 DOES IS IT CODIFIES IN THE
PENAL CODE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSISTED DIVERSION
OPPORTUNITIES, WHERE IT IS ON
THOSE FRONT LINE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONDERS, IF THEY CHOOSE THAT
IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE AND
THE INTEREST OF WHAT'S BEST FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY,
TO TAKE THIS PERSON TO COMMUNITY
BASED PROVIDER, TO PROVIDE THE
CARE FOR THE NEEDS THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING, THAT THEY CAN DO
THAT AND THAT THAT RIGHT TO DO
THAT IS NOW PRESENT IN OUR PENAL
CODE. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH
ME TODAY IS RICK OWENS FROM THE
PENAL CODE REVISION COMMITTEE
HERE AT THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RICK OAN.
I'M SENIOR STAFF COUNSEL FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE. THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE IS A STATE ENTITY THAT
WAS CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
ALL ASPECTS OF CRIMINAL LAW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYAN IS A
MEMBER OF THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE, AB 2215 IS BASED ON A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE PENAL
CODE COMMITTEE'S MOST RECENT
ANNUAL REPORT. IT BUILDS ON
CURRENT LAW BY GIVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT A TOOL THEY COULD
USE IF THEY CONCLUDE THAT TAKING
SOMEONE TO JAIL DOES NOT IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. THAT TOOL IS AB
2215 CLEAR DIRECTION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT INSTEAD OF
JAIL, THEY COULD TAKE SOMEONE TO
AN EXISTING PROGRAM THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
CRIMINAL CONDUCT. THIS IS A TYPE
OF PRE-BOOKED DIVERSION THAT IS
ENTIRELY AT THE ARRESTING
OFFICER'S DISCRETION, AS GUIDED
BY LOCAL DEPARTMENTAL POLICY.
THE BEST EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
PRE-BOOKING DIVERSION IS LEAD,
AN ACRONYM FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSISTED DIVERSION. CALIFORNIA
FUNDED PILOT PROJECTS FOR LEAD
IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO, AND EACH PILOT WAS
EVALUATED BY INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHERS. THE RESEARCHERS
CONCLUDED THAT LEAD LED TO
SIGNIFICANT DROPS IN NEW ARRESTS
FOR PEOPLE IN THE PROGRAM,
COMPARED TO SIMILARLY SITUATED
PEOPLE NOT IN LEAD PRE-BOOKING.
DIVERSION IS MOST OFTEN USED FOR
PEOPLE COMMITTING REPEAT LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES WHO ARE IN
IMMEDIATE NEED OF SERVICES.
ALMOST 90% OF ALL CURRENT
ARRESTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE FOR
MISDEMEANORS AND LOW LEVEL
FELONIES, AND PREBOOKING
DIVERSION WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
FOR MANY OF THESE OFFENSES.
WHILE THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
PENAL CODE THAT PREVENTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR FROM UNDERTAKING
PRE BOOKING DIVERSION LIKE LEAD,
THE PENAL CODE COMMITTEE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THAT A PENAL
CODE PROVISION SPECIFICALLY
AUTHORIZING OFFICERS TO USE
PRE-BOOKING, DIVERSION THROUGH
LEAD OR OTHER SIMILAR PROGRAMS
WOULD EMPOWER MORE OFFICERS TO
USE THEIR DISCRETION TO DIVERT
APPROPRIATE CASES TO CONCLUDE
THE PENAL CODE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED WHAT IS NOW AB 2215
BECAUSE IT CONCLUDED THAT IT
WOULD IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
WHILE REDUCING UNNECESSARY
INCARCERATION. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
. SEEING NONE. WE'RE GOING TO GO
INTO ME TWOS. NATASHA MINSKER
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT DANICA ADAMO ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
THE VERA INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT ANTHONY DEMARTINO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. PROUD
SPONSOR LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DAN PHILLIPS, ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
SUPPORT. REBECCA KRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND SUPPORT. YOLANDA
NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT AND
SUPPORT. AGUILAR, ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KELLY WALTERS, LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND STRONG SUPPORT.
PRISCILLA. KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
SUPPORT JOHN DREBINGER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. STRONG SUPPORT. MELISSA
MOORE. ALL OF US ARE NONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. CARRIE ARZATE
PRISON FROM THE INSIDE OUT AND
CALIFORNIA IMPACTED FAMILIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. JIM LINDBERG, ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES, SENATOR SIERRA. COME ON.
JUST IS THAT A SIGH? SO I HAD A
QUESTION CONCERNING WHEN YOU
WERE DEVELOPING THE BILL. YEAH.
AND FIRST, WELCOME AGAIN, WHEN
YOU WERE DEVELOPING THE BILL,
WAS CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO HOW
HOW THEY WOULD DETERMINE WHICH
CBO WAS GOING TO BE THE
RECIPIENT OF, BECAUSE SOMETIMES
THERE'S MULTIPLE CBOS IN A, IN
AN AREA AND THEY'RE ALL KIND OF
COMPETING A LITTLE BIT FOR THE,
THE, THE PERSONS. SO THAT THEY
CAN EITHER GET THEIR
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR, FOR
TREATMENT, BUT ALSO SO THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO OPERATE. SO I'M
A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL, FOR ABUSE WHERE ONE
CBO IS MAKING DEALS TO GET ALL
OF THE PATIENTS SENT TO THEM AND
CREATING THAT KIND OF AN
OPPORTUNITY. DID YOU EXPLORE
THAT AT ALL WHEN YOU WERE DOING
YOUR BILL DEVELOPMENT, IN OTHER
WORDS, HOW ARE THEY GOING TO GET
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO GET
DISTRIBUTED? A FORMAL KIND OF
MOU WITH THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AROUND THIS KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP HAS TO EXIST. SO
THE SUGGESTION THAT THERE WOULD
BE ABUSE BY THAT WOULD ALSO BE
ABUSE BY THESE SAME LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO HAVE
ENGAGED IN THIS RELATIONSHIP,
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
THAT HAVE PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE
IN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES, AND WE
DID NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO MAP
OUT EVERY SUCCESSFUL
ORGANIZATION UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. BUT WE DO TRUST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS, LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS, TO DEVELOP THE
KIND OF CARE NETWORKS AND
CONTINUUMS OF CARE THAT ALLOW
FOR FOLKS TO GET THE KIND OF
SERVICES TREATMENT AND SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED BASED ON WHATEVER
CRISES WE'RE SEEING ON THE
STREETS. RIGHT. AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M SAYING. NO MONEY ATTACHED TO
THIS BILL. THERE'S USUALLY A LOT
OF CBOS ARE ARE GREAT AT WHAT
THEY DO, BUT THEY ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE THE CLIENTELE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO GET GRANTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND, AND SO,
YOU KNOW, THE PICKING AND THE
CHOOSING PART OF IT, I THINK
ENTERS INTO THE EQUATION A
LITTLE BIT. AND SO THAT'S ONE OF
MY CONCERNS WITH THIS APPROACH,
BUT, SINCE THERE IS NOBODY ELSE
HERE, I AM GOING TO THIS TIME
GIVE A COURTESY MOTION SO THAT
WE CAN VOTE. THANK YOU. I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE YOUR COURTESIES
TODAY, IT ALLOWS US TO BE
EFFICIENT. SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? ABSOLUTELY, WE ARE SEEING
CRISES PLAY OUT ON OUR STREETS.
AND THESE CRISES ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
TO POVERTY, NEEDS TO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND TREATMENT NEEDS. NEEDS
THAT YOU DON'T FIND IN THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM NEEDS THAT
ARE NOT ALLEVIATED BY GOING TO
JAIL. AND EVEN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS KNOW THAT.
AND WHAT THIS DOES IS ALLOW FOR
THEM TO DECIDE WHEN THEY COME
INTO SITUATIONS WHERE THEY KNOW
THIS PERSON COULD HAVE BETTER
OUTCOMES IN A COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAM, THAT THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY, THEY HAVE THE BACKING
OF THE PENAL CODE TO TAKE THEM
TO THAT KIND OF PROGRAM. THIS
BILL HAS HAD BYPASS FAN SUPPORT
THUS FAR. IN FACT, BOTH FORMER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ON OUR
HOUSE FLOOR SPOKE UP IN SUPPORT
ON OUR HOUSE FLOOR OF THIS BILL,
AND THAT MAY BE THE ONLY TIME IN
ASSEMBLY HISTORY THAT I HAVE
THAT KIND OF A SITUATION. BUT I
THINK IT SPEAKS TO THE
COMPREHENSIVE NATURE OF THE
APPROACH THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
BRING TO THIS WORK. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SALADO. CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? VOTE AB 2215.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
FLOOR. WAHAB AYE. AYE. SATO.
SATO. NØ. RADFORD SKINNER.
WIENER THAT. BILLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PINK.
THANKS SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR.
HAPPY TO PRESENT AB 1814. FIRST,
LET ME JUST THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENTS.
WE'RE HAPPILY TAKING THEM RIGHT
NOW. WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
REGULATIONS, NO PROTECTIONS, NO
GUIDELINES ON FACIAL RECOGNITION
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE OUTSIDE OF
A FEW CITIES WHO HAVE TAKEN THE
POSITION TO BAN FACIAL
RECOGNITION, INCLUDING MY OWN,
AB 1814 PREVENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM BEING ABLE TO ARREST,
SEARCH OR GET A WARRANT APPROVED
BY A JUDGE WHEN THE SOLE BASIS
FOR THAT ACTION IS FACIAL
RECOGNITION MATCH, WITH CIVIL
PENALTIES UP TO $25,000 FOR
VIOLATIONS. IN PREVIOUS YEARS, I
HAVE DONE LEGISLATION TO FIRST
HAVE A THREE YEAR MORATORIUM, ON
THE BANNING OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION WITHIN BODY CAMERAS
THAT EXPIRED ON JANUARY FIRST,
2023, WHICH IS WHY I FELT AN
URGENCY TO DO LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR TO REALLY HAVE THE MOST
ROBUST FACIAL RECOGNITION
GUIDELINES IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. AT THIS POINT, THERE IS
NO STATE THAT BANS FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE LÀ, OR DOES
NOT BAN THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION WITHIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO HAVE A MORE ROBUST SET OF,
GUIDELINES, BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ADVOCATES WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING LATER, WHO
ABSOLUTELY WILL NOT SUPPORT
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT A COMPLETE
OUTRIGHT BAN. SO WITH THAT, I
MOVE, RESPECTFULLY, I VOTE ON AB
1814. I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES, SO CAN GO DIRECTLY TO
LEAD OPPOSITION. TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS DAVID ROBINSON. I AM AN
ATTORNEY AND FORMER POLICE
OFFICER WITH THE CITY OF DETROIT
. I SERVED AS LEGAL ADVISOR TO
THE POLICE CHIEF AND REPRESENTED
OFFICERS WHO WERE BEING SUED. I
HAVE PRACTICED POLICE LITIGATION
ON BOTH SIDES FOR ABOUT 38
YEARS. IN 2019, I WAS CONTACTED
BY MICHAEL OLIVER, WHO HAD BEEN
ARRESTED FOR FELONY, WHICH
CARRIED A FOUR YEAR TERM. IF
CONVICTED, MICHAEL BECAME A
SUSPECT AFTER THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION USED BY THE DETROIT
POLICE DEPARTMENT SPED HIM OUT.
THE VICTIM CAPTURED THE ACTUAL
PERPETRATOR ON A CELL PHONE AND
A CROPPED IMAGE OF THAT PERSON
WAS RUN IN. FACIAL RECOGNITION.
THE DETECTIVE THEN DID A PHOTO
SHOW UP AND DESPITE OTHER
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE, THE VICTIM
PICKED MICHAEL. MICHAEL WAS
ARRESTED ON A NOT IN CUSTODY
WARRANT FOLLOWING A TRAFFIC STOP
IN A NEIGHBORING SUBURB. THE
WARRANT REQUEST IN MICHAEL'S
CASE WAS BASED ENTIRELY ON
SUPPOSED FREE MATCH AND A PHOTO
LINEUP. OTHER THAN THE PHOTO
LINEUP, AND THE DETECTIVE DID NO
OTHER INVESTIGATION, SO IT'S
EASY TO SAY THAT IT'S THE
OFFICER'S FAULT THAT HE DID A
POOR JOB OR NO INVESTIGATION,
BUT HE RELIED ON FOR TÊ
BELIEVING IT MUST BE RIGHT.
THAT'S THE AUTOMATION BIAS THAT
THIS HAS BEEN REFERENCED IN
THESE SESSIONS. SO DESPITE THE
WARNING TO THE OFFICER,
INVESTIGATIVE LEAD, ONLY THAT
PRESCRIPTION WAS TRUMPED BY THE
MESMERIZING EFFECT OF THIS
MACHINE THAT THE OFFICER SAW IS
FASTER AND SMARTER THAN HE. AND
IT MUST BE RIGHT. INTERESTINGLY,
MICHAEL'S CASE WAS DISMISSED,
BUT THE DISMISSAL WAS ON THE DAY
OF TRIAL, A RESULT OF BOTH THE
PROSECUTOR AND HIS DEFENSE
LAWYER LOOKING AT THE ACTUAL GUY
THAT COMMITTED THE CRIME. AND
MICHAEL, WHO WAS PRESENT IN
COURT. AND IT WAS CLEAR TO THE
THOSE FOLKS THAT MICHAEL WASN'T
THE PERPETRATOR. IS THAT IT? I'M
SORRY. FACIAL RECOGNITION. FACE
ID? SO IT BEGS THE QUESTION. ALL
RIGHT. WHY COULDN'T THE
DETECTIVE HAVE SEEN THE SAME
THING, 1814 WOULD NOT HAVE
OFFERED MICHAEL ANY PROTECTION.
I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO.
DO WE HAVE ANOTHER LEAD?
OPPOSITION IN TWO MINUTES. MY
NAME IS MATTHEW Kò, AN ORGANIZER
WITH THE STOP LAPD SPYING
COALITION. WE'RE A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION BASED IN SKID ROW.
WE FIGHT AGAINST LAPD
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS AND, THE
TECHNOLOGY OF SURVEILLANCE
EQUIPMENT, THE ACQUISITION OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGIES WITH A
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON THE IMPACT
THESE THESE PROGRAMS HAVE ON
POOR BLACK AND BROWN LÀ
COMMUNITIES FOR TÊ HAS A CLEAR
AND WELL REPORTED DISPARATE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON BLACK
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. ITS
SUPPORTERS ALLEGE IT MAY BE A
USEFUL TOOL FOR MAINTAINING
SAFETY. WE WOULD DENY THAT
COMPLETELY. I THINK EVEN A
SUPPORTER WOULD CONCEDE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF ITS APPLICATION ARE
AMBIGUOUS AT BEST. WHAT'S
CERTAIN IS THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
MISIDENTIFIES BLACK AND TRANS
PEOPLE AND WILL INEVITABLY LEAD
TO AN ENCOUNTER BETWEEN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND POLICE. POLICE
INTERACTIONS ARE HISTORICALLY
VIOLENT FOR BLACK COMMUNITIES.
AT BEST. WE ENDURE BUREAUCRATIC,
PSYCHOLOGICAL, AND FINANCIAL
VIOLENCE OF CRIMINALIZATION. AT
WORST, WE LOSE OUR LIVES.
LEGISLATION LIKE AB 1814 DOESN'T
ACTUALLY END OR MINIMIZE THE
DANGERS. I'VE NAMED, IF
ANYTHING, LEGISLATING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IN THIS
WAY NORMALIZES ITS USAGE. IT
INCHES US US TOWARD A CODIFIED,
QUOTE UNQUOTE REGULATED NORM
WHERE THERE'S INHERENTLY RACIST
TECH IS ROLLED OUT ACROSS THE
STATE. WE HAVE PLENTY OF
EXAMPLES OF AGENCIES IGNORING
STRONGER LOCAL REGULATIONS,
INCLUDING THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. A BILL AS TEPID AS AB
1814 WILL BE UNDERSTOOD AS A
SIGNAL TO POLICE AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE AND THE PRIVATE TECH
COMPANIES THAT DEVELOP THESE
TOOLS THAT, DESPITE THE CLEAR
DANGERS POSED BY, FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY, DESPITE
THE AS OF YET IMAGINARY BENEFITS
IT MAY HAVE, IT IS PERMISSIBLE
FOR THIS TECHNOLOGY TO MOVE
AHEAD. FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY FOLLOWS A LINEAGE OF
TECHNOLOGIES DEVELOPED AT THE
ACCEPTABLE EXPENSE OF BLACK
SAFETY AND THE CONTINUED
EXTRACTION OF OUR COMMUNITY'S
RESOURCES. THIS BILL WOULD
FACILITATE THAT LINEAGE OF
VIOLENCE TO THE BENEFIT OF
POLICE AND TECH COMPANIES. WE
SAY VOTE NO. MAYBE 1814. THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO
ME. TWO BOTH IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. BECCA KRAMER, MATTER
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION ACCESS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE, COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN-ISLAMIC RELATIONS,
CALIFORNIA GENDER JUSTICE LÀ.
IF. WHEN, HOW? LAWYERING FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE TEACH
TEACHER TRAINING IN EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. NATIONAL
IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER, PARIVAR
BAY AREA, ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION, SAN FRANCISCO BLACK
AND JEWISH UNITY COALITION,
BLACK LIVES MATTER, CALIFORNIA
ASIAN LAW ALLIANCE, ALL FAMILY
LEGAL PC, CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR YOUTH AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE
O'REILLY ORGANIZING ROOTED IN
ABOLITION, LIBERATION, AND
EMPOWERMENT, THE SIDEWALK
PROJECT, UNIVERSIDAD POPULAR
ORGANIZATION FOR IDENTITY AND
CULTURAL DEVELOPMENT ALLIANCE,
SAN DIEGO, AND CODE, JUSTICE AND
FOOD EMPOWERMENT PROJECT IN
OPPOSITION. HELLO, DANNY KENDALL
KAISER, IN OPPOSITION, SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION, UC IRVINE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, SAN DIEGO FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, TECH EQUITY ACTION,
ELECTRONIC PRIVACY INFORMATION
CENTER, SANTA MONICA DEMOCRATIC
CLUB, FIGHT FOR THE FUTURE.
STUDENTS DESERVE SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY OVERSIGHT PROJECT.
TEAM JUSTICE SAN DIEGO FREE
SPEECH COALITION, ADVOCACY FOR
PRINCIPLED ACTION IN GOVERNMENT
AMERICAN ATHEISTS CANCEL THE
CONTRACT AV CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA. INDIVISIBLE.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE.
STRONG. INDIVISIBLE. EAST BAY.
INDIVISIBLE YOLO. LA DEFENSA.
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE.
SECURE JUSTICE, AND SILICON
VALLEY. DEBUG. THANK YOU. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION,
WHITNEY FRANCIS WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
OPPOSITION. JULIANA VORIS WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. OBED FRANCO, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. CHAIR
MEMBERS. MAX PERRY, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH AND THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
PERSECUTED. ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAMERON DIMITRI WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
SECURITY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KELLY
WALTERS, LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
OPPOSITION. LAWRENCE COX ALL OF
US ARE NONE. OPPOSITION ALYSSA
MOORE. ALL OF US ARE NONE.
OPPOSITION. ANTONIO AGUILAR HERE
ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. YOLANDA NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT. RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
HENRY ORTIZ, WITH ALL OF US IN
THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
KERRY ARZATE WITH PRISON FROM
THE INSIDE OUT AND CALIFORNIA
IMPACTED FAMILIES RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION. TANISHA CANNON,
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. MINISTER KING X OF
CALIFORNIA PRISON FOCUS CAGE
UNIVERSAL. LIBERATE OUR ELDERS.
ALDER KAISER AUTONOMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NOBODY ELSE, COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? SURE FIRST, LET ME JUST
AGREE WITH OPPOSITION THAT I
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY,
WHICH IS WHY I'VE BEEN A
CHAMPION IN THIS AREA, IN TERMS
OF WHAT OUR WITNESS FROM DETROIT
TALKED ABOUT, THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
POTENTIALLY FALSE ARREST BECAUSE
IT FORCES THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES NOT TO MAKE A ARREST
BASED ONLY ON FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. IN TERMS OF THE
WITNESS FROM LOS ANGELES, AGAIN,
AS OF RIGHT NOW, LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE STATE DO NOT
NEED ANY PERMISSION FROM ANYONE
TO DO ANYTHING ON FACIAL
RECOGNITION. RIGHT NOW. THEY
HAVE COMPLETE AUTHORITY TO GO
AHEAD, TO USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION, TO USE SURVEILLANCE
TO ANY OF THAT. THERE IS NOTHING
IN ANY STATE LAW THAT ACTUALLY
PROVIDES GUIDANCE IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA. SO THIS
ACTUALLY TAKES A GOOD FIRST STEP
TO REALLY PROVIDE SOME SECURITY,
TO PROVIDE SOME CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS, AND TO ENSURE THAT
WE TAKE THE FIRST STEP TO
REGULATE FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. AGAIN, I JUST I
ADDRESS THE ISSUE. LAST YEAR, I
HAD A MUCH MORE ROBUST BILL, OF
WHICH THE SAME ADVOCATES WERE
NOT WILLING TO WORK WITH ME TO
SUPPORT. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. SIMPLY BECAUSE
WE ARE SEEING FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IN MORE AND MORE
FACETS OF OUR LIVES. I CAN'T
EVEN GO THROUGH THE AIRPORT
WITHOUT USING FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THIS IS A VERY GOOD
FIRST STEP AS MANY THINGS THAT
WE DO HERE. IT'S THE FIRST STEP.
IT'S NOT THE LAST STEP. AND I
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON AB 1814. THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SATO. I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I WOULD
HAVE LOVED AN OUTRIGHT BAN AS
WELL. I THINK THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS SAFEGUARDS, SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SATO, CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL,
PLEASE? AB 1814, THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS, AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WAHAB, I
HAVE AYE. SATO. I SATO I
BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
WIENER THAT BILLS ON CALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF MEMBERS
LEAVING. I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR TO PEOPLE THAT AS MEMBERS
LEAVE, IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
HERE. WE JUST ALSO HAVE TO
PRESENT BILLS AND OTHER
COMMITTEES, AND IT'S ACTUALLY
ACROSS THE STREET. SO, WE'RE
RUNNING AROUND OUR NEXT SPEAKER
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS, THANK
YOU FOR BEING PATIENT. WE WILL
BE HEARING AB 2295 AND, SENATOR
SKINNER WILL BE TAKING OVER
SHORTLY. WELL, THANK YOU. AND,
GOOD MORNING. STILL, IT'S EARLY
MORNING STILL. THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELCOME.
SENATOR SKINNER, TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB 2295, THE CHILD
SEX ABUSE JUSTICE ACT, WHICH
ELIMINATES THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR CRIMINAL CASES
INVOLVING THE SEX ABUSE OF A
MINOR UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES, WHICH ALLOWS
SURVIVORS TO SEEK JUSTICE. SO I
WANT TO START BY THANKING TWO
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BRAVERY AND JOINING
US AND ALL SURVIVORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO HAVE EITHER TAKEN
THEIR EXPERIENCES AND SHARED
THEM, TAKEN TIME TO ADVOCATE ON
THIS ISSUE OR IN SOME CASES ARE
NOT AVAILABLE OR NOT ABLE TO AND
HAVE SIMPLY SURVIVED SUCH
INSTANCES. AND WE JUST WANT TO
APPRECIATE YOU AS WELL AS, YOU
KNOW, CHILD SEX ABUSE OCCURS
ACROSS ALL SOCIETAL GROUPS AND
WITHIN ALL TYPES OF
INSTITUTIONS. IT'S MORE COMMON
THAN YOU MIGHT THINK. AND
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT AT LEAST
1 IN 5 GIRLS AND 1 IN 13 BOYS
ARE SEXUALLY ABUSED AS CHILDREN.
TRAUMA FROM CHILD SEX ABUSE
AFFECTS SURVIVORS THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIVES. SURVIVORS OFTEN
SUFFER FROM DISRUPTED
NEURODEVELOPMENT, PTSD,
INCREASED USE OF OTHER NEGATIVE
EXCUSE ME, INCREASED RISK OF
OTHER NEGATIVE OUTCOMES LIKE
ALCOHOL PROBLEMS, DEPRESSION,
FAMILIAL AND RELATIONSHIP
ISSUES, AND UNLIKE OTHER TYPES
OF OFFENDERS, PREDATORS OF CHILD
SEX ABUSE DO NOT SIGNIFICANTLY
DECREASE THEIR RISK OF
RECIDIVISM. RECIDIVIST WITH THE
PASSAGE OF TIME ALONE, ACCORDING
TO ONE STUDY, 55% OF CHILD SEX
OFFENDERS REPORTED THAT THEIR
OFFENSES ACTUALLY BECAME MORE
SERIOUS OVER TIME, SO. SO
HISTORICALLY, THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS, WHICH IS AN
ARBITRARY DEADLINE FOR
PROSECUTING CRIMES, HAS BEEN
UNFAIRLY SHORT FOR CHILD SEX
ABUSE. LAST ONLY UNTIL
SOMEBODY'S 40TH BIRTHDAY AND
THIS IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE FOR
MANY SURVIVORS OF CHILD SEX
ABUSE, THEY DO SUFFER IN SILENCE
FOR DECADES AND OFTEN DO NOT
COME FORWARD UNTIL THEIR MID
50S. IT CAN TAKE YEARS AND YEARS
TO PROCESS WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
MANY SURVIVORS STRUGGLE TO COME
FORWARD BECAUSE OF AN INABILITY
TO RECOGNIZE THEY WERE ABUSED.
FEELINGS OF SHAME, SELF-BLAME,
FEAR OF BLAME FROM OTHERS,
GENDER STEREOTYPES, LACK OF
TRUSTED ADULTS, STIGMA AROUND
CHILD SEX ABUSE, AND VERY REAL
FEAR OF NOT BEING BELIEVED. SO
AS A RESULT, AS I MENTIONED OVER
HALF OF SURVIVORS FIRST DISCLOSE
AT AGE 50 VÆ OR OLDER WITH THIS
IN MIND, IT'S CLEAR THAT OUR
SHORT STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
SILENCE SURVIVORS VOICES BY
PREVENTING THEM FROM SEEKING
JUSTICE AND LEAVING OTHER
CHILDREN VULNERABLE TO SEXUAL
ABUSE. IT IS AN UNACCEPTABLE
TRAGEDY THAT SURVIVORS ARE
UNABLE TO HOLD ABUSERS
ACCOUNTABLE. SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
AN ARBITRARY CLOCK THAT HAS RUN
OUT. SO AB 2295 DOES ONE VERY
SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT THING. IT
REMOVES THE DEADLINE BY WHICH
CHILD SEX ASSAULT SURVIVORS MUST
COME FORWARD TO SEEK JUSTICE
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES SO IT IT
OPENS THE DOORS TO JUSTICE AND
OPENS THE DOORS TO PREVENTION.
AND WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN THIS
OVER TO. FIRST, DIANA HAMPTON,
MOTHER OF TREVOR MARTIN. AND
THEN BRITTANY BARBER, SURVIVOR
AND ADVOCATE FROM MY DISTRICT ON
THE CENTRAL COAST. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. YES. GO AHEAD. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS DIANA HAMPTON. I'M HERE
TODAY TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 2295 TO ELIMINATE
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
CRIMINAL CASES OF CHILD SEXUAL
ASSAULT. MY SON, TREVOR MARTIN,
WAS A VICTIM OF SEXUAL ABUSE BY
A PRIEST AT THE AGE OF TEN. AND
I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF TREVOR AND ALL CHILDREN OF
SEXUAL ABUSE. I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE CHANGE IS
CRUCIAL TO ENSURE JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS AND HOLDING
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR UNSPEAKABLE ACTIONS. I
HAVE WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE
IMMENSE CHALLENGES SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT FACE IN COMING
FORWARD AND SEEKING JUSTICE. THE
TRAUMA INFLICTED UPON VICTIMS OF
SUCH ABUSE OFTEN LEAVES DEEP
EMOTIONAL SCARS THAT CAN TAKE
YEARS, IF NOT DECADES, TO
CONFRONT AND PROCESS. MANY
SURVIVORS STRUGGLE WITH FEELINGS
OF SHAME, GUILT, AND FEAR OF
RETALIATION, MAKING IT
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO DISCLOSE
THEIR ABUSE AND PURSUE LEGAL
ACTION. MY SON, TREVOR MARTIN
DID CONFRONT HIS ABUSER. IT WAS
ONLY AFTER TREVOR'S ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE THAT I LEARNED ABOUT HIS
ABUSE BY FATHER MICHAEL KELLY, A
PRIEST FROM THE STOCKTON
DIOCESE. HAD I NOT LEARNED ABOUT
THE ABUSE AND PURSUED JUSTICE
FOR MY SON, I TRULY DON'T KNOW
IF OR WHEN TREVOR WOULD HAVE
BEEN READY TO CONFRONT THE
PRIEST. I WILL NEVER KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THIS. AS MY SON PASSED
AWAY IN 2016, ELIMINATING THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS WILL GET
DANGEROUS PREDATORS AWAY FROM
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
IN OUR CHILDREN. IT WILL ALSO
HELP IDENTIFY INSTITUTIONS THAT
FACILITATE THE ABUSE OF OUR
CHILDREN. WE ARE HERE TO REMOVE
THE ABILITY FOR A TO JUST WAIT
IT OUT FOR AN ARBITRARY AMOUNT
OF TIME TO PASS, WHERE THEY ARE
FREE FROM BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. I CAN IMAGINE THE
SIGH OF RELIEF A HAS WHEN THEY
KNOW THEY HAD MADE IT PAST THE
TIME WHEN A VICTIM COULD SEEK
JUSTICE. BY PASSING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL, VICTIMS CAN TAKE
THE NEEDED TIME TO FIND THEIR
WAY TO HEALING AND JUSTICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AB 2295 AND THE REMOVAL OF
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS OF
CRIMINAL CASES OF SEXUAL CHILD
ABUSE BY DOING SO, WE CAN SEND A
POWERFUL MESSAGE TO SURVIVORS
THAT THEIR VOICES WILL BE HEARD,
PERPETRATORS WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, AND JUSTICE WILL
PREVAIL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION IN THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MATTER. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU
CAN COME TO THE MIC AND ADD YOUR
METOOS. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
BRITTANY. I AM A SURVIVOR OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE. MY
ABUSER WAS MY BIOLOGICAL FATHER.
THE ABUSE BEGAN BEFORE I CAN
REMEMBER AND IT CONTINUED IN
SOME FORM OR ANOTHER UNTIL HE
WAS ARRESTED IN 2019. THE
PHYSICAL ABUSE HAD STOPPED AS I
HAD GOTTEN OLDER, BUT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE LASTED LONG
THROUGHOUT ADULTHOOD. I WAS
TERRIFIED OF HIM UNTIL ANOTHER
YOUNG WOMAN CAME FORWARD WITH
HIS ABUSE, AND I WAS ABLE TO
FIND MY VOICE AS A CHILD, I WAS
REPEATEDLY THREATENED, BEATEN
AND TERRORIZED INTO SILENCE IN
THE CRIMINAL TRIAL AGAINST MY
ABUSER. THERE WERE TWO OTHER
WOMEN WHO HAD THE CRIMES AGAINST
THEM DISMISSED DUE TO THE
CURRENT STATUTES, BUT THEY STILL
FACED HIM IN COURT IN FRONT OF A
JURY AND TESTIFIED TO THE
HORRORS THAT HE SUBJECTED THEM
TO AS CHILDREN. MANY TIMES,
PREDATORS WILL CONVINCE THEIR
VICTIMS THAT THEY ARE THE ONLY
ONE, YET IN EVERY INSTANCE OF
SEXUAL ABUSE OF A CHILD THAT I
PERSONALLY KNOW OF, THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN JUST ONE VICTIM. THE
MONSTERS THAT COMMIT THESE
CRIMES ARE MASTER MANIPULATORS
AT BREAKING THEIR VICTIMS AND
HOLDING THEM IN THEIR SILENCE.
AS A SURVIVOR, I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPLAIN THAT MOST OF US FEEL
SCARED. WE FEEL THAT WE WILL BE
SHAMED. WE FEEL LIKE OUR VOICES
DON'T MATTER. WE FEEL WE ARE
AFRAID THAT WE WILL NOT BE
BELIEVED, OR THAT JUSTICE WON'T
BE SERVED AGAINST OUR ABUSERS.
WE FEEL SO MANY THINGS THAT NO
PERSON, ESPECIALLY NO CHILD,
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO FEEL. AND IT
TAKES US LONGER TO WORK THROUGH
OUR ISSUES OR COME FORWARD.
BECAUSE MOST OF THE TIMES WE ARE
FORCED TO WORK THROUGH THESE IN
THE DARK. WE DON'T HAVE SUPPORT,
WE HAVE SECRETS. WE ARE CHANGED
IN CRITICAL, LIFE ALTERING WAYS
BECAUSE OF ABUSE COMMITTED BY
TRUSTED ADULTS DURING OUR
FORMATIVE YEARS. SOME OF US ARE
PROTECTING OURSELVES, OUR
ABUSERS, OR OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THAT DOESN'T GO AWAY WHEN WE
BECOME ADULTS. IN MANY CASES,
THOSE OBSTACLES AND THOSE PEOPLE
REMAIN IN OUR LIVES TO SOME
EXTENT PREVENTING US FROM
FEELING FREE TO SPEAK, EVEN
YEARS LATER. THERE SHOULD NEVER
BE A POINT WHERE ENOUGH TIME HAS
PASSED THAT THE SEXUAL ABUSE OF
ANY CHILD SHOULD EVER BE
FORGIVEN OR DISMISSED, TELLING
SURVIVORS THAT IT IS TOO LATE
FOR WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM TO
DESERVE JUSTICE ONLY REAFFIRMS
ONLY REAFFIRMS THE ABUSERS
MANIPULATION TO THE SURVIVORS
THAT THEIR VOICE DOESN'T MATTER.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM
DOESN'T MATTER. BUT IT SHOULD
MATTER TO EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
US. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
AND APOLOGIES. YOU WERE THE
SECOND WITNESS, SO YOU WERE
ALLOWED THE TIME. NOW EVERYONE
ELSE WHO IS A SUPPORTER CAN COME
AND SAY, YES, WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
JUST THE ME TOO'S. ALL RIGHT. SO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME TO
THE MIC. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. MY, I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE SURVIVORS
NETWORK OF THOSE ABUSED BY
PRIESTS WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. GREAT. ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? GO AHEAD
. MEMBERS DAN FELIZARDO, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. GREAT. OKAY. ANY OTHERS
? ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY Kò
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ARE
THERE ANY, INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION WHO JUST WANT TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION?
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION? I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE, YOU KNOW, WE'VE WITHDRAWN
OUR OPPOSITION. OKAY, GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
SO, WE'VE FINISHED THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PART, AND I DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER MEMBER TO MAKE A COMMENT
, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I APPRECIATE
THE BILL. THESE ARE THESE ARE
TOUGH SUBJECTS BECAUSE AS YOU
POINT OUT, AND AS OUR WITNESSES
HAVE SPOKEN, MANY TIMES, THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S ABUSED AS A
CHILD, BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OR BECAUSE OF
EITHER SHAME OR THEIR WHO IT IS,
THERE'S A VERY STRONG,
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S A TRUSTED IT
WAS A TRUSTED INDIVIDUAL. IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE A
FAMILY MEMBER, JUST A TRUSTED
INDIVIDUAL. THEN THERE WAS
THERE'S A WHOLE APPARATUS THAT,
IN EFFECT, PROTECTS THAT
INDIVIDUAL. AND, MAKES IT EITHER
THAT THE CHILD FEELS THEY WON'T
BE BELIEVED OR THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE NO ONE TO TURN TO TELL, AND
SO IT IS IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR
A PERSON WHO EXPERIENCED THIS TO
NOT REALLY CONFRONT THAT ABUSE
UNTIL THEY ARE, IN ADULTHOOD.
AND I KNOW THAT FOR SOME PEOPLE
DEFIES LOGIC. BUT IT IN FACT IS
THE CASE, AND IT'S WELL
DOCUMENTED IN RESEARCH, SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THE
BILL. I DON'T NECESSARILY LIKE
EXTENDING STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS IN A LOT OF,
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT I THINK THESE
THIS IS A PARTICULARLY UNIQUE
ONE BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCE
OF THE ABUSE HAPPENING IN
CHILDHOOD AND THE KINDS OF, AS I
MENTIONED, THE KIND OF
CONDITIONS FOR WHICH A PERSON
WOULD NOT COME FORWARD. AND EVEN
WHEN YOU DO COME FORWARD AS AN
ADULT, IT IS A VERY COURAGEOUS
ACT, BECAUSE YOU HAVE SURVIVED
THAT LONG, IN EFFECT, BURYING
THAT, BEARING THAT INFORMATION.
SO ANYWAY, I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT, WE CAN'T TAKE A MOTION YET
BECAUSE THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO
MAKE THAT MOTION, BUT YOU MAY
CLOSE. WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN. AND I WOULD
SAY I AGREE AND OFTEN SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS IN TERMS OF LIFTING
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS. AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A UNIQUE AND IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT IS ACTUALLY
PREVENTATIVE IN NATURE, IN THAT,
ABUSERS HAVE SET THEIR CRIMES
OFTEN GET WORSE, AND MORE
PREVALENT OVER TIME. AND SO IF
WE CAN REMOVE THOSE FOLKS FROM
HAVING ACCESS TO CHILDREN IN THE
FUTURE, THEN IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
JUSTICE, BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT
PREVENTION. AND THE ONLY WAY TO
REMOVE ACCESS TO CHILDREN IS
THROUGH THE CRIMINAL COURT
SYSTEM, BECAUSE THAT IS THE ONLY
WAY THAT SOMEBODY CAN BE ON A
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY. SO I WANT
TO APPRECIATE THE DEEP THINKING
THAT HAS GONE INTO THIS. AND
WE'VE WORKED A LOT WITH
OPPOSITION AND REALLY REMOVED
MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL. SO
WHEN THE TIME IS READY,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANKS SO MUCH. AND WHEN
THE TIME IS READY WE WILL GET A
MOTION AND MOVE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. GREAT THANKS FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT. NOW WE
WILL GO TO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WEBER TO PRESENT AB 2681. GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING, I WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 2681 AND WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ADVANCED ROBOTS ARE
ENORMOUSLY BENEFICIAL TO MANY
INDUSTRIES, INCLUDING ENERGY
CONSERVATION, CONSTRUCTION,
MANUFACTURING, HEALTH CARE, AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. THESE
TECHNOLOGIES KEEP PEOPLE SAFE BY
PERFORMING DANGEROUS OR
DIFFICULT TASKS AND HELPING
PEOPLE DO THEIR JOBS EFFICIENTLY
. HOWEVER, AS ROBOTS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC, THERE ARE RECENT
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE MOUNTING
DANGEROUS WEAPONS TO THEM, OFTEN
WITH THE GOAL OF CREATING A
SENSATIONAL VIRAL SOCIAL MEDIA
VIDEO. THE MISUSE OF WEAPONIZED
REMOTE CONTROLLED OR AUTONOMOUS
ROBOTS IS UNETHICAL, POSES A
SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY THREAT AND
DAMAGES THE PUBLIC'S ACCEPTANCE
OF THESE BENEFICIAL TECHNOLOGIES
IN SOCIETY. THE AB 2681 SOLVES
THIS PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING
BASIC GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE THAT
ADVANCED ROBOTICS ARE USED
ETHICALLY AND SAFELY, SAFELY,
AND FOSTERS PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT OF AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF INNOVATION
IN OUR STATE. WE MUST ALERT THE
PUBLIC THAT IT IS NOT ALLOWED IN
CALIFORNIA TO ARM THESE DEVICES.
THE IMAGERY OF ARMED ROBOTS
WALKING THE STREETS OF
CALIFORNIA IS DAMAGING TO THE
GOAL OF MANY RESPONSIBLE ROBOTIC
COMPANIES. THESE DEVICES ARE
BEING DESIGNED TO BUILD AND
ASSIST US. THEY ARE NOT BEING
DESIGNED TO HARM US. IT IS AGAIN
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE
NATION AND ESTABLISH PROHIBITION
OF WEAPONIZED ROBOTS AND DRONES.
IS HERE TODAY. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS LARA BENNET, WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS REPRESENTING
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL,
BOSTON DYNAMICS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
LARA BENNET, HERE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY ON BOSTON DYNAMICS,
BOSTON DYNAMICS IS THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF 2681. AND THANKS TO
MEMBER WEBER FOR INTRODUCING
THIS CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY
MEASURE, AS WELL AS THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK
ON THIS BILL. BOSTON DYNAMICS IS
A COMPANY THAT DESIGNS AND
MANUFACTURES THE MOST ADVANCED
MOBILE ROBOTS SINCE OUR FOUNDING
BY AN MIT PROFESSOR AND HIS
STUDENTS OVER 30 YEARS AGO, OUR
VISION HAS BEEN TO CREATE
GENERAL PURPOSE ROBOTS THAT
BENEFIT HUMANITY BY KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE FROM HARM,
INCREASING PRODUCTIVITY AT WORK,
AND FURTHERING EDUCATION AND
SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER, AS ADVANCED MOBILE
ROBOTS HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE, WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY SEEN EXAMPLES OF
PEOPLE MOUNTING DANGEROUS
WEAPONS THROUGH ROBOTS THAT ARE
CAPABLE OF NAVIGATING WITHIN
LOCATIONS WHERE PEOPLE LIVE AND
WORK, WHICH RAISES NEW RISKS OF
HARM AND SERIOUS ETHICAL
CONCERNS, AS WELL AS GENERATING
WIDESPREAD FEAR AND CONDEMNATION
IN THE PRESS, GOVERNMENT,
ACADEMIA, ACADEMIA, AND
COMMUNITIES. AB 2681 FULFILLS A
CRUCIAL VISION FOR THE ETHICAL
AND SAFE ROBOTS IN SOCIETY BY
PROHIBITING THE MANUFACTURE,
SALE, USE, OR OPERATION OF A
ROBOTIC DEVICE, INCLUDING A
DRONE THAT IS MOUNTED WITH A
WEAPON DESIGNED TO THREATEN
CAUSE DEATH, INCAPACITATE, OR
PHYSICALLY INJURE A PERSON
APPROPRIATELY. WE BELIEVE IT
LEAVES UNAFFECTED MILITARY
SYSTEMS AND CONTRACT WHO WHOSE
DEVELOPMENT AND MANUFACTURING
ACTIVITIES ARE WELL MANAGED AND
NOT AN ISSUE. THE ACT ALSO
WISELY DOES NOT PROHIBIT THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF BOMB SQUADS.
OFFICIAL OFFICIALS WHO USE
ROBOTS TO SAFELY DISABLE
SUSPECTED EXPLOSIVES WHILE
KEEPING OFFICERS SAFE. THESE ARE
OPERATIONS THAT PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THAT ARE CONDUCTED BY
EXPERIENCED TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS. IT ALSO PERMITS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS TO
CONTINUE WITH THEIR BATTLEBOTS
PROGRAMS WHEN CONDUCTED WITH
SAFETY PROTECTIONS FOR
PARTICIPANTS AND SPECTATORS. IN
SUMMARY, AB 2681 IS A BALANCED
FOCUS AND EFFECTIVE SOLUTION. WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. REAL CONCERNS
ABOUT WEAPONIZED ROBOTS WILL
HELP BUILD PUBLIC TRUST IN THE
ROBOTICS INDUSTRY. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 2681. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE, IS THERE ANOTHER KEY
WITNESS THAT YOU'RE SEEING? IF I
MAY, MADAM CHAIR, THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE. CAN I EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT PERFECTLY? ABC
DRONE DEPLOY IN SILICON VALLEY
ROBOTICS ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. EXCELLENT. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT? OKAY, WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION, BUT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WANTS TO ADD ON
TO OPPOSITION OR NOT? ADD ON
WANTS TO COME FORWARD AND
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I APPRECIATE YOUR BILL,
BECAUSE OF OTHER COMMITTEES AND
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
HAVING TO PRESENT BILLS AND
OTHER COMMITTEES, THEY'RE NOT
HERE AT THE DAIS, SO WE CAN'T
TAKE A MOTION YET. BUT CERTAINLY
YOU MAY CLOSE. WELL, ONCE AGAIN,
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH WITH MY STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT THAT THIS IS A VERY
RESPONSIBLE, THOUGHTFUL BILL
WHEN I THANK THE SPONSORS. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS SINCE LAST
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND, YOU
KNOW, IT'S INTERESTING. I THINK
IT WAS ABOUT A MONTH AGO. I WAS
GOING TO SPEAK AT A CONFERENCE
IN SAN DIEGO CONCERNING THIS,
AND THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT HAD
JUST COME ON ON THE INTERNET,
SOMEONE HAD A COMPANY WHERE
THEY'VE TAKEN ONE OF THESE
ROBOTS AND THEY'VE STRAPPED A
FLAMETHROWER ONTO THEM, AND THEY
ARE SELLING THEM. AND YOU COULD
JUST GO TO THE WEBSITE AND BUY
THESE ROBOTS WITH A FLAMETHROWER
AND, YOU KNOW, LIKE I SAID, THIS
BILL IS A VERY, VERY WELL
THOUGHT OUT, VERY RESPONSIBLE
WAY TO ALLOW FOR INNOVATION TO
CONTINUE, BUT TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE KEEPING THE PUBLIC SAFE AS
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES. WE'RE
SEEING THAT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ARE USING SOME VERY
INTERESTING WAYS, NOT ORIGINALLY
INTENDED FOR THE TECHNOLOGY, AND
WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE KEEPING THE RESIDENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SAFE AND WITH
THAT, WHENEVER WE HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE HERE, HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET
A MOTION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ON AB 2681.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AND WE, WHEN WE DO HAVE
SOME FOLKS BACK IN THE ROOM,
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AS AS
AMENDED, AS YOU INDICATED, YOU
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE'S AMEND.
SO THANKS VERY MUCH. NOW, WE
WILL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. AND THAT BILL IS AB
2739. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, AB 2739 SEEKS TO
ENSURE ALL GUNS CARRIED
ILLEGALLY ARE TREATED THE SAME
UNDER THE LAW. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, CARRYING A CONCEALED WEAPON
WITHOUT A PERMIT IS A CRIME AND
IS DEEMED A PUBLIC NUISANCE. THE
FIREARM THAT IS ILLEGALLY
CARRIED MUST BE SURRENDERED AND
DESTROYED. HOWEVER, THE SAME
RULES DO NOT EXIST FOR OPENLY
CARRYING AN UNLOADED HANDGUN IN
PUBLIC OR CARRYING A LOADED
FIREARM IN PUBLIC. AB 2739
DECLARES BOTH OF THESE CRIMES A
NUISANCE AND SUBJECTS THE
FIREARMS TO EXISTING SURRENDER
AND DESTROY PROVISIONS.
ADDITIONALLY, IT APPLIES THE
SAME SURRENDER AND DESTROY
STATUTES TO FIREARMS USED IN
CRIMES FOR WHICH A DEFENDANT IS
GRANTED MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION.
AB 2739 FOCUSES SOLELY ON THE
FIREARM IT DOES NOT CREATE A NEW
CRIME OR INCREASE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES OR INTERFERE WITH THE
DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO BE
GRANTED DIVERSION. IT ALSO DOES
NOT INFRINGE ON THE RIGHTS OF
LAW ABIDING GUN OWNERS, AS ANY
FIREARM SUBJECT TO AB 2739 ARE
FIREARMS THAT WERE CARRIED IN
VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
THIS BILL IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT TARGETS
IRRESPONSIBLE GUN POSSESSION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I VOTE
. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. DO
YOU HAVE ANY Kò WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, LET US JUST SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTS TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT GREAT. MADAM CHAIR,
MEMBER. STANFILL, ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
? ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NOT REGISTERED, BUT IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WITH
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME TO THE
MIC NOW. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I THINK YOU WERE IN THE
ROOM WHEN I MENTIONED, MOST OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE OFF AT
OTHER COMMITTEES PRESENTING
BILLS. IT'S TIME OF YEAR, SO WE
CAN ENTERTAIN OUR MOTION YET,
BUT AS SOON AS WE HAVE SOME
FOLKS BACK, WE WILL. AND WITH
THAT, I'LL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
WELL, THANK YOU, I GUESS I'LL
JUST ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THEN,
SINCE WE CAN GET IT DONE. ONE.
NOTHING. BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANKS SO MUCH,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND WE WILL
ENTERTAIN THAT MOTION WHEN WE
HAVE FOLKS BACK IN THE ROOM. ALL
RIGHT. NOW, WE DON'T HAVE
AUTHORS. WE'LL WAIT A MOMENT TO
AWARENESS. AND FOR OTHERS, WE
STILL HAVE, FOUR BILLS, FOUR
AUTHORS. SO WE'LL SEE IF WE, IF
SOMEBODY GETS HERE SOON. OKAY.
SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE YOUR PEN
FOR A SECOND. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
MISSING. SO IT'S MCKENNA BALDWIN
MISSING. OKAY WE HAVE MCKENNA
MISSING. YEAH. MCKENNA OKAY. AND
HART AND SUBARU, I THINK NOT.
HART, AND I'M SORRY. YEAH. I
ALREADY DID MY WORDLE. OKAY.
SHE'S IN. SHE'S IN JUDICE. SHE'S
IN JUDICIAL.
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR. LET'S SEE ON
OUR LIST, WE WOULD GO TO MISS
WALDRON FIRST. SO, MISS WALDRON,
YOU WANT TO PRESENT AB26, TWO
FOUR IF YOU NEED A FEW MINUTES,
I COULD ALWAYS GO TO MISS,
MCKENNA. OKAY. I MEAN, SORRY,
MISS WILSON. GOD. SORRY ALL
RIGHT. THAT WAS A BIG MISTAKE.
AND YOU CAN, LASH ME 20 TIMES
FOR THAT ONE. ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON A B
2624. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A B 2624, WHICH IS A
CRUCIAL STEP TAKE IN TAKEN
TOWARDS SUPPORTING INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS DURING THEIR TIME OF
LOSS OF A LOVED ONE. FIRSTLY, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY TEAM
ON THE AMENDMENTS WHICH WE ARE
ACCEPTING THE PASSING OF A CLOSE
FAMILY MEMBER IS A DIFFICULT
TIME FOR ANYONE. PARTICULARLY SO
IF YOU ARE ISOLATED AND BEHIND
PRISON GATES EVERY INDIVIDUAL
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO GRIEVE AND
NEED THAT GOES BEYOND THE WALLS
OF INCARCERATION AND RECOGNIZES
THE HUMANITY OF US ALL. THIS
BILL ALLOWS INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO GRIEVE FOR UP TO
THREE DAYS WITH DIGNITY,
UNBURDENED FROM THE WEIGHT OF
THEIR WORK OR PROGRAMMATIC
DUTIES. DURING THIS TIME,
COMPENSATION WOULD STILL BE
RECEIVED FOR MISSED WORK,
ALLEVIATING ANY FURTHER WORRIES
AND MY VISITS WITH MANY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IN
SEVERAL PRISONS. I LEARNED THAT
THIS TIME OF LOSS, THIS TIME OF
GRIEVING, CAN BE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT TIMES OF HEALING,
EMPATHY, AND UNDERSTANDING. MANY
HAVE SAID THAT THE LOSS OF A
MOTHER, A BROTHER OR OTHER CLOSE
PERSON WAS THE IMPETUS TO OPEN
THE DOOR FOR POSITIVE CHANGE IN
THEIR LIFE. HAVING ACCESS DURING
THIS TIME TO A COUNSELOR OR
PASTOR TO ASSIST IN THE
EXPERIENCE IS VERY BENEFICIAL.
BUT HAVING THE TIME TO FEEL AND
GRIEVE IS NECESSARY. THIS BILL
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT
WILL CHANGE THE PATH FORWARD FOR
MANY INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
TODAY, I HAVE CAPRI WALKER WITH
THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION
JOINING US TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SKINNER, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS OR GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND WONDERFUL COMMITTEE STAFF,
CAPRI WALKER, ON BEHALF OF
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, WE
ARE HERE TODAY TO EMPHASIZE THE
CRITICAL NEED OF PROVIDING
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE LOST AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBER. GRIEVING IS A
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN EXPERIENCE,
AND THE PAIN OF LOSING A LOVED
ONE DOES NOT DIMINISH BEHIND
PRISON WALLS. INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALREADY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT EXACERBATES
MENTAL HEALTH STRUGGLES, AND
WITH THE COMPOUNDED GRIEF THAT
FROM THE LOSS OF A FAMILY MEMBER
WITHOUT ADEQUATE SPACE TO
PROCESS IT CAN LEAD TO SEVERE
EMOTIONAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
CONSEQUENCES. BEREAVEMENT LEAVE
OFFERS A VITAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
HONOR THEIR LOSS, PROCESS THEIR
GRIEF, AND BEGIN HEALING BY
ALLOWING THIS SPACE, WE NOT ONLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR HUMANITY, BUT
ALSO SUPPORT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AND REHABILITATION. IT IS OUR
MORAL DUTY TO ENSURE THAT EVEN
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED ARE
AFFORDED THE BASIC DIGNITY OF
GRIEVING THEIR LOVED ONES. WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? YOU CAN JUST COME TO
THE MIC. GO AHEAD. ME TOS. YES
LESLIE CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT ANTHONY
DEMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. CHRIS
LAWSON, POLICY MANAGER,
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
SUPPORT. CARRY OUR SYSTEM
IMPACTED AND MY HUSBAND HAS BEEN
INCARCERATED ALMOST TWO DECADES.
LOST HIS MOTHER AND HIS DAUGHTER
THIS YEAR. SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
BILL. Dð COONEY, ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JACK
CASTELO, A MEMBER OF THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION.
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CASSIE SCHER, MEMBER OF THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM AND STRONG
SUPPORT. FRANK ABELLA, ON BEHALF
OF THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KELLY
WALTERS, ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JOHN
VASQUEZ, ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
YOLANDA NAVARETTE ON BEHALF OF
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JESSE CLYDE BURLESON, LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US AND NONE
AND STRONG SUPPORT. IN OUR NAME,
ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JAMILA LAND,
CO-FOUNDER OF THE ANTI-VIOLENCE
SAFETY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PROJECT AND STRONG SUPPORT.
TATIANA LEWIS WITH THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TANISHA CANNON, LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. NÓI GODINO WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN IN SUPPORT. LINA
DIN. ALL OF US ARE NONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ROBERT BOWDEN,
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND STRONG SUPPORT
. MELISSA MOORE. ALL OF US ARE
NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT. HENRY
ORTIZ, LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US ARE NONE. SACRAMENTO AND
STRONG SUPPORT. JOE BROWN,
ANTHONY MURILLO WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TOCCOA BONNER WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. AND OLIVER SHANNON IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MÐI GIL, WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SIENNA COBURN, WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN IN SUPPORT HANNAH KHN
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MINISTER KING
ACTS AT CALIFORNIA PRISON. FOCUS
CASE. UNIVERSAL AND STRONG
SUPPORT. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL? OKAY. SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I'VE EXPLAINED
THIS, BUT I WILL DO SO FOR YOU.
ALSO, OUR OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE PRESENTING BILLS AND
OTHER COMMITTEES, SO WE CAN'T
TAKE A MOTION YET, BUT AS SOON
AS SOMEONE RETURNS, WE WILL. AND
WITH THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AB 2624 WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE TIME OFF
WORK AND EDUCATION TO PROPERLY
PROCESS AND GRIEVE THE LOSS OF A
LOVED ONE. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING MY
BILL AND ALL THOSE WHO CAME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU,
VERY MUCH FOR PRESENTING AND
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD. AND
LIKE I SAID, WE WILL ENTERTAIN
THAT, SO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON
WAS IN THE ROOM FIRST, BUT WE DO
FILE ORDER, AND MISS CHAPMAN
HAS, ARRIVED. SO WE WILL. ARE
YOU DEFERRING? OKAY, GREAT.
THEN, WONDERFUL. WE LOVE THAT
KIND OF COOPERATION, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. THEN YOU MAY
PRESENT ACA EIGHT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND I APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPP AND MY
COLLEAGUE AS A GIVER. I WAS A
GIVER. I KNOW HER TO BE. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT TODAY,
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS PRIORITY AS A PART OF OUR
REPARATIONS. REPARATIONS
PACKAGE. ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. ALSO KNOWN AS ACA
EIGHT. THE END SLAVERY IN
CALIFORNIA ACT, THIS ACA WOULD
ALLOW CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE TO AMEND
ARTICLE ONE, SECTION SIX OF THE
STATE CONSTITUTION TO PROHIBIT
SLAVERY AND INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE, WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
TODAY, SLAVERY TAKES ON THE
MODERN FORM OF INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE, INCLUDING FORCED
LABOR IN PRISONS. SLAVERY IS
WRONG IN ALL FORMS, AND
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE CLEAR AND
DENOUNCING THAT IN THE
CONSTITUTION. THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO GIVE CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE WITH THEIR
VALUES. WE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ARE AMONG ONLY 16 STATES WITH AN
EXCEPTION CLAUSE FOR INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE AND IN STATES
CONSTITUTION, MOST RECENTLY,
VOTERS IN ALABAMA, OREGON,
TENNESSEE AND VERMONT REMOVED
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. LANGUAGE
FROM THEIR STATE CONSTITUTIONS.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE HAVE LONG
FACED CRUEL TREATMENT FOR ANY
WORK ABSENCES. THIS INCLUDES
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE, SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT, DENIAL OF PHONE
CALLS, AND FAMILY VISITS, AND
LIMITING PARTICIPATION IN
SELF-HELP GROUPS, AS WELL AS
DISCIPLINARY WRITE-UPS THAT
RESULT IN LONGER PRISON TERMS
SUCH PUNISHMENTS OR THREATS OF
SUCH PUNISHMENTS ARE OFTEN
ISSUED EVEN WHEN ABSENCES ARE
DUE TO ILLNESSES OR INJURIES
SUSTAINED THROUGH THE WORK
ITSELF. FORCED LABOR GIVES WORK
A BAD NAME. INCARCERATED
PEOPLE'S RELATIONSHIP TO WORK
SHOULD NOT BE ONE OF
EXPLOITATION AND LITTLE TO NO
AGENCY. THE CURRENT PRACTICE OF
FORCED LABOR DOES NOT PREPARE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FOR SUCCESS
UPON REENTRY. LET ME REPEAT
BEFORE FORCED LABOR IS NOT
REHABILITATIVE. SO WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS DAVE VASQUEZ
WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE, YOUTH
JUSTICE AND JAMELIA LAND WITH
ANTI-VIOLENCE SAFETY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT. IT.
MADAM CHAIR, DO YOU WANT HIM TO
COME TO THERE OR STAY THERE, YOU
MAY SPEAK RIGHT THERE AT THE AT
THE PODIUM. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. WHEN I WAS
16, I WAS TRANSFERRED TO ADULT
COURT. AND SINCE 31 YEARS TO
LIFE AFTER A ROUGH START, I
DECIDED TO TURN MY LIFE AROUND
AND WANTED TI¾N A VICTIM IMPACT
CLASS. HOWEVER THE CLASS WAS
DURING MY WORK HOURS SO I WASN'T
ABLE TO ATTEND. HAD I PUT DOWN
THAT BROOM AND ATTENDED THE
CLASS, I WOULD HAVE BEEN ISSUED
A RULE VIOLATION REPORT AND THAT
REPORT COULD HAVE COST ME
POTENTIALLY A 10 OR 15 YEAR
DENIAL. SO WHEN I WENT FROM THE
PAROLE BOARD, PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
THE CHOICE WHETHER TO WORK OR
ATTEND REHABILITATION, SUCH AS
EDUCATION, VOCATIONAL TRAINING,
SUBSTANCE USE PROGRAMING,
SELF-HELP OR COLLEGE. ACA EIGHT
IS ABOUT ALLOWING INCARCERATED
PEOPLE THE AUTONOMY TO CHOOSE
WHAT REHABILITATIVE PATH THAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEM TO SUIT
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS. AT THE
MOMENT THERE AT ACA EIGHT IS NOT
ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN PRISONS FOR
A LACK OF WORKERS. MY EXPERIENCE
HAS SHOWN ME THAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE WANT TO WORK, AND THEY DO
SO FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS. ONE
OF THE WORST THINGS ABOUT DOING
TIME IS BOREDOM. MANY PEOPLE
WORK WANT TO WORK JUST TO GET
OFF THE CELL. OTHER PEOPLE
PREFER TO LOVE. THEY LIKE TO BE
ON THE YARD, SO THEY PREFER TO
BE YARD CREW. OTHERS, SUCH AS
MYSELF, I LOVE TO EAT. SO, YOU
KNOW, SOME PEOPLE PREFER TO WORK
IN THE KITCHEN WHILE OTHERS WANT
TO WORK AS PORTERS JUST SO THEY
GET EXTRA TOILET PAPER OR
CLEANING SUPPLIES. JUST LIKE IN
THE FREE COMMUNITY, PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT MOTIVATIONS FOR
WORKING AND WHAT TYPE OF WORK TO
DO. SO THE ASSUMPTION THAT
PRISONS WILL STOP RUNNING IF YOU
DON'T FORCE PEOPLE TO WORK IS
SIMPLY A MYTH. DURING MY 25
YEARS OF INCARCERATION, THERE
WERE NEVER ENOUGH JOBS TO
ACCOMMODATE EVERYBODY. I WAS ON
A WAITING LIST, A JOB WAITING
LIST FOR OVER THREE YEARS. ACA
EIGHT WILL ACTUALLY IMPROVE
WORKER PRODUCTIVITY BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO BE IN WORK
ASSIGNMENTS THAT THEY ACTUALLY
CHOOSE TO BE IN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANOTHER,
TWO KEY WITNESSES? GREAT. YOU
MAY YOU MAY PROCEED. AND TWO
MINUTES. SO GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS JAMILIA LAND, IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE CO-FOUNDER
OF THE ANTI-VIOLENCE SAFETY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT, I AM
ALSO CO-DIRECTOR OF STATE
OPERATIONS FOR THE ABOLISH
SLAVERY NATIONAL NETWORK. WE ARE
THE NATIONAL COALITION THAT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY HELPED TO REMOVE
THESE UNJUST MUST CLAUSES. I
HAVE A QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU
ALL BY A SHOW OF HANDS, IF YOU
WOULD NOT MIND, HOW MANY OF YOU
HAVE EVER STEPPED INSIDE OF A
PRISON, KEEP GOING. HOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE A LOVED ONE WHO HAS
BEEN IN PRISON, OR A COMMUNITY
MEMBER THAT YOU HAVE HAD TO
SUPPORT? OKAY, SO WE HAVE A LOT
OF MYTHS, AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU, JAY, FOR ADDRESSING SOME OF
THEM. WE HAVE BEEN SOCIALLY
INDOCTRINATED TO BELIEVE THAT
WORK IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
REHABILITATION. IT IS NOT. WE
ALSO RESIDE IN A STATE THAT
TOUTS TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE IN THE COUNTRY, AND
WE ARE VERY PROUD TO STATE THAT
WE ENTERED THE UNION AS A FREE
STATE. HOWEVER, OUR LAWS DO NOT
REFLECT THAT. IN ADDITION TO
HAVING INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE AS
A FORM OF PUNISHMENT IN OUR
CONSTITUTION, WE HAVE ALSO GONE
SO FAR AS TO CODIFY IT IN OUR
PENAL CODE. PENAL CODE SECTION
2700 STATES THAT EVERY ABLE
BODIED PERSON INCARCERATED IN A
CALIFORNIA PRISON SHALL PERFORM
AS MANY HOURS OF FAITHFUL LABOR
EACH AND EVERY DAY, AS
PRESCRIBED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
IF THAT DOES NOT SOUND LIKE
LEGALIZED CONSTITUTIONAL SLAVERY
TO YOU, I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE. ARE YOU
FAMILIAR THAT THERE IS AN AGENCY
CALLED CALPIA, THE CALIFORNIA
PRISON INDUSTRY AUTHORITY? DO
YOU KNOW THAT THEY PRODUCE SOME
OF EVERYTHING? YOU KNOW, THIS
PODIUM THAT I'M STANDING AT
LIKELY IS PRODUCED AT CALPIA,
SAME AS THE MEMBER. THESE CHAIRS
, YOUR CHAIRS, THE DESK IN YOUR
OFFICE. THIS IS BEYOND WHAT IT
MAY LOOK LIKE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CONVERSATION
HAS BEEN FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AS YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR WAS ACA
THREE AND IT HAS BEEN
PREDOMINANTLY FOCUSED ON WAGES.
AND LET'S BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WAGES. THIS IS
ABOUT HUMANIZING A DEMOGRAPHIC
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
RELEGATED TO THE DARKEST CORNER
OF SUBHUMANITY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THIS COUNTRY, FOR
WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY THAT A
CONSTITUTION STATES THAT PERSONS
WHO LOOK LIKE I AND THE MAJORITY
OF US IN THIS ROOM ARE 3/5 OF A
HUMAN BEING FOR PURPOSES OF
REPRESENTATION IN A SOCIALLY
CONSTRUCTED ENTITY THAT OUR
LIVES HAVE NO VALUE. YOU NEED TO
WRAP UP. YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT, I WILL STATE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FINALLY UNDO WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE. LET'S HUMANIZE THE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT ARE BEHIND THE
CARCERAL WALLS. LET'S SHOW THE
REST OF THE WORLD THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN AND IN FACT, IS
PROGRESSIVE. AND FINALLY PUT AN
END TO LEGALIZED CONSTITUTIONAL
SLAVERY. ALL RIGHT. AND WE CAN
NOW HAVE THE ADD ONS JUST COME
UP. YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. SO THIS IS THE SUPPORT,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MY NAME
IS SEDALIA KING. ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE OF THE REPARATIONS,
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
FOR CIVIC EMPOWERMENT, ÁP FORCE
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
DANICA ADAMO. ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND THE GRIP
TRAINING INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ADRIANA CHAMPAGNE
ZAMORA WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LAURENCE COX
WITH ALL OF US ARE N N STRONG
SUPPORT. CARRIE ARZATE WITH
PRISON FROM THE INSIDE OUT AND
CALIFORNIA IMPACTED FAMILIES BY
INCARCERATION AND OUR YOUTH THAT
ARE ALSO IMPACTED HERE,
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YOLANDA NAVARETTE, ON BEHALF OF
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KRISTIN NIMMERS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK POWER
NETWORK, ALSO PART OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR REPARATIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
CARMEN NICOLE COX ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD
CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU. HANNAH
KHN WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. KELLY WALTERS A
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND STRONG
SUPPORT. PRISCILLA. KUDOS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT. ANTHONY DEMARTINO,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SIENNA COBURN, WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND STRONG SUPPORT
. MÐI GILL WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
I'M JOHN CANNON WITH ALL OF US
OR NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TANISHA CANNON WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US ARE NONE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ANTONIO
AGUILAR, ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN, A PROUD CO-SPONSOR,
ALSO WANT TO READ OFF OTHER
CO-SPONSORS IN SUPPORT
INTERFAITH MOVEMENT FOR HUMAN
INTEGRITY. YOUTH LEADERSHIP
INSTITUTE, BEND THE ARC A NEW
WAY OF LIFE. CARAVAN FOR JUSTICE
. FREEDOM FOR YOUTH. LEGAL AID
AT WORK. THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
VOTE PROJECT, FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AND CONVICTED
PEOPLE AND FAMILIES MOVEMENT,
WORK SAFE ASIAN PRISONER SUPPORT
COMMITTEE, AND ABOLISH BONDAGE
COLLECTIVELY. THANK YOU. FRANK
ABELLA WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MINISTER
KING ASKED THE CALIFORNIA PRISON
FOCUS AND STRONG SUPPORT ALSO
LIKE TO NAME OFF SOME OF THE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AND STRONG
SUPPORT CGRTS UNIVERSAL LIBERATE
OUR ELDERS, POOR MAGAZINE, SAN
FRANCISCO BAY VIEW AUTONOMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ALL OF HIS
CADRE AND FERM STRONG SUPPORT.
JESSE CLYDE BURLESON, LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US AND NONE.
ALSO THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
REPARATIONS COMMISSION. I'M A
COMMISSIONER ON THAT AS WELL.
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CHRIS LAWSON, ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR A JUST AND EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA, BOTH CO-SPONSORS THE
AMERICAN REDRESS COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA, SACRAMENTO, AMERICAN
REDRESS COALITION OF CALIFORNIA,
BAY AREA, LINEAGE EQUITY AND
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT, AND THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK LINEAGE SOCIETY
, ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. PAMELA COUCH WITH BRIAN
GOETZ, LAW OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. JACK CASTELO, A MEMBER
OF THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GILBERT ANTHONY MURILLO WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND ALL OF US,
NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINA
DIÆN, LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ROBERT BOWDEN,
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND STRONG SUPPORT
. IN ORTIZ WITH LEGAL FOR LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US IN ON THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TATIANA
LEWIS, ON BEHALF OF THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KATHY SCHER, MEMBER OF
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY NAME. MY NAME
IS TI¾N. I AM A MEMBER OF
TACOMA'S YOUTH DIVERSION TIED
AND I SUPPORT THE END OF SLAVERY
. MY NAME IS TAQWA BONNER, WHO
IS AN ADVOCATE OF ALL OF US AND
NONE. AND LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. NOIW GODINO WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. AND ALL OF US ARE
NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT. TAMIKA
ROBINSON WOULD TALK, WAS YOUTH
DIVERSION AND TIED IN STRONG
SUPPORT. JOHNNA MOREHOUSE,
CONSTITUENT OF DISTRICT 51 AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT. LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. GREAT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER? GO AHEAD,
ANNIE CHAU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JODI PRUNIER, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS FOR THE ARTS,
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BRENNAN GREEN
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY STRONG SUPPORT. SALLY
CHING WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR IN SUPPORT.
CAPRI WALKER, ON BEHALF OF
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
ALYSSA MOORE. ALL OF US ARE NONE
AND ALSO FOR OUR IN SUPPORT OF
OUR RIVERSIDE CHAPTERS ORANGE
COUNTY, LONG BEACH, LOS ANGELES
AND SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. JIM
LINDBERG, FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BILL MELENDEZ,
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. JAMAL YELLEN, ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THE
INCARCERATED MEN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN INSIDE OF OUR SYSTEM IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. WE STAND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL?
REGISTERED OPPOSITION? I DON'T
THINK WE HAD REGISTERED. SO DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTS TO INDICATE OR TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING NONE, I
DON'T AS I'VE MENTIONED,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON,
APOLOGIES, BUT WE HAVE MEMBERS
IN OTHER COMMITTEES AT THAT TIME
OF YEAR. YES. AND AS I KNOW, YOU
JUST CAME FROM A COMMITTEE. SO
YOU YOU KNOW THAT, THERE'S MANY
COMMITTEES GOING ON, BUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS.
I HAVE SUPPORTED, THE VARIOUS,
VERSIONS OF THIS EFFORT TO FIX
OUR CONSTITUTION LAST YEARS AND
THE PREVIOUS. I THINK IT WAS
PREVIOUS, MAYBE TWO PRIOR YEARS,
WITH, SENATOR, NOW,
CONGRESSMEMBER SIDNEY KAMLAGER
DOVE AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
TESTIMONY AND THE REASONS, BUT I
THINK THAT WE I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT ADDITIONALLY, WE KNOW THAT,
IF WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF HOW
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN OUR
COUNTRY BEGAN, THEY BEGAN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF, GOING AFTER,
QUOTE UNQUOTE, ESCAPED SLAVES.
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF
MANY OF OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
AND, OF COURSE, THEN ONCE THEY
WERE PICKED UP, THEY WERE NOT
ONLY RETURNED TO A SLAVE OWNER,
BUT RATHER INCARCERATED. AND
THEN THAT INCARCERATION WAS USED
TO REPLACE THE LABOR THAT THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN
PERFORMING, ENSLAVED. AND THAT
IS WHAT ALSO, WHY THIS IS SO AT
ODDS WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE OUR
US CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
FORBIDS SLAVERY, THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT THAT, IN EFFECT,
APPROVES IT OR ALLOWS IT. IT IS
COMPLETELY INCONSISTENT AND IT
IS LONG. IT'S BEEN LONG TIME FOR
US TO CORRECT IT, NOW I
UNDERSTAND MANY PEOPLE CAME
FORWARD AND TALKED ABOUT THIS IS
NOT WAGES. AND IT'S TRUE THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT IS SILENT ON
THAT. I THINK, HOWEVER, WE ALL
WOULD LIKE TO SEE, WHEN WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HELD IN OUR
STATE FACILITIES AND THEY ARE
DOING WORK, THEY'RE PERFORMING
WORK EITHER TO SUPPORT THE
INSTITUTION OR TO PROVIDE, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE FURNITURE, AS WAS
POINTED OUT, IS PRODUCED, OR
OTHERS. THE THE PALTRY
COMPENSATION THAT IS RECEIVED.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THAT, WE
EXPECT INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
TO PAY RESTITUTION THÀNH WE
EXPECT THEM TO HAVE TO COVER
COSTS OF MANY THINGS THAT THEY
NEED WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
FACILITY, AND TO PROVIDE THEM
THE KIND OF RIDICULE $0.06 ON A
DOLLAR THAT WE DO. BUT AGAIN, I
BRING THAT UP, NOT TO CONFUSE
THE ISSUE, BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THAT, BUT I DO THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE AT SOME POINT FOR
SOMEONE. THIS IS MY LAST YEAR.
SO BUT FOR SOMEONE TO BRING
FORWARD A MEASURE NOW WE'RE IN A
BUDGET DEFICIT. SO THAT WOULD BE
QUITE DIFFICULT TO DO SO IN THIS
YEAR. BUT I THINK IT IS
APPROPRIATE THING FOR WE AS THE
STATE TO LOOK AT. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME, THIS IS A PRINCIPLED
MEASURE. AND IT'S A PRINCIPLED
MEASURE BECAUSE IT WOULD CORRECT
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION AND A
CORRECT IT FROM SOMETHING THAT
IT PUTS IT AT GREAT ODDS TO OUR
US CONSTITUTION. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON, YOU BRINGING IT BACK.
AND EVERYONE WHO CAME HERE AND
TESTIFIED, AND LIKE I SAID, WE
WILL HAVE TO WAIT TO A MOTION,
BUT I WILL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. AND AND, THEY ARE DULY
NOTED. AND AS YOU STATED, THE
WAGE ISSUE IS NOT A PART OF THIS
ISSUE, BUT WE CAN'T EVEN GET TO
THAT CONVERSATION WITHOUT, DOING
THIS FIRST. AND AS AS MUCH AS
I'M PROUD TO BE THE AUTHOR THAT
INTRODUCED THE BILL, IT IS A
PART OF THE BLACK CAUCUS
REPARATIONS PACKAGE. ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE BLACK CAUCUS,
INCLUDING MY FELLOW SENATOR HERE
, ARE JOINT, YOU KNOW, AUTHORS
WITH ME, IN THIS EFFORT. AND IT
IS, YOU KNOW, A PRIORITY OF US
TO DEAL WITH THIS. THIS IS THE
LEGACY OF SLAVERY. AND WE KNOW
THAT, AS YOU NOTED IN YOUR
COMMENTS, THAT SLAVERY AND
FORCED LABOR RUNS DEEP IN NOT
JUST THE STATES, THE NATION'S
HISTORY, BUT IN OUR VERY STATE,
WHETHER IT'S THE EXPLOITATION OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND SPANISH
MISSIONS TO BLACK SLAVES BEING
FORCED TO MINE FOR GOLD, WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A STEP IN
THE DIRECTION TOWARDS ENDING
THAT LEGACY. AND THIS BILL,
THROUGHOUT ITS HISTORY, HAS
ENJOYED NO OPPOSITION ON RECORD
OR TESTIFYING AGAINST IT. SO IT
IS REALLY, I BELIEVE, CONSISTENT
WITH CALIFORNIA'S VALUES. AND
IT'S TIME WE SHOWED IT IN
WRITING AND NOT JUST IN TALK. SO
WITH THAT, I, AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, URGE A STRONG AYE VOTE. I
THANK YOU FOR THAT. CLOSE. WE DO
HAVE A MEMBER HERE, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION, YES. I'D LIKE TO MAKE
THE MOTION. I WOULD ALSO GO
AHEAD, PLEASE. I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN MEMBER WILSON FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE, FOR OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUES. NOW, CONGRESSWOMAN
SIDNEY KAMLAGER HAD THIS BILL
THREE YEARS AGO AND UNFORTUNATE
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO GET IT OFF
OUR SENATE FLOOR. AND WHO WOULD
THINK IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN 2022 THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
MEMBERS WHO STILL BELIEVE THAT
SLAVERY IS FINE, WHETHER YOU'RE
IN PRISON OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE? SO THIS CLEARLY SENDS A
MESSAGE THAT SLAVERY SHOULD NOT
BE ACCEPTED, EXPECTED,
PERMITTED, WHETHER YOU'RE
INCARCERATED OR NOT. WE NEED TO
REMOVE THIS FROM OUR
CONSTITUTION. WE SHOULD REMOVE
IT FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE STATE STAIN OF THIS
NATION. MANY TIMES WE SAY
CALIFORNIA WASN'T A SLAVE STATE.
WELL, THIS IS A PRIME EXAMPLE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS VERY MUCH AND
HAS BEEN A SLAVE STATE. SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING AYE ON THIS MEASURE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION SO WE CAN, TAKE A
ROLL CALL ON IT. WE WILL HAVE TO
KEEP IT OPEN BECAUSE WE HAVE
MEMBERS MISSING, BUT WE CAN DO
THE ROLL CALL, SO PLEASE
PROCEED. AK EIGHT WILSON BE
ADOPTED AND RE REFERRED TO
ELECTIONS. WAHAB SEYARTO
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON CALL. HAS
TWO AYE VOTES. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAPAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURTESY. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR BILL. NOW GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. NICE
TO BE WITH YOU TODAY. SO I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 2842, WHICH
IS A CRUCIAL STEP TOWARDS
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS FROM THE
DANGERS OF GHOST GUNS. I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK,
ON THIS BILL. AND THERE HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS AND
I TRULY APPRECIATE IT. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS CONFISCATED GUNS TO BE
RESURRECTED IN GHOST FORM.
SHOCKINGLY, GUN BUYBACKS AND
CONFISCATION HAVE RESULTED IN A
PROLIFERATION OF UNTRACEABLE
FIREARMS OR GHOST GUNS THAT
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO BYPASS
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND EVADE
ACCOUNTABILITY. HOW DOES THIS
HAPPEN? CURRENTLY, THERE ARE NO
GUIDELINES ON THE PROPER
DISPOSAL OF THESE WEAPONS IN THE
ABSENCE OF STATE GUIDANCE, LOCAL
AGENCIES, HAVE CONTRACTED WITH
THIRD PARTY COMPANIES FOR, QUOTE
UNQUOTE DESTRUCTION, A LOOPHOLE
IN THE DEFINITION OF A FIREARM
ALLOWS THESE COMPANIES TO
LEGALLY DESTROY A WEAPON BY
MERELY DISMANTLING ITS INTERIOR
FRAME OR RECEIVER, WHICH
ESSENTIALLY IS THE SKELETON OF
THE WEAPON. THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWS
FIREARM DESTRUCTION COMPANIES TO
THEN SELL THE REMAINING PARTS AS
EASILY ASSEMBLED GUN KITS
ONLINE, WITH THE CHAIR'S
PERMISSION, I DO HAVE A HANDOUT.
YOU HAVE IT. OKAY, GREAT. THANK
YOU, AND I APOLOGIZE FOR HOW
SMALL THIS HANDOUT IS, BUT THE
VISUAL AID WILL SHOW YOU WHICH
PART IS REMOVED. IT'S LOCATED
WITH A RED ARROW, AND THAT IS
THE ONLY PART OF A COLT 1911
HANDGUN THAT GETS REMOVED. THE
REST IS SOLD AS A KIT. AND, WHAT
HAPPENS IS, BEFORE YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE HIGHLIGHTED THERE'S A
RED ARROW THAT SHOWS WHICH PART
HAS TO BE DESTROYED. ALL ELSE
REMAINS INTACT. THEN YOU CAN SEE
A HIGHLIGHTED PORTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE, WHICH STATES THAT
THE ONLY THING THIS IS LACKING
IS THE RECEIVER, WHICH CAN BE
EASILY RECREATED BY A 3D PRINTER
OR A CNC MACHINE. THERE IS NO
SERIAL NUMBER ON THE NEWLY
CREATED GUN MADE UP OF THE KIT,
AND THE 3D CREATED PART. IT'S AN
UNTRACEABLE GHOST GUN. MY BILL
WOULD STOP THE UNINTENDED
CREATION OF GHOST GUNS BY
PROHIBITING GUN CONSTRUCTION
COMPANIES FROM RESELLING
LEFTOVER GUN PARTS. FOLLOWING
THE DESTRUCTION OF THE FIREARM
MECHANISM. TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA
ABOUT THE PROLIFERATION
PROLIFERATION OF GHOST GUNS FROM
2010 TO 2020, LAW ENFORCEMENT
RECOVERED SOME 39,000 GHOST GUNS
. FROM 21 TO 22 ALONE. LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECOVERED 45,000
GHOST GUNS. WE CAN'T ALLOW THIS
CRISIS TO SPIRAL FURTHER OUT OF
CONTROL. AB 2842 ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY ENSURING FIREARMS
CONFISCATED FROM CRIME SCENES
AND GUN BUYBACK PROGRAMS CANNOT
BE REPURPOSED INTO NEW GHOST
GUNS. IT MANDATES THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES ONLY CONTRACT WITH
FIREARM DESTRUCTION COMPANIES IF
THE AGREEMENT PROHIBITS THE
RESALE OF ANY GUN PARTS. THIS
MEASURE ENDS THE CURRENT
PRACTICE WHILE LEAVING OPEN TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTORS. WHAT THEY
ULTIMATELY WANT TO DO WITH IT.
WE'RE ALSO HAPPY TO ACCEPT A
POREC HAD AN AMENDMENT THAT
DEALT WITH, DONATING ANTIQUE OR
HISTORICALLY SIGNIFICANT WEAPONS
TO MUSEUMS. WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THAT WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
DANNY CLARK, WHO IS A MOMS
DEMAND ACTION VOLUNTEER, AND I
HAPPEN TO HAVE GROWN UP IN MY
DISTRICT, SO I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY WITNESS, GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY Kò WITNESS TO, MINUTES.
OKAY. HELLO, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DANNY CLARK. I'M A
MEMBER OF MOMS ACTION. ALTHOUGH
TODAY I'M JUST HERE AS A
CONCERNED CITIZEN. I CARE ABOUT
MY COMMUNITY AND WANT TO TAKE
CARE OF MY COMMUNITY. AND I SEE
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION AS PART
OF THAT. I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PEPIN'S AB 2842, WHICH WILL STOP
THE ABILITY OF GUN DESTRUCTION
COMPANIES FROM SELLING LEFTOVER
GUN PARTS FOLLOWING THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE FRAME OR
RECEIVER AT A TIME OF INCREASING
GUN VIOLENCE. THE GROWING EASE
OF PURCHASING GUN KITS ONLINE
PRESENTS A DIRE THREAT TO PUBLIC
WELFARE, ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO
PROCURE FIREARM COMPONENTS
ONLINE WITHOUT PROPER REGULATION
AND OVERSIGHT IS A RECKLESS
DISREGARD FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THESE GUN KITS
BYPASS THE NECESSARY BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND SAFEGUARDS THAT ARE
IN PLACE WHEN PURCHASING
FIREARMS THROUGH LICENSED
DEALERS. THEY PROVIDE AN AVENUE
FOR INDIVIDUALS, INCLUDING
MINORS, THOSE WITH CRIMINAL
INTENTS OR MENTAL INSTABILITY,
TO OBTAIN DEADLY WEAPONS WITH
MINIMAL SCRUTINY. IN FACT, A
WOMAN WHO WAS ABUSED IS FIVE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE AT THE
HANDS OF HER ABUSER WHEN THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO A GUN BY
PERMITTING THE ONLINE SALE OF
GUN KITS, WE ARE ESSENTIALLY
HANDING DANGEROUS FIREPOWER TO
ANYONE WITH INTERNET CONNECTION
AND CREDIT CARD, UNDERMINING
EFFORTS TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
AND PROTECT INNOCENT LIVES. THIS
PRACTICE NOT ONLY FUELS THE
PROLIFERATION OF UNREGISTERED
FIREARMS IN OUR COMMUNITIES, BUT
ALSO MAKES IT EXCEEDINGLY
DIFFICULT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TRACK AND REGULATE THEIR
DISTRIBUTION. WE CANNOT IGNORE
THE ALARMING CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS LOOPHOLE IN OUR GUN LAWS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE TAKE
DECISIVE ACTION TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES AND ENACT
COMPREHENSIVE MEASURES TO ENSURE
THAT FIREARMS ARE OBTAINED
THROUGH LAWFUL AND ACCOUNTABLE
CHANNELS. THIS B2842 OFFERS A
SOLUTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. I EXTREMELY I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES? NO. SEEING NONE.
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ME TWOS SEEING
NONE. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
WOULD YOU GUYS LIKE TO COMMENT?
I WILL MOVE THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, I JUST
THINK THIS IS A PRAGMATIC
APPROACH TO REDUCING GHOST GUNS,
AND I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND
REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
PRAGMATIC SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER, AND IF WE CAN
GET A ROLL CALL, VOTE, PLEASE.
AB 2842, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WILL HAVE A
HAVE A SEYARTO BRADFORD A
BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE. WIENER THE BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DEFINITELY,
WE ARE. WE WOULD LIKE THE
SERGEANT TO CALL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA TO SHOW UP. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART, IF POSSIBLE. WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS MOTIONS
ON. DO YOU WANT TO DO THE
MOTION? LET'S LET'S ASK FOR A
MOTION ON SOME BILLS. WHICH ONE?
AB 2295. ADDIS NEEDS A MOTION. I
AM SO MOVED. SENATOR SKINNER
MOVES THE BILL. CAN WE GET A
ROLL CALL? VOTE MOTION IS. DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB.
AYE. SEYARTO BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER A SKINNER. AYE.
WIENER. THAT BILLS ON CALL AB
2624. MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATION AS IT
NEEDS A MOTION. CAN I GET A
MOTION SO MOVED. SENATOR SKINNER
MOVES. LET'S GET A ROLL CALL.
VOTE. WAHAB. AYE, AYE. SATO
BRADFORD. YEAH, I BRADFORD. AYE
SKINNER. I SKINNER. AYE. WIENER
THAT BILLS ON CALL. AB 26 AB
2681 WEBER NEEDS A MOTION SO
MOVED SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES.
LET'S GET A ROLL CALL. VOTE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, A WAHAB.
AYE. SATO. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
WIENER THANK YOU. 27 THAT BILLS
ON CALL AB 2739 MAIENSCHEIN
NEEDS A MOTION. SO MOVED.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES THE BILL,
CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL? VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS, WAHAB. AYE, AYE.
SATO BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. WIENER
THAT. BILLS ON CALL. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS THAT ARE ON CALL?
LIKE I COULD ADD ON TO. YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH. CAN WE HIT THE ROAD?
YEAH. SO YOU WERE HERE FOR THAT?
I KNOW THERE WERE A COUPLE. I
WASN'T. SENATOR, CAN WE ADD. CAN
WE LIFT THE CALLS? YEAH ITEM TEN
AB 19, AB 1960. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR.
AYE. VICE CHAIR. NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD A BRADFORD. AYE.
SKINNER A SKINNER. AYE WIENER
THAT BILLS ON CALL. AB 2943
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR AYE. VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING. SKINNER 2943.
ITEM 22. SORRY OH, OKAY. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE THAT BILL'S ON
CALL. DID I VOTE FOR THAT? I
DON'T HAVE YES. I HAVE YOU AS AN
AYE. HAS YOU LISTED. DO YOU NOT
HAVE WHAT DO YOU WANT TO CALL
THEM AGAIN. JUST TO MAKE SURE.
OKAY. MOTION WAS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE ADD BILLS ON CALL.
30 ZERO NINE ON THE REST OF
THEM. YEAH WE HAVEN'T VOTED ON A
NUMBER OF THEM. LET'S START FROM
THE TOP. START FROM. SO WE NEED
TO START FROM IRWIN ALL THE WAY
DOWN. YEAH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
LET'S GO. I'M GONNA GO ALL THE
WAY. OKAY. LET'S START FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING. THIS IS MÁS. I
THINK THESE GUYS ARE ALL. LET'S
JUST LET'S JUST. SO FOR CLARITY,
LET'S JUST START FROM NUMBER ONE
AND GO THROUGH FILE ITEM ORDER.
IRWIN. NUMBER ONE, NUMBER ONE,
NUMBER TWO. ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
ITEM FOUR AB 1810. MOTION WAS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AS VICE
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. BRADFORD A BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER A SKINNER. AYE ITEM
FIVE AB 2215. MOTION WAS Dð
PASSED TO THE FLOOR. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO. BRADFORD A. BRADFORD. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SKINNER AYE. SKINNER.
AYE ITEM SEVEN AB 1814. MOTION
WAS Dð. PASS TO JUDICIARY, CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
ITEM 12 AB 3209. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING.
NOT VOTING. BRADFORD A BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER A SKINNER. AYE.
MOTION. MONEY. OKAY. SO AK
EIGHT. WILSON. MOTION WAS BE
ADOPTED AND REFERRED TO
ELECTIONS. WAHAB, I HAVE AYE.
ALL RIGHT. I THINK THAT'S ALL
WE'VE GOT. I THINK THAT'S ALL
WE'VE GOT. ALL RIGHT. I VOTE FOR
ANY ONE WAS ON CONSENT AND I
THINK WE JUST RAISED THE ISSUE
ON THE OTHER ONE. LET ME SEE.
MEMBER. HART AND SKINNER.
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING? AB 3077?
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 3077.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, JUDGE REYES
MAY CONSIDER A DEFENDANT'S
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSIS WHEN
EVALUATING IF THE DEFENDANT IS
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
ELIGIBLE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. JUDGES ALSO HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO REDUCE THE
PENALTIES FOR A DEFENDANT WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS, IF DOING SO IS
IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. INDIVIDUALS WITH
BORDERLINE PERSONALITY DISORDER,
HOWEVER, ARE EXCLUDED FROM THESE
PROVISIONS. DATA SHOWS THAT 2 TO
6% OF THE POPULATION SUFFERS
FROM BORDERLINE PERSONALITY
DISORDER, AND IS NOW KNOWN TO BE
TREATABLE WITH A COMBINATION OF
PSYCHOTHERAPY AND MEDICATION.
THE EXCLUSION EXISTING LAW IS
NOT DATA DRIVEN, PERPETUATES
HARMFUL STIGMA ABOUT THE
DISORDER, AND LIMITS ACCESS TO
NECESSARY MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. AB 3077 WILL ADD
BORDERLINE PERSONALITY DISORDER
TO THE EXISTING LIST OF
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSIS. THE
JUDGES MAY CONSIDER WHEN
EVALUATING IF DEFENDANTS ARE
COMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
ELIGIBLE TO HAVE THEIR
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS
DISMISSED. THE BILL WILL
INCREASE EQUITY WITHIN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH BORDERLINE PERSONALITY
DISORDER AND HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RATES. SPEAKING
SUPPORTED THE BILL WITH ME TODAY
IS JOHN DREBINGER FROM THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. YOU'LL HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR I'M NOT JOHN
DREBINGER. I LIKE HIM VERY MUCH
AND USED TO EMPLOY HIM. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON, ARE
WE AFTERNOON YET, CLOSE TO IT.
CHAIR WAHAB. MEMBERS AND STAFF.
I AM DOCTOR LEONDRA CLARK
HARVEY, A PSYCHOLOGIST AND THE
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES, WHERE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER CLINICS
SERVING A MILLION OF THE FOLKS
THAT LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICTS. THE
GOOD NEWS TODAY IS THAT BY
BORDERLINE PERSONALITY DISORDER
IS TREATABLE AND TREATMENT
REDUCES THE RISK OF RECIDIVISM,
I KNOW THIS BECAUSE I'VE WORKED
IN AN IST PROGRAM IN ANOTHER
STATE. THE BAD NEWS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT LAW
EXCLUDES BPD PERPETUATING
HARMFUL STIGMA ABOUT THE
DISORDER AND LIMITING ACCESS TO
TREATMENT. AT ITS CORE, AB 3077
IS ABOUT EQUITY. PEOPLE WITH BPD
SHOULD BE TREATED THE SAME AS
PEOPLE WITH THE DISORDERS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR IST,
INCLUDING DEPRESSION, ANXIETY,
SCHIZOPHRENIA AND MANY, MANY
OTHERS. THERE'S NO CLINICAL OR
SCIENTIFIC REASON TO EXCLUDE BPD
IN LAW. RESEARCH AND CLINICAL
KNOWLEDGE HAS ADVANCED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND SO SHOULD THE
STATUTE AND IF IT DOES? IF IT
DOES NOT, WE WILL ALL BE
COMPLICIT IN PERPETUATING
STIGMA, LEADING TO FEWER PEOPLE
RECEIVING A BPD DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT. IF THIS BILL SEEMS
FAMILIAR, IT IS LAST YEARS AB
1412 REMOVED ALMOST IDENTICAL
LANGUAGE ABOUT BPD AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAM.
THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORTED AB
1412. THE FULL ASSEMBLY
SUPPORTED AB 1412, THE SENATE
SUPPORTED IT, AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SIGNED IT INTO LAW. SO WE
URGE YOU ALSO TO SUPPORT AB 3077
TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES? SEEING NONE.
LEAD OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE.
WE'LL MOVE TO METOOS. DANICA
DÂN, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BRADFORD, MOVE THE BILL. CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? VOTE, PLEASE?
MAYBE 30, 77. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB
Ã. AYE. SEYARTO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE. ALL RIGHT, SO THAT BILLS ON
CALL. I APPRECIATE IT. WE ARE
WAITING ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKENNA. SHE'S ON HER WAY. BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT MEANS SHE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN OVER.
WHAT IS IT? WHAT DO WE HAVE? NO.
THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR MOCENIGO'S
. GOOD THINGS GO SMOOTHLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY. YEP GOOD.
OKAY. THIS IS. THE LAST PUBLIC
SAFETY SPACE AT 2200. AND.
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. OKAY OKAY. YOU GUYS MIGHT
HAVE TO WAIT BECAUSE I COME OVER
HERE. SHE'S GOT. AND, YOU KNOW,
I'LL LET HER KNOW, BUT I'LL.
I'LL WALK UP AND TELL HER, WHERE
ARE YOU AT? I HAD TO SKIP
BREAKFAST. AND WHAT CAN WE DO?
YOU STARTED. ONE IS ONE OF THEM.
I'M GOING TO GO. THAT WAY,
EVERYTHING GOOD? WITH ONE STAFF.
THAT'S OKAY. YEAH. SO WE.
Þ. YEAH. IT'S. OKAY.
NO ISSUES. AND I JUST. SCHEDULED
. SO SHE'S ON HER WAY OVER. OH,
BOY.
ALL RIGHT, FOLKS, IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A RECESS OF PUBLIC SAFETY,
AND WE'RE GOING TO ASK EVERYONE
TO RETURN AT 145. THANK YOU.
START. ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
RECONVENES. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA PRESENT.
AB 2833, FOLLOWED BY AB 3127.
THESE ARE THE LAST TWO.
BEGINNING FOR THE HEART. BILL,
WHY DON'T WE DO? BECAUSE I JUST
WANT TO GET MINE'S DONE. OKAY
FINAL ITEM, NUMBER 24, AB 3077.
OKAY. THANK YOU. I DON'T HAVE. I
ITEM 24, AB 3077. CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 0. WAHAB I MEAN, SORRY.
SEYARTO NØ. SATO. NO. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FINAL
ITEM NUMBER 13, AB 2833 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, AND I WILL LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2833, A BILL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
ADMISSIBILITY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY,
CONFIDENTIALITY, PROTECTION FOR
ALL RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESSES THAT OCCUR WITHIN THE
STATE. CURRENTLY, SEVERAL
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
CONFIDENTIALITY BY ENTERING INTO
MOUS WITH LOCAL PROSECUTORS
OFFICES AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. THESE MOUS TYPICALLY
GOVERN ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM'S
OPERATIONS, INCLUDING
CONFIDENTIALITY. THOSE CHOOSE
THOSE, CHOOSE WHAT IS
CONFIDENTIAL AND TYPICALLY
PREVENT INFORMATION OBTAINED
DURING A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESS FROM BEING USED AGAINST
THE PERSON WHO CAUSED HARM IN
FUTURE PROCEEDINGS. HOWEVER, NOT
ALL ORGANIZATIONS USE MOUS, AND
IT IS INCREDIBLY LABOR INTENSIVE
TO NEGOTIATE AND RENEGOTIATE
THESE AGREEMENTS. IT ALSO LEADS
TO INCONSISTENCIES ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND RESULT IN A
PATCHWORK OF UNDERSTAND ING
REGARDING CONFIDENTIALITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS, RATHER THAN A
COMPREHENSIVE PROTECTION RELATED
TO RESTORATIVE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PROCESSES. ADDITIONALLY
THESE MOUS ARE HIGHLY SUBJECT TO
LOCALIZED POLITICS AND THUS NEED
IN NEED OF STANDARDIZING AND
CREATING AND GIVING GUARDRAILS
THAT CAN COME FROM WELL CRAFTED
LEGISLATION. WITH ME HERE TODAY
IS DANIKA WITH INITIATE JUSTICE.
OUR WITNESSES OBVIOUSLY HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON, DANIKA
ODOM, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB
2833 AND MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
POLICY COALITION. AB 2833 REALLY
DOES SEEK TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESSES BY MAKING SURE THAT
THINGS THAT PEOPLE SHARE IN
THOSE PROCESSES CAN'T BE USED
AGAINST THEM IN FUTURE LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS. CALIFORNIA'S
INCREASINGLY RECOGNIZING THE
VALUE OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN
PROVIDING REAL ACCOUNTABILITY,
HEALING, AND CLOSURE IN WAYS
THAT WE KNOW THE TRADITIONAL
CRIMINAL LEGAL PROCESS CANNOT
DO. BUT OFTENTIMES PEOPLE CHOOSE
NOT TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORRIED THAT SOMETHING
THEY SHARE IN THOSE PROCESSES
MAY BE USED AGAINST THEM. AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE REALLY ONLY
WORKS WELL WHEN PEOPLE FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN BE TRULY OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT IN THE PROCESS. WE
KNOW FROM VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
THAT THAT IS WHAT ACTUALLY MAKES
THEM FEEL BEST. COMING OUT OF A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROCESS. IF
THEY FEEL LIKE THE PERSON WHO
CAUSED HARM THAT'S IN THE
PROCESS WITH THEM REALLY IS
TRULY ABLE TO BE HONEST WITH
THEM AND ACCOUNTABLE FOR HARM
THAT THEY MAY HAVE CAUSED. SO WE
HOPE THAT AB 2833 WILL ENCOURAGE
MORE PEOPLE TO TAKE PART IN
THESE PROCESSES. AND I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ON TO ME. TWOS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION, PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DAN
FELIZARDO, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ANTHONY DEMARTINO, ON BEHALF OF
CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE, PROUD
CO-SPONSORS, AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF ACLU IN SUPPORT. TATIANA
LEWIS WITH THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. PHIL
MELENDEZ, SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
SPEAKERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
MEMBERS, DO YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS, CONCERNS,
SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, DO I HAVE A
MOTION COURTESY SEEING NONE,
I'LL GIVE YOU A MOTION COURTESY.
OKAY, SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SARDO. CAN WE GET A ROLL
CALL? AB 2833. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY.
WAHAB A WAHAB I SATO. SATO. NOT
VOTING. BRADFORD. SKINNER.
WIENER. THAT BILL IS ON CALL. WE
CAN MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL.
THANK YOU, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 3127, A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
SURVIVORS CAN ACCESS HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BY CREATING A SURVIVOR
CENTERED TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACH AND LIMIT OF
NON-CONSENSUAL AND POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS REFERRALS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BY LIMITING
MANDATORY REPORTS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ONLY FIREARM AND
LIFE THREATENING INJURIES, WE
HAVE SEEN THE WAYS IN WHICH
MEDICAL MANDATED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL VIOLENT
INJURIES HAVE KEPT SURVIVORS.
SURVIVORS FROM SEEKING NECESSARY
HEALTH CARE IN THE FIRST PLACE,
MADE SURVIVORS FEEL LIKE THEY
COULD NEVER RETURN TO THE HEALTH
CARE TO HEALTH CARE AFTER THEY
LEARNED OF THE REQUIREMENT, OR
MADE THEM FEEL LIKE THEY COULD
NOT SHARE THE REASON FOR OR
EXTENT OF CERTAIN INJURIES OR
HEALTH ISSUES WITH THEIR
PROVIDERS. NOT ONLY DO THESE
REQUIREMENTS CREATE A BARRIER TO
HEALTH CARE, BUT MEDICALLY
MANDATED REPORTING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN RESULT IN
ESCALATING OF ABUSE, UNDUE CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT. SURVIVORS
THEMSELVES BEING CRIMINALIZED,
EXPOSED TO IMMIGRATION DETENTION
OR DEPORTATION, AND MORE. WITH
ME HERE TODAY IS CATALINA
COLLINS, A TRAUMA SURGERY AND
CRITICAL CARE FELLOW AT SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL. AND
I'M NOT GOING TO TRY DOCTOR, I'M
GOING TO LET YOU SAY YOUR NAME.
A PROGRAM MANAGER AT EUREKA.
GOOD AFTERNOON. HI THERE.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR CAITLIN COLLINS. I'M A
TRAUMA SURGEON IN CRITICAL CARE
INTENSIVIST AT SAN FRANCISCO
GENERAL HOSPITAL. OUR SAFETY NET
AND ONLY MAJOR TRAUMA HOSPITAL
IN SAN FRANCISCO. AS PART OF MY
JOB, I TREAT PATIENTS WHO'VE
SUFFERED INJURY FROM INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. OUR CURRENT
MANDATORY REPORTING LAWS
POSITION THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER BETWEEN THEIR LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PATIENT'S
EXPRESSED WISHES, NOT TO INVOLVE
THEM. THIS CONFLICT
RETRAUMATIZES PATIENTS AND
CAUSES MORAL DISTRESS FOR
PROVIDERS COUNTLESS TIMES I'VE
WITNESSED THE LOOK OF TERROR
THAT COMES ACROSS A VICTIM'S
FACE WHEN A POLICE OFFICER
ENTERS THE ROOM, THE FEAR IS
PALPABLE AND UNFORGETTABLE,
ESPECIALLY FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE
BLACK AND BROWN. LAST YEAR, I
CARED FOR LATINX MAN WITH A STAB
WOUND WHO WE STRONGLY SUSPECTED
HAD BEEN ASSAULTED BY HIS
INTIMATE PARTNER DURING MY
EVALUATION OF THE PATIENT, A
POLICE OFFICER ENTERED THE ROOM.
TEARS WELLED UP IN THE YOUNG
MAN'S FACE AND HE BEGAN TO
TREMBLE AS HE STUTTERED TO
ANSWER THE OFFICER'S QUESTIONS.
THIS PATIENT SUBSEQUENTLY
REFUSED ADMISSION TO THE
HOSPITAL, CITING HIS FEAR OF
FURTHER INTERROGATION AS HE
DEPARTED HASTILY. WE WERE UNABLE
TO PROVIDE HIM WITH HIGH QUALITY
CARE FOR HIS STAB WOUND, NOR
CONNECT HIM WITH ADVOCACY
SERVICES TO IMPROVE HIS SAFETY.
UNDER AB 3127, THE PATIENT MIGHT
HAVE FELT SAFER SEEKING CARE
BEFORE THE VIOLENCE ESCALATED.
WE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO OFFER
HIM A WARM HANDOFF TO COMMUNITY
BASED ADVOCACY SERVICES. IN
ADDITION TO OFFERING ASSISTANCE
WITH REPORTING THE INCIDENT TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND COORDINATING
A MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY HEARING. I
MEAN, EXAM, SORRY, THIS BILL IS
EVIDENCE BASED, CONSISTENT WITH
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE, AND DOES
NOT RESTRICT A PROVIDER FROM
HELPING A PATIENT ENGAGE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD THEY CHOOSE
IT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS AS
LEAD WITNESSES? LEAD WITNESSES?
GOOD AFTERNOON. I AM PRABHA
VISHWANATH THÀNH. I'M A PROGRAM
MANAGER AT NARIKA. WE ARE A
NONPROFIT BASED IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY SERVING SOUTH ASIAN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
ACROSS THE BAY AREA. I'M HERE
TODAY TO STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
3127. WHILE THE INTENTION BEHIND
MANDATORY REPORTING LAWS IS
OFTEN TO PROTECT VICTIMS AND
PREVENT FURTHER HARM IN SOUTH
ASIAN AND OTHER IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, IT CAN
INADVERTENTLY REMOVE THE
SURVIVORS AUTONOMY AND AGENCY
ASIDE FROM CULTURAL BARRIERS,
FINANCIAL BARRIERS AND FEAR OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, SURVIVORS MAY
FEAR THAT REPORTING COULD LEAD
TO UNWANTED CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS
RETALIATION FROM THE ABUSER AND
THEIR FAMILY, INVOLVEMENT OF THE
LEGAL SYSTEM, LOSING THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS, WHICH IN
TURN CAN RESULT IN LOSS OF CHILD
CUSTODY. A SOUTH ASIAN SURVIVOR
REACHED OUT TO NARIKA AFTER MANY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCING PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE AND MULTIPLE UNTREATED
INJURIES. BECAUSE SHE WAS AFRAID
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL FOR FEAR
OF REPORTING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT,
SHE HAD NOT SEEN HER PCP OR OB
GYN IN YEARS. THIS HAD LEFT HER
WITH NOT JUST UNTREATED INJURIES
, BUT ALSO COMPLICATIONS FROM
UNTREATED DIABETES AND OTHER
CHRONIC CONDITIONS, WHICH NEEDED
MEDICAL ATTENTION. THÀNH. THIS
STORY IS NOT UNIQUE. WE SEE THIS
HAPPEN FREQUENTLY. THEY ARE NOT
JUST MISSING OUT ON MEDICAL
RESOURCES, BUT ALSO CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC RESOURCES THAT THEY CAN
TAP INTO. MEDICAL PROVIDERS CAN
BE POWERFUL ALLIES FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. INSTEAD OF
MANDATED REPORTING REFERRALS TO
COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS CAN
HELP SURVIVORS GET RESOURCES,
REYES, AND SERVICES THAT THEY
CHOOSE TO ACCESS. REFERRALS TO
COMMUNITY BASED, CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE PARTNERS ASSIST THE
SURVIVORS IN GETTING LEGAL
CONSULTATION, EDUCATION ON DV
THERAPY SUPPORT, AND VARIOUS
OTHER SERVICES TO HELP THEM MAKE
AN INFORMED DECISION. WE BELIEVE
THAT SURVIVORS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SEPARATELY
FROM CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 3127. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, CAN I HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION? TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS KIM WALKER. I'M A LICENSED
REGISTERED NURSE IN CALIFORNIA
AND HAVE BEEN A SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINER OR SAFE FOR
THE LAST 20 YEARS. SAFE PROVIDE
THE TRAUMA INFORMED MEDICAL CARE
AND FORENSIC EVIDENCE COLLECTION
FOR SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
DOMESTIC INTIMATE, INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE, STRANGULATION
AND ABUSE ACROSS EVERY AGE
GROUP. I ALSO SERVE ON THE
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP BOARD FOR
CAL SAFE, WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINERS ASSOCIATION
THAT REPRESENTS THE 49 EXAM
TEAMS IN CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBERS
ARE DEDICATED TO PROVIDING THE
HIGHEST STANDARD OF MEDICAL
FORENSIC CARE AND ENSURING THAT
OUR PATIENTS ARE SUPPORTED,
BELIEVE AND APPROPRIATELY CARED
FOR. OUR MEMBERS ARE SPECIALLY
TRAINED TO DOCUMENT AND COLLECT
OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE OF HARM DONE
TO SURVIVORS, AND THESE ACTIONS
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TOOLS
USED BY BOTH CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
ATTORNEYS, SOCIAL WORKERS AND
ADVOCATES WHO ARE IN THEIR
SUPPORT. WE WANT TO KEEP
SURVIVORS SAFE AND THEIR
FAMILIES SAFE AND HOLD ABUSERS
ACCOUNTABLE. CAL SAFE STRONGLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL AS WRITTEN. WE
DO AGREE THAT THE RELEVANT PENAL
CODE SECTIONS FOR MANDATED
REPORTING NEED TO BE AMENDED TO
BETTER PROVIDE FOR SURVIVORS OF
ABUSE, BUT THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE
IN THIS BILL, IS A DANGEROUS
OVERREACH THAT WILL CREATE
CONFUSION AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN ITS APPLICATION.
AS WRITTEN, IT WILL IMPEDE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS FROM
ACTING IN SUPPORT OF SURVIVORS.
IT WILL LEAVE SURVIVORS WITHOUT
SUPPORT OF TRAUMA INFORMED IN
PERSON ADVOCATES. IT WILL MAKE
IT OPTIONAL FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IT WILL LEAVE THOSE
AT HIGHEST RISK VULNERABLE TO
THEIR ABUSER. IF PASSED AB 3127,
AS WRITTEN, WILL RESULT IN
FURTHER ROLLING BACK OF THE
SAFETY NET FOR AT RISK
POPULATIONS, MOST ESPECIALLY
WOMEN AND GIRLS ACROSS ALL
BACKGROUNDS. WE RECOGNIZE THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
THAT CAN BE MADE TO HEALTH CARE
MANDATED REPORTING, BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOUR
THE FAVOR OF YOUR OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD OPPOSITION? TWO MINUTES.
HI. MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
WINTERS HALL. I AM A FORENSIC
NURSE EXAMINER, A REGISTERED
NURSE AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE AT
ENLOE MEDICAL CENTER IN BUTTE
COUNTY. WE ARE A NONPROFIT LEVEL
TWO TRAUMA CENTER FOR THE
REGION. OUR CATCHMENT AREA IS
ALL THE RURAL COUNTIES. COLUSA
BUTTE, GLEN, TEHAMA AND PLUMAS
COUNTY AND SHASTA COUNTY. IN MY
ROLE, I AM ALSO THE SAFE
COORDINATOR FOR THE TEAM. IN MY
ROLE, MY PATIENTS ARE SURVIVORS
OF VIOLENT CRIME ALL DAY, EVERY
DAY. I AM A FORENSIC NURSE. ALL
DAY, EVERY DAY, THIS BILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS RURAL
CALIFORNIANS. AB 3127 ADVOCATES
FOR A WARM HANDOFF TO VICTIM
SERVICES. IT SAYS IT SIX TIMES
IN THE BILL. WARM HANDOFF TO
VICTIM SERVICES. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. BUT RURAL COMMUNITIES DO
NOT HAVE THESE RESOURCES. REYES
WE DO NOT HAVE A FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER. WE DO NOT HAVE A TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTER. WE DO NOT HAVE
RESOURCES FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
SURVIVOR OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CALLS FROM BUTTE COUNTY OR GLENN
COUNTY FOR SERVICES TO THE
NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE, THEY ARE TOLD TO CALL
THE POLICE OR GO TO THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE THE CLOSEST RESOURCES
FOR THEM ARE 90 MILES AWAY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. WE, OUR COUNTY
ONLY HAS ONE. IT'S A C  AGENCY
FOR DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AGENCY. THERE WONDERFUL. BUT
THEY CANNOT RESPOND TO THE
HOSPITAL. THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
FUNDING OR THE STAFFING TO
RESPOND TO THE HOSPITAL FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
FURTHERMORE, NOT ALL VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIME FALL INTO THE
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
CATEGORY. THERE ARE, SORRY,
VICTIMS OF GANG VIOLENCE.
THERE'S NO ADVOCACY AGENCY TO
TURN TO, TO TURN THEM OVER TO
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
DO WE HAVE ANY? ME TWOS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION?
LIEUTENANT HÌ DELEON FROM THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S OFFICE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WHITNEY
FRANCIS WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
ANTHONY DEMARTINO, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT DANICA
ADAMO, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE, ACLU, CAL ACTION AND
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. PHÐ MELENDEZ, SMART
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. KATE VAN
DER TAG ON BEHALF OF FUTURES
WITHOUT VIOLENCE AND THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS.
DISTRICT NINE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW,
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CLINIC.
VICTIMS EMPOWERMENT SUPPORT
TEAM, THE YWCA, GOLDEN GATE
VALLEY, SILICON VALLEY,
ANNICELLI FROM FUTURES WITHOUT
VIOLENCE. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL, ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMEN'S
COLLECTIVE EMPOWERMENT
INSTITUTE, CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS, PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA EAST LOS ANGELES
WOMEN'S CENTER AND POWER YOLO
FAMILY VIOLENCE APPELLATE
PROJECT, HEAL TRAFFICKING,
HEALTHY ALTERNATIVES TO VIOLENT
ENVIRONMENT, CGRTS, AND NEXT
DOOR SOLUTIONS TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU. SALLY CHANG
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR IN SUPPORT, ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S LAW
CENTER, STAND FOR FAMILIES FREE
OF VIOLENCE AND FAMILY VIOLENCE.
LAW CENTER, COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING,
COMMUNITY SOLUTIONS FOR CHILDREN
, FAMILIES, AND INDIVIDUALS,
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK, AND THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, AUSTIN D¯ÚI ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER SPEAKERS, CAN WE MOVE ON
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE?
SENATOR SATO, HI. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BILL, I HAD A QUESTION
REGARDING, ANY, YOU KNOW,
CREATING THIS LEGISLATION OR
THIS BILL, WERE THERE ANY
STUDIES THAT YOU WERE AWARE OF,
THAT OTHER, STATES HAVE TRIED
THIS BEFORE AND WHAT THE RESULTS
OF THAT WERE? I'M GOING TO BRING
UP SOME OF MY EXPERTS TO ANSWER.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, BUT CAN I
JUST RESPOND TO ONE OF THE COME
ON UP, ONE OF THE, THE ITEMS
THAT SOMEONE SAID ABOUT, THIS IS
ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, NOT
LIKE GANG VIOLENCE. SO I JUST
WANT TO CLEAR THAT UP, THAT THIS
IS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BILL. I'M
FAMILIAR WITH BOTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SO THERE HASN'T BEEN
A LARGE RANDOMIZED CONTROL
CONTROL, STUDY ON THIS ISSUE.
HOWEVER, THE ONLY OUTCOME STUDY
WAS A NATIONAL STUDY, FROM
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO
HAD EXPERIENCED MEDICAL MANDATED
REPORTING AND ONLY 17% SAID THAT
IT HAD BEEN OF ANY HELP TO THEM,
50% MADE IT SAID THAT IT MADE
THE SITUATION MUCH WORSE. 30%
SAID, THAT IT MADE IT SLIGHTLY
WORSE. AND THEN SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES SAID THAT IT DIDN'T
IMPROVE OR CHANGE A SITUATION.
SO THAT'S THE ONLY OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATED WITH, THE RESULT OF
MEDICAL MANDATED REPORTING. OKAY
KENTUCKY IS A STATE THAT
ELIMINATED HEALTH CARE,
MANDATORY REPORTING ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO. AND THEY'VE HAD A 63%
INCREASE IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATHS. DOES THAT FRIGHTEN
ANYBODY? FRIGHTENS ME, AS I WAS
A MANDATORY REPORTER, AS YOU
KNOW, IN THE HEALTH CARE FIELD,
IT'S AN UNCOMFORTABLE THING TO
BE IN, AND THE, THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE BEING SUBJECTED TO THE
VIOLENCE, OF COURSE, THEY'RE
ALSO AFRAID TO SAY ANYTHING
BECAUSE THEY'RE ONLY PROTECTED
FOR SO LONG, BEFORE SOMETHING
BAD HAPPENS TO THEM. AND SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN ABOUT THIS
APPROACH, IS THAT, THERE IS NO
TRACK RECORD OF THIS, AND THE
ONLY ONE THAT I'VE FOUND IS NOT
VERY GOOD. AND KNOWING THE,
DURESS THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE SUBJECTED TO THIS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, ARE THAT THEY'RE
UNDER, THAT THEY'RE ALREADY NOT
WANTING TO SAY A WORD TO ANYBODY
. AND THEIR ONLY PROTECTION IS
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO RESPOND
TO THEIR INCIDENT SAYING
SOMETHING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
THEY CAN AT LEAST INVESTIGATE
WHAT IS GOING ON. AND, YOU KNOW,
WHILE THAT DOES, CREATE SOME
PROBLEMS FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THE DOMESTIC ABUSERS, I THINK I
HAVE TO ON THE SIDE OF CAUTION,
WHICH IS THE PERSON BEING
SUBJECTED TO THAT ABUSE, WHETHER
THEY WANT HELP OR NOT, I WOULD
RATHER THEM GET HELP OR AT LEAST
HAVE IT INVESTIGATED, RATHER
THAN GOING ON THE SAME PERSON
THÀNH A WEEK OR TWO LATER, ONLY
THIS TIME THEY'RE DEAD, SO, SO
YEAH, I'LL BE OPPOSING THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE OF THOSE CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE. AND, BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS IN
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE
BEING SUBJECTED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. ACTUALLY HAD ANOTHER
WITNESS ABOUT. TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. I'M SO SORRY. ON THE
STUDY. WILL YOU ALLOW, MADAM
CHAIR? THANKS YEAH. THANK YOU.
SO, WITH REGARDS TO THE CASE IN
KENTUCKY. SO WE, THE CO-SPONSOR
GROUP OF AB 3127 HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE FOLKS IN
KENTUCKY THAT WERE, WORKING ON
PASSING THAT LAW. AND WE TALKED
TO THEM SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THAT
ISSUE OF THE DV HOMICIDE RATES.
AND, YOU KNOW, THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF OTHER FACTORS THAT
HAPPENED ACROSS THE STATE THAT
IT'S, YOU KNOW, IT'S A
REDUCTIONIST TO EQUATE THE
INCREASE IN DV HOMICIDE RATES
WITH THE CHANGE OF THAT LAW.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE WERE HAPPY TO
ALSO FOLLOW UP WITH MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT. BUT
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF OTHER
FACTORS THAT WERE HAPPENING IN
THE STATE THAT WERE CONTRIBUTING
TO THE DV HOMICIDE RATES, NOT AS
DIRECTLY AS A RESULT OF THAT
LAW. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THAT EXPLANATION, BUT IT STILL
DOES NOT ALLEVIATE MY CONCERN
THAT SOME OF THAT 63% IS FROM
THE ELIMINATION OF THE PERSON
THAT IS INFLICTING THE VIOLENCE
ON SOMEBODY IS NOT BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE OR AT LEAST GETTING
TREATMENT. SO THAT THEY
DISCONTINUE THE PRACTICE OF
INJURING SOMEBODY, MAYBE
KENTUCKY HAS STRONGER BOURBON,
AND THAT'S CONTRIBUTING TO IT, I
DON'T KNOW. SO ANYWAY, THANK
YOU, THOUGH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXPLANATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
SENATOR, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I WANT TO REALLY THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR PERSEVERANCE ON
THIS, ISSUE. I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
FEW YEARS NOW, THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL, I THINK I
COAUTHORED THE LAST VERSION OF
IT, AND I KNOW IT'S A IT'S A
TOUCHY SUBJECT, AND I KNOW IT'S
EASY TO, FOR THE OPPOSITION TO,
YOU KNOW, TO FOCUS ON THE ON THE
JUST HORRIFIC REALITY OF, OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, BUT WE'RE,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE RISKING PUTTING
PEOPLE IN AN EVEN WORSE
SITUATION. AND IT ALSO TAKES
AWAY THE AGENCY OF FOLKS WHO ARE
VICTIMS, TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS FOR
THEMSELVES AND, AND TO PUT
PEOPLE IN A POSITION WHERE THEY
KNOW THAT IF THEY SEEK TREATMENT
, THEY'RE AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO
INVOLVE LAW ENFORCEMENT, EVEN IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO OR, OR IT
PUTS THEIR LIFE AT RISK. THAT'S
JUST NOT SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
CONDONING. SO I'M HAPPY TO. IF
THERE HASN'T BEEN A MOTION, THEN
I'LL THANK YOU. I'LL MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES, JUST JUST A FEW
WORDS. I HAD A RELATIVE, A
COUSIN THAT, GOT BEAT UP BY HER
BOYFRIEND MAYBE ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO. NOTHING LIKE THIS HAD EVER
HAPPENED IN MY FAMILY. IT WAS
HORRIBLE. BUT SHE WAS. SHE FELT
COMFORTABLE TO GO TO THE DOCTOR.
BUT THEN AS WE AS SHE TOOK HER
TREATMENTS AND SHE STARTED TO GO
TO THESE ORGANIZATIONS AND SEEK
THERAPY ABOUT IT, WE FOUND OUT
THAT IT'S MANY, LOTS AND LOTS OF
WOMEN THAT DO NOT GO TO THE
DOCTOR. THEY BREAK THEIR ARM AND
THEY KEEP THEIR ARM IN A SLING
AND IT JUST STAYS BROKEN. AND IT
IT MEANS THAT WAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THEIR SPOUSE IS GOING TO AFTER
AFTER THE DOCTOR, CALLS THE
POLICE, MAYBE THE POLICE PICKS
THE HUSBAND UP, MAYBE NOT. BUT
IF THEY PICK HIM UP AND HE GETS
LET OUT AND COME BACK HOME AND
SHE'S STILL THERE, SHE REALLY,
SHE GETS BEAT UP EVEN MORE. AND
SO THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
BILL. AND, I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. AND I KNOW THAT WE ALL
JUST REALLY, REALLY WANT TO
PROTECT THE VICTIMS AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER AB
3127 MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I HAVE A
SEYARTO. SATO. NO. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. WIENER WIENER. I THANK
YOU THAT BILLS ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL AND
SENATOR SATO IS GOING TO TAKE
OVER. THANK YOU. LET'S START
FROM FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB 1779. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS ONE TO OH NO. 3
TO 0 AB 1779 IRWIN WIENER Ã
WIENER I 4040. ARE WE GOING TO
KEEP IT OPEN? NO. WE'RE DONE,
WE'RE DONE. YOU'RE THE ZERO. OH
THAT'S RIGHT. SORRY ITEM TWO AB
1794 MCCARTY. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 0. WIENER Ã WIENER
I ZERO. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS
OUT. ITEM THREE, AB 1802. JONES,
JOAN. SAWYER. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 0. WIENER Ã WIENER I.
THAT BILL HAS FOUR VOTES. IT'S
OUT. ITEM FOUR AB 1810. BRIAN.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WIENER Ã WIENER I THAT
BILL HAS FIVE VOTES. IT'S OUT.
ITEM FIVE AB 2215 BRIAN. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO THE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1. WIENER
Ã WIENER I. THAT BILL IS OUT
WITH FOUR VOTES, 4 TO 1, 4 TO 1.
CONSENT CALENDAR WIENER I WIENER
I50. BILL IS OUT FIVE. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED
FIVE ZERO ITEM SEVEN AB 1814
TING. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. WIENER
Ã WIENER I BILL IS OUT WITH THE
FIVE ZERO VOTE. ITEM TEN AB 1960
SORIA MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT. BEFORE
YOU CALL THE ROLL, I JUST WANT
TO SAY SOMETHING. OKAY. OR
UNLESS YOU. OH, NO, I'M GOING TO
BE VOTING AYE ON THIS BILL. THIS
IS NOT TYPICALLY A BILL THAT I
WOULD, SUPPORT, BUT WE ARE, YOU
KNOW, WORK WORKING WITH A
NETWORK OF BILLS TO ADDRESS
RETAIL THEFT, SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. I RESERVE MY
RIGHT TO, TO, TO POTENTIALLY NOT
SUPPORT IT ON THE FLOOR. SO
WIENER I WIENER I. THAT BILL IS
OUT 4 TO 0. ITEM 12 AB 3209
BERMAN MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0 WIENER I WIENER I THAT
BILL IS OUT 4 TO 0. ITEM 13 AB
2295 ADDIS MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. SATO I, SATO I WIENER I
WIENER I FILLS OUT THAT BILL IS
OUT 5 TO 0. MAYBE ITEM 14 WAS
PULLED. SENATOR, JUST SO YOU
KNOW. OKAY YES. ITEM 14 IS
PULLED. ITEM 15 AB 26 TO 24.
WALDRON. MOTION WAS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. SATO I,
SATO I WIENER I WIENER I THAT
BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0. ITEM 16.
ITEM 16 IS AB 2681. WEBER.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 0. SATO I, SATO I WIENER
I WIENER I. THAT BILL IS OUT 5
TO 0. ITEM 18 AB 2739
MAIENSCHEIN MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. OH NO. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. SATO NOT VOTING. SATO.
NOT VOTING. WIENER I WIENER I
ZERO. PERFECT TIMING THAT ITEM
IS OUT 4 TO 0. ITEM 19 AB 2833
MCKINNEY. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING. NOT VOTING BRADFORD I
BRADFORD I SKINNER. SKINNER I
WIENER I'M SORRY, WHICH ONE WAS
IT? ITEM 19. SKINNER. THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE I WIENER I
THAT BILL IS OUT 4 TO 0. ITEM 20
AB 3127 MCKINNEY. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS CHAIR I VICE CHAIR NO.
BRADFORD WHICH ONE IS THIS ITEM?
ITEM 20 BRADFORD I SKINNER.
SKINNER. I 4 TO 1. THAT BILL IS
OUT 4 TO 1 ITEM 21 AB 2842
PAPPIN MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. SATO I, SATO I WIENER I
WIENER I ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT
5 TO 0. ITEM 22 AB 2943 ZUBIATE
ACTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. WIENER I WIENER I BILL
IS OUT 4 TO 0 AND LET'S SEE.
ITEM 24 AB 3077 HEART MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1 WIENER I
WIENER I I'M BILL IS OUT 4 TO 0
AND ITEM 25 4 TO 1 I'M SORRY.
YEAH. 4 TO 1. MY BAD ITEM 25 AK
EIGHT WILSON. MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AND RE REFERRED TO
ELECTIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO
0. SATO. OUR NO SATO. NO WIENER
Ã WIENER I 4 TO 1, 4 TO 1. AND
THAT BILL IS OUT. 4 TO 1. WE
ADJOURNED. OKAY. AND I BELIEVE
THAT TAKES CARE OF EVERY ALL OUR
BILLS. SO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU. LET MY PEOPLE GO.